FOR THE SENATE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
ON EDUCATION- WILL COME TO ORDER
I'M GOING TO GO THROUGH OUR
USUAL INSTRUCTIONS HERE BECAUSE
WE STILL ARE TAKING PRECAUTIONS
TO MANAGE THE ONGOING COVERT
NINETEEN RHYS- WE WANT TO
WELCOME THE PUBLIC AND PROVIDE
ACCESS FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE. I WILL BE POSTED-
ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN THERE IT
IS ALL ANNOUNCES NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE SIX THREE AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SEVEN THREE SIX TWO
EIGHT THREE THREE. I WILL MAIN
TO MAINTAIN DECORUM A DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THE
CONNECTIONS MADE. WE'RE HOLDING
OUR SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE
IN THE- STREET BUILDING I ASK
ALL SUBMIT THE SUB COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO BE PRESENT IN TWENTY.
OR ONE HUNDRED UP SENATOR
MINUTES HERE SENATOR- CHAU BOGUS
EXPECTED SHORTLY. ARE THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE ALSO
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR A
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK AND LASTED
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED. THAT YOU USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE PLEASE
SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING OUR- INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY PERSONNEL WILL PUT
YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU ARE
DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK
PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT YOU CAN BE
SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR
NAME AND THEN YOU'RE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. A TO
ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. A PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL BE HEARD AFTER ALL
DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED. AND WE ARE HAVING A
SECTION OF THE HEARING THE FIRST
ONE ON HIGHER EDUCATION THE
SECOND SECTION OF THE HEARING.
IS ON OUR K. THROUGH TWELVE. AND
WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT. ON
EITHER OF THOSE AFTER BOTH THOSE
SECTIONS OF THE AGENDA ARE
COMPLETE- TODAY IS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE PROPOSALS
IN EDUCATION. THIS FOLLOWS OUR
LAST HEARING WHICH- HEARD SENATE
PROPOSALS SO WE WILL BE ABLE TO
SEE THE TWO TOGETHER. R. WE'RE
GOING TO FIRST DISCUSS HIGHER
EDUCATION. AND I AM GOING TO-
MAKE SOME OPENING COMMENTS
BECAUSE I WANTED TO SET THE
STAGE FOR EXPECTATIONS GOING
FORWARD OVER THE COMING WEEKS.
AS WE HEARD MULTIPLE TIMES IN
SUB COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE AND WE
HAD HEARINGS IN FEBRUARY ON UC
CSU AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
THEN THE ONE I REFERRED TO. THAT
WAS LAST WEEK. THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMPACTS WITH UC AND
CSU AND ROAD MAP WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
REPRESENT AGREEMENT. BETWEEN THE
SEGMENTS AND THE ADMINISTRATION
WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE INPUT. ARE
WE AGREE WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OVERALL EMPHASIS IN THE COMPACTS
BUT I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCHES THE BRANCH
THAT APPROPRIATES FUNDING AND
GOVERNMENT SPENDING DECISIONS
WITHOUT SUFFICIENT RESOURCES AND
DELIBERATE DECISIONS THE
SEGMENTS WILL BE UNABLE TO HIT
THE EXPECTATIONS SET FORTH. TO
THE DISADVANTAGE OF FACULTY
STAFF AND ULTIMATELY THE
STUDENTS. ARE QUESTIONS
THROUGHOUT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
PROCESS AND STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT INFORMED OUR FUNDING
RECOMMENDATIONS AND IDENTIFIED
HOW WE CAN PROVIDE DIRECTION AND
STRUCTURE TO STRENGTHEN THOSE
AGREEMENTS IN THE- IN THE BUDGET
HERE AND IN THE OUT YEARS. ARE
WE BELIEVE THAT THE CONTACTS
DON'T GO FAR ENOUGH IN CERTAIN
AREAS WHEREAS THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES. BLANKET 5% INCREASES
FOR UC AND CSU TO MEET THE
COMPACT GOALS THE SENATE
PROPOSES TEN AND 14% TARGETED
INCREASES RESPECTIVELY. THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES NO
INCREASES FOR THE ALREADY
OVERSUBSCRIBED STUDENT HOUSING
GRANT PROGRAM. IMAGE ONE THE
SENATE PROPOSES AN ADDITIONAL
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AND TWENTY TWENTY
THREE WHEREAS THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES MODEST. INCREASES FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE CAPITAL
OUTLAY MODERNIZATION ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROJECTS AND STUDENT
SUPPORT PROGRAM THE SENATE'S
PLAN GOES MUCH FURTHER. ARE
THESE ADDITIONS FOR STUDENT
SUPPORT FINANCIAL AID UNDER
REPRESENTED STUDENT OUTREACH.
YLIDES AND RESOURCES FOR FACULTY
AND STAFF ARE DESIGNED TO MAKE
THE COMPACT STRONGER AND MORE
COMPREHENSIVE- WE VIEW THAT
SENATE'S PLAN. HAS A COMPAQ'S
PLUS WE WERE THE PUSH FOR THAT
IN THE WEEKS AND I WILL MAKE A
SIMILAR STATEMENT OF COMPARISON.
ARE ABOUT THE K. TO TWELVE
PORTION OF THE HEARING WHEN WE
GET TO THAT STAGE. SO I JUST
WANTED TO START OVER WITH THAT
LEVEL. OF CLARITY- SENATOR MEANT
TO HAVE ANY OPENING COMMENTS.
OKAY THEN WE ARE GOING TO MOVE-
TO ISSUE NUMBER ONE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMPACTS WITH. A UC
AND CSU AND THE ROAD MAP WITH
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM OUR
PANEL WILL BE REBEKAH KIRK FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
JENNIFER PURCELL UP FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
FIJA VIRTON AND FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WAS AT
NAVARETTE FROM THE- COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND
RYAN STORM FROM THE CALIFORNIA.
STATE UNIVERSITY I KNOW WE HAVE
CHRIS FERGUSON FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON STAND
BY FOR QUESTIONS WILL GO IN THAT
ORDER AND WILL BEGIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. THANK YOU- IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN JANUARY
WE ANNOUNCED COMPACT AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY AS
WELL AS THE ROAD MAP AGREEMENT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. SINCE THOSE AGREEMENTS
WERE ANNOUNCED WE HAVE CONTINUED
WORKING WITH EACH SEGMENT OF
PUBLIC POST SECONDARY EDUCATION-
FIND SPECIFIC METRICS. TO
MEASURE THE PROGRESS TOWARD THE
GOALS AND COMMITMENTS
ARTICULATED IN THOSE CONTACTS
OVER THE COMING YEARS. THAT WILL
BEGIN WITH ANNUAL REPORTING
STARTING LATER THIS YEAR FROM
EACH SEGMENT ON SPECIFIC ACTIONS
THAT THEY HAVE PLANS TO ACHIEVE
THESE GOALS. THEIR PROGRESS
TOWARD THOSE ACTIONS
SPECIFICALLY QUANTIFYING AND
MEASURING THE PROGRESS THAT THEY
HAVE ACHIEVED. AS WELL AS- AS
WELL AS THEIR STRATEGIC
COLLABORATIONS WITH THEIR INNER
SIGNAL PARTNERS ADVANCING
PERFORMANCE OUTCOMES AND
BENEFITING STUDENTS OR GREATER
AND SIGNAL COOPERATION. THESE
CONTACTS AND THE ROAD MAP ARE
DISCREET GRIEVANCE BETWEEN
ADMINISTRATION EACH SEGMENT
HOWEVER THERE'S A LOT OF OVERLAP
AND COMPLEMENTARY GOALS. BROADLY
SPEAKING THOSE GOALS WHICH TAXED
ON THIS COMMITTEE AND THE PAST
INCLUDED ENSURING THAT WE ARE
MEETING THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS IN THE WORKFORCE OF THE
FUTURE WE'RE CLOSING EQUITY GAPS
BETWEEN STUDENTS WHO ARE
UNDERREPRESENTED. LOW INCOME OR
DISABLED AND THEIR PEERS AND
THEY WERE BETTER POSITIONING
CALIFORNIA TO MEET THE STATE'S
70% POSTSECONDARY DEGREE AND
CERTIFICATE TEAMMATE COLE.
REGARDING YOUR COMMENTS AT THE
BEGINNING STRUCTURE WE CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE AND APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE'S ROLE. IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS OF COURSE THE
FUNDING ASSOCIATED WITH BOTH THE
CONTACTS. AND THE ROAD MAP IN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS BUT
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS
FUNDING THE REVISION. OUR
COMPONENTS THAT WOULD BE ACTED
UPON BY THE LEGISLATURE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
DISCUSSION AROUND THAT PROPOSED
FUNDING. THE CONTACTS ON THE
ROADMAP THEMSELVES ARE NOW
AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE AND
HAVE BEEN SHARED WITH THE
COMMITTEE. SO WE ARE HAPPY TO BE
SHARING THE ADDITIONAL DETAIL
AND METRICS AT THIS TIME. I AM
PLEASED TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WILL
MOVE ON TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. JENNIFER
BETULA FROM THE L. A. ELVES SO-
FACT CONTAINS SOME OF THE
COMMENTS OF THE CHAIR THE
NEIGHBOR VISION CHANGES TO THE
COMPACTS AND ROADMAP THEY DON'T
ADDRESS ANY OF THE CONCERNS WE
RAISED WITH THE PLANS BACK IN
JANUARY. THEY STILL HAVE MANY
MANY EXPECTATIONS EVEN MORE NOW
THERE ARE STILL ON
INCONSISTENCIES ACROSS THE
STATEMENTS NO SPECIFIC COST
ESTIMATES NO CLEAR
REPERCUSSIONS. WHERE THE
SEGMENTS NOT TO MEET THE
EXPECTATIONS AND STILL NO DIRECT
PRODUCTIVE ENGAGEMENT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. ARE YOU HEARD ABOUT
THE NEW RECORDING A PROGRESS
REPORT THAT THE STATEMENTS WOULD
BE ASKED TO DELIVER BUT THAT
WOULDN'T BE QUALIFIED. SO IT'S
AN INFORMAL AGREEMENT BETWEEN
ADMINISTRATION AND THE SEGMENTS.
OF THE LEGISLATURE IF YOU WOULD
LIKE MORE INFORMATION ON THE
PERFORMANCE OF THE STATEMENT
SOME PARTICULAR AREAS. YOU COULD
DECIDE WHAT AREAS YOU WANT TO
SEE IMPROVEMENTS AN AND THEN
HAVE A CORRESPONDING REPORTING
REQUIREMENT AND BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE OR TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. CODIFYING THE
REQUIREMENT WOULD. PROMOTE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
. SEVEN BUCKS FOR A MOMENT YOU
ON THE JUST FOR ARCH POINT AS
YOU MAY YOUR WAY THROUGH THAT
OTHER ISSUES THIS MORNING ON
YOUR AGENDA AS YOU ULTIMATELY
BELCHER EDUCATION BUDGET
PACKAGE. JUST WANTED A FEW TO
SHARE A FEW PIECES OF
INFORMATION FOR CONTACTS. WHILE
THE STATE FOR PROCESS VERY LARGE
THIS YEAR THERE ARE ECONOMIC
SIGNS SUGGESTING A HEIGHTENED
RISK OF A RECESSION GDP HOME
SALES CONSUMER CONFIDENCE.
THEY'RE ALL WEAK INFLATION IS
HIGH THE LABOR MARKET IS TIGHT.
IN THE PAST SUCH SIGNS HAVE BEEN
FOLLOWED BY RECESSIONS. SO
BUILDING RESERVE EVELS ABOVE
THE MAY REVISION LEVELS WOULD
HELP YOU SUSTAIN ONGOING
PROGRAMS OR THE STATE TO ENSURE
RECESSION. THE SAY ALSO IS
FACING SEVERAL SIGNIFICANT
CONSTITUTIONAL BUDGET
REQUIREMENTS OPPOSITION FOR
RELATING TO THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT PROPS TO
RELATING TO BUDGET.
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT PROP
NINETY EIGHT RELATED TO K.
FOURTEEN FUNDING ALL PLACE
CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENTS ON
THE STATE. THE MEMBERS LAMBS AN
UNADDRESSED ALL REQUIREMENT OF
THREE POINT FOUR BILLION IN-
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE WHICH WE
ESTIMATE GROWS TO ANOTHER TWENTY
BILLION DOLLAR ISSUE AND TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR. BY COMPARISON
WE ESTIMATE THE STATE WILL HAVE
A SURPLUS IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR OF ONE POINT SIX BILLION SO
LEAVING A LARGE PROJECTED BUDGET
GAP NEXT YEAR. THIS MEANS THAT
ONGOING PROGRAMS COULD BE AT
RISK RIGHT AROUND THE CORNER. SO
WE JUST THOUGHT YOU MIGHT WANT
TO KEEP THESE FACTORS IN MIND AS
YOU SELECT AMONG THE MANY BUDGET
PROPOSALS BEFORE YOU AND DECIDE
ON THE BEST MIX OF ON GOING A
ONE TIME SPENDING. HAVE AN
ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WILL MOVE TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR LETTER TO MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY AND SAY
OVER TEN AND REPRESENTING
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTS GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
PROPOSAL TO STRENGTHEN AND
BETTER SERVE STUDENTS THROUGH A
FIVE YEAR FUNDING COMPACT THAT
OFFERS RELIABLE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT. FOR OUR CAMPUSES
COUPLED WITH AMBITIOUS YOUR
GOALS. RELIABLE ONGOING STATE
FUNDING INCLUDES INCREASES
TOGETHER WITH OUR TUITION
STABILITY PLAN ARE IMPORTANT TO
UC CAMPUSES AND COVERING THE
COST INCREASES. AND ENSURING
STUDENT SUCCESS THROUGH MORE
COURSE OFFERINGS ADVISING AND
OTHER SERVICES. WE FULLY SUPPORT
THE SHARED GOALS ARTICULATED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED COMPACT
WHICH FOCUS ON ACCESS SUCCESS
AFFORDABILITY AND INTER
SEGMENTAL COLLABORATION. THE
UNIVERSITY CECE'S GOALS OUTLINED
IN THE MULTI YOUR CONTACT AS A
CONVERSATION BETWEEN THE
GOVERNOR LEGISLATURE AND
UNIVERSITY. ON THE WAY USED TO
ACHIEVE THE OUTLINED AMBITIOUS
GOALS EACH YEAR AT THE
UNIVERSITY WILL TAKE STEPS
TOWARDS THESE GOALS WHICH
REPRESENT THE IDEALS WE WOULD
ALL LIKE TO SEE A CHEAT. THE
COMPACT INCLUDES ANNUAL
COMPREHENSIVE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND IN ADDITION TO
ENSURE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
FEELS COMFORTABLE WITH THE
UNIVERSITIES PROGRESS TOWARDS
YOUR GOALS. WE WOULD PROVIDE
BRIEFINGS TO LEGISLATORS AND
THEIR STAFF. WE WELCOME
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE LEGISLATURE IN CAPITAL
OUTLAY FUNDING ENROLLMENT AND
THE REGION'S REQUEST FOR STUDENT
SERVICES AND HEALTH EDUCATION
AND RESEARCH FUNDING. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU
ARE. AND WILL MOVE TO THE
COMMUNITY CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN LAYERED ON
MEMBERS OF THE AFFECTED SUB
COMMITTEE WAS EVER AT- SECOND
LICENSE OF THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
COLLEGES I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR OPENING COMMENTS ABOUT THE
SOME OF THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT
STILL REMAIN AHEAD IN THIS
BUDGET IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
I'M GOING TO COVER AND THREE
AREAS OF ALIGNMENT. IN TWO AREAS
OF OPPORTUNITY- THAT- ARE
AVAILABLE TO US IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET AS WELL- AS ALIGNMENT
WITH THE SENATE'S PRIORITIES THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED ROADMAP TO
CALIFORNIA'S ME COLLEGES ONLINE
TO THE VISION FOR SUCCESS GOALS
THEY CREATE NEW AVENUES FOR DATA
SHARING WITH THEIR UC AND CSU
PARTNERS. CREATE CROSS SYSTEM
COLLABORATION FIND RESOURCES IN
KEY AREAS MANY OF WHICH HAVE-
ARE ECHOING THE LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES FROM PRIOR YEARS MORE
IMPORTANTLY TO HELP US AS A
SYSTEM CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON
CLOSING RACIAL EQUITY GAPS. AND
SUPPORTING STUDENT SUCCESS. WHAT
TO APPROACH THAT'S IN. IN THE
MAY REVISION AROUND A PORTION
MEN'S AND STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA WE- APPLIED THE
APPROACH THAT REALLY LOOKS AT
ELEVATING PER STUDENT FUNDING
FOR STUDENTS RECOGNIZING THAT-
BY PROVIDING HIGHER RATES. AND A
BASE INCREASES STUDENTS YOU'RE
NOT ONLY- ELEVATING KEY
COMPONENTS AND TENANTS OF THE
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA
BUT ENSURING THAT DISTRICTS
CONTINUE TO DO THE RIGHT THING
FOR STUDENTS HELPING THEM
PROGRESS ON THEIR JOURNEY TO AN
EDUCATIONAL GOAL BE A TRANSFER.
DEGREE ATTAINMENT SKILLS
DEVELOPMENT- OCCURRED ARE
DECREASED YOUR CREDENTIALS SO WE
DO THINK THAT IF THERE ARE
AREAS- OF FURTHER INVESTMENT
ADDING TO THE BASE FOR RATES-
ISN'T. A VALID APPROACH. NOW AND
A LOT OF WILL APPROACH. LAST I
WANT TO HIRE- SYSTEM TO PASS
THAT ADDED- TO. GOVERNOR'S ON
MAY REVISION BY ADDING TWENTY
SIX POSITIONS FOR THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE THESE
POSITIONS HELP US IN SUPPORTING
DISTRICTS AND COLLEGES AND
ENSURING THAT WE CAN CONTINUE.
REMAINING ON TRACK WITH THE
GOALS AND THE DELIVERABLES THAT
ARE EXPECTED BY THE LEGISLATURE
BY THE ADMINISTRATION AND BY OUR
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE AS
A SYSTEM WE'VE IN HARD- A MAJOR
INCREASE IN PROGRAMS THAT WE
ADMINISTER IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
ADMINISTERED FIFTY NINE PROGRAMS
WE'RE NOW UP TO A HUNDRED. AND
FIVE- WITH LIMITED POSITIONS
ADDED IN THESE- POSITIONS AGAIN
ENSURE THAT NEED CAN PROVIDE
DELIVERABLES THE KEY INFORMATION
THAT OUR STATE LEADERS NEED TO
MAKE IMPORTANT. DECISIONS SUCH
AS BUDGETARY ONCE. HELLO I WANT
TO HIGH- THE COMMENTS AROUND
HOUSING WE DO BELIEVE THAT NOW
IS THE PERFECT TIME WITH ONE
TIME RESOURCES TO INVEST IN
CUISINE. AND INVESTMENT OF THAT-
IN BOTH THEIR PROPOSED AN
ELIGIBLE PROJECTS- WOULD NEARLY
DOUBLE THE NUMBER OF BEDS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. LASTLY WE
URGE YOU TO CONTINUE YOUR
EFFORTS AROUND CAL GRANT AND CAL
GRANT REFORMS WHILE THERE WERE
SOME LAUDABLE INCREASES LAST
YEAR WE KNOW THAT THIS SYSTEM OF
CAL GRANTS NOT GET SIMPLIFIED
ENOUGH FOR FAMILIES. AND ACROSS
THE STATE STUDENTS CONTINUE TO
MENTION FINANCIAL AID ACCESS IS
ONE OF THEIR PRIMARY BARRIERS TO
SUCCESS WE HOPE THAT YOU WILL
TAKE THIS TIME AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE TO REFORM CAL GRANTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JIM LEHRER.
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND NOW WILL
MOVE ON TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM- GOOD MORNING-
CHAIRED LAYERED AND SANDERS. I
THINK YOU SHOULD ALERT FOR THOSE
OPENING COMMENTS ABOUT THE
CONTACT PLUS MUCH APPRECIATED HI
MY NAME IS RYAN STORE I AM THE
ASSISTANT VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
BUDGET FOR THE CSU OFFICE OF THE
CHANCELLOR. NOW THE CONTACT IS
AN IMPORTANT MILESTONE FOR
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY SEE ISSUES
FINANCIAL SUSTAINABILITY AND
PREDICTABILITY. AND WE VIEW THIS
CONTACT AS A CRITICAL SAFETY NET
TO PROTECT THE UNIVERSITY
UNIVERSITY FROM ECONOMIC
FLUCTUATIONS OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS. WE ARE GRATEFUL TO THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR ADDITIONS TO
THE REVISED COMPACT THOSE ARE
STATEMENTS OF OPENNESS PROVIDING
MORE ON GOING AND ONE TIME
FUNDING TO THE C. ISSUE TO THE
EXTENT STATE REVENUE THAT'S
AVAILABLE. WE'RE ALSO
APPRECIATIVE OF THE ON GOING AND
WHAT TIME FUNDING THAT GOVERNOR
NEWSOM PROPOSED IN JANUARY AND
THAT HE CONTINUED IN THE MEMBER
NATION. WE SEE THOSE AS GOOD AS
A GOOD START. THAT'S THE
QUESTION POSED IN THE AGENDA IS
THE AMOUNT IN THE MAY REVISION
ENOUGH. THE ANSWER IS THAT IT
WILL NOT FUND ALL OF THE
UNIVERSITIES NEEDS IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. FRANKLY THIS ISSUE
COULD ONLY COVER SOME OF ITS
MANDATORY COSTS AND ONLY SOME OF
OUR ANTICIPATED EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION COSTS CONTAINED IN
THE TRUSTEES BUDGET REQUEST. AND
WE CANNOT FIND MANY OF OUR OTHER
PRIORITIES IN THE BUDGET CRISIS
LIKE GRADUATION ISSUED ANOTHER
CAPITAL IN OUR CAPITAL OUTLAY
PLAN. AS WE CONTINUE TO ASK FOR
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS OF ONGOING FUNDING ABOVE
THE GOVERNOR'S. PROPOSAL FOR
THINGS SUCH AS FAIR AND
EQUITABLE COMPENSATION FOR
FACULTY AND STAFF. WE SEE TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS OF ON GOING FUNDING TO
IMPLEMENT THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE STAFF SALARY STUDY. THAT
CAME OUT RECENTLY. THE STUDY
REVEALED MAJOR FINDINGS IN THE
AREAS OF COMPETITIVE MARKET
SALARY STRUCTURE JOB FRAMEWORK
AND PREDICTABLE AND IT WILL PAY
FOR OUR STAFF EMPLOYEES CSU.
ALSO READ WE REQUEST NINE
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TYPE FUNDING
TO HELP. US REPAIR AND MODERNIZE
OUR AGING FACILITIES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. UNLESS YOU WILL
NOTICE THAT THE SENATE'S APRIL
BUDGET PLAN WHICH ADDRESS MUCH
OF THOSE NEEDS. AND WE ARE VERY
THANKFUL FOR- YOU ALIGNING YOUR
PARTIES WITH THIS ISSUES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
QUESTIONS- OF THE COMMITTEE IN.
OF THERE WAS ONE QUESTION IN THE
AGENDA PACKET THAT ARE THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM CS YOU JUST.
ANSWERED WHICH IS- IS THE AMOUNT
INCLUDED IN THE MAY REVISION
ENOUGH TO COVER THE ONGOING COST
PRESSURES AT YOUR CAMPUSES IN
UPHOLD THE AGREEMNTS. ARE IN
THE COMPACTS AND ROAD MAPS THAT
WOULD BE PUT THAT TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
THEN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. AND BEGIN
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU CENTER
LAYERED- THE PROPOSED AMOUNT IN
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION IS
SLIGHTLY LESS THAN THE AMOUNT
THAT WAS REQUESTED BY THE
REGENTS- SO IN THAT SENSE THE
SENATE PLAN FOR THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA IT WOULD HELP US
COVER ALL OF OUR COSTS AND HAVE
FUNDING LEFT OVER TO INCREASE
STUDENT SERVICES AND ENROLLMENT-
IF THOSE ARE THE SENATE'S
PRIORITIES THAT WOULD. BE VERY
HELPFUL AND WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF YOU CONSIDERING
THOSE FUNDS- THE RELIABLE BASED
BUDGET SUPPORT PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR WHEN COMBINED WITH OUR
CO HEARD FACED TUITION INCREASES
WILL PROVIDE CAMPUSES SUFFICIENT
REVENUE TO COVER THE NEW
MANDATORY COST INCREASES AND
INCREASE STUDENT SERVICES. A
LITTLE BIT THE CAMPUSES WILL
HAVE TO BE VERY PRUDENT AND HOW
THEY BUDGET FOR NEW SERVICES AND
THEY WILL HAVE TO LOOK FOR COST
CONTAINMENT WITHIN THEIR
EXISTING ENTERPRISE OF FUNDING
STRUCTURE IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO. COVER ALL THE COSTS WITHIN
THE GOVERNOR'S FAVORITE VISION-
I DO WANT TO ADVISE THE
COMMITTEE THAT GIVEN THAT
INFLATION IS INCREASING VERY
RAPIDLY. OF WE MAY NEED TO HAVE
A CONVERSATION IN FUTURE YEARS
ABOUT WHAT CAN BE ACHIEVED WITH
THE PROPOSED BASED BUDGET
INCREASES IF INFLATION CONTINUES
TO INCREASE AT THE SAME PACE AS
IT HAS BEEN INCREASING OF THESE
LAST SEVERAL MONTHS- BUT WE ARE
VERY- THANKFUL THE GOVERNOR- FOR
PROPOSING THESE. YOUR FUNDING-
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
TO HOW TO MAKE IT ALL WORK. IN
TERMS OF STUDENT SERVICES THE
REGION'S HAD- THE PROPOSAL
FRAMEWORK TWENTY THIRTY WHICH
WAS THE CLOSE GRADUATION GAPS
THE COST OF THAT PLAN WAS
ESTIMATED AT THIRTY ONE TO SIXTY
MILLION ANNUALLY. SO THOSE COSTS
WOULD BE COMING OUT OF THE BASE
BUDGET INCREASE THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING- AND THAT
MEANS OF THE CAMPUSES WILL HAVE
TO BE A VERY JUDICIOUS AND HOW
THEY ALLOCATE- FUNDING FOR THEIR
EXISTING. EXISTING COSTS WITHIN
THE CAMPUSES. THANK YOU BEFORE
WE GO TO COMMUNITY- THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE LET ME ASK A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION BECAUSE YOU SAID YOU
YOU MIGHT WANT TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT INFLATION
THAT'S WHAT THIS HEARING IS THIS
HEARING IS THE CONVERSATION NOW
AND SO MY QUESTION WOULD BE DOES
THE SENATE'S PROPOSAL ADDRESS
THE INFLATION CONCERNS YOU
EXPRESSED. FOR THE BUDGET HERE.
YES THE SENATE'S PROPOSAL TAKES
CARE OF THE INFLATION FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR AND I WOULD THINK
BUDGET YOUR PLUS ONE S. WELL OF
BECAUSE THE SENATE PROPOSAL IS
QUITE GENEROUS. SO WOULD ALLOW
US TO ADDRESS ALL ARE BASED COST
INCREASES INFLATION AND STUDENT
SERVICES AS WELL AS ENROLLMENT
GROWS. OKAY THANK YOU NOW MOVES
TO THE- ORIGINAL QUESTION IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. YOU GERMAN
LAYERED LOOK THAT NEVER AT WITH
IT CANCERS OFFICE I'M OUR
SEVENTY THREE DISTRICTS ARE IN
VARYING STAGES OF ADDRESSING ONE
OF THEIR PRIMARY COSTS PRESS
PRESSURES WHICH YOUR STORES IN
PERS PENSION. RELATED COSTS AND
SO- IT'S HARD TO TELL WHETHER
THE AMOUNT REALLY ADDRESSES
THESE COSTS- INCREASES BUT IT IS
AN IMPORTANT START BUT I DO WANT
TO- AND THE SIZE OF THE SENATE'S
PLAN WOULD GET COLLEGES MUCH
CLOSER. NOW TO IN ADDITION TO
REALLY EMPHASIZING THAT THE
PROPOSED SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION BLOCK GRANT SHOULD BE
FIRST UTILIZED TO ADDRESS
PENSION INCREASES IN THOSE COST
PRESSURES AS AN IMPORTANT USE OF
THOSE ONE TEN DOLLARS AND FOR
LONG TERM PLANNING- I WANT TO
ADDRESS ALSO COST PRESSURE FOR
STUDENTS- THAT CONTINUES TO
ESCALATE. FINANCIAL LADEN CAL
GRANTS TO NON ADJUSTED WITH
INFLATION AND SO FOR STUDENTS-
THEIR COST PRESSURES ARE NOT
KEEPING PACE AND SO ON A
SENATE'S EFFORTS AROUND CAL
GRANT REFORMER IMPORTANT AS ARE
THOSE RELATED TO HOUSING WHICH
COULD REMOVE UP FOR SOME
STUDENTS OF THE HOUSING.
UNAFFORDABILITY IN SOME REGIONS
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE THE ANSWERS THOSE
QUESTIONS IN LET ME ASK ONE OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHICH
WAS ALSO LISTED. ABOUT FROM.
WHETHER THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- THROUGH THE MAY REVISE
IS PROPOSING. ARE COMPACT
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS IN THE
BUDGET AND IF THERE'S ANYTHING
IN THE COMPAQ'S. ARE THAT YOU
ARE SEEKING LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL
OF OR SEEKING THE LEGISLATURE TO
CODIFY. I'M HERE BAKER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
FUNDING ASSOCIATED WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS FOR
THE COMPACTS AND FOR THE ROAD
MAP. WORST ARE INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET BILL AND THEN TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE IN SOME CASES FOR
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THOSE
WOULD BE ACTIONS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE OR PROPOSALS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WE TAKE ACTION
ON. FOR THAT THE FISCAL
APPROPRIATIONS THEMSELVES- WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE OR TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO CODIFY THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENT ASSOCIATED
WITH THE CONTACTS OR WITH THE
ROAD MAP THOSE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ARE PART OF THE
CONTACTED ROADMAP DOCUMENTS
THEMSELVES. THEY DO SPECIFY THAT
THE SEGMENTS WOULD BE REPORTING
NOT ONLY TO THE ADMINISTRATION
BUT ALSO TO THE LEGISLATURE ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS ABOUT THEIR
PROGRESS TOWARD THOSE GOALS. AND
I WOULD JUST NOTE ON THAT THE
FUNDING TOPIC AS WELL. BUT THE
5% YEAR OVER YEAR BASIS INCREASE
AS FOR GENERAL FUND THAT ARE
ENVISIONED FOR BOTH USED AND CSU
AS PART OF CONTACT REALLY
PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY AND
PREDICTABILITY FOR THE
UNIVERSITIES TO FUND THEIR
ONGOING NEEDS ACCORDING TO THEIR
PRIORITIES. AND THEY REALLY DO
REPRESENT SOME OF THE LARGEST
AND MOST CONSISTENTLY PLAN
GENERAL FUND INCREASE THAT'S FOR
THE UNIVERSITIES INRECENT
HISTORY. I'M JUST ALLOWED RIGHT
ON THAT POINT AS WELL OVER THE
FIVE YEAR PERIOD OF THE COMPACT
THOSE YEAR OVER YEAR PLANNED
GENERAL FUND INCREASES OF 5%
EACH YEAR WOULD BE PROVIDING YOU
SEE ALSO THAT. AGGREGATE WITH
MORE THAN ONE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN NEW ON GOING FUNDING
AND THIS YEAR MORE THAN ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN NEW
ONGOING FUNDING BY THE END OF
THE FIVE YEAR TERM SO WE DO
RECOGNIZE AND WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THOSE
PLANNED INVESTMENTS. ARE AND
ALSO JUST REITERATING THAT OU
KNOW AND THE GOVERNOR'S IN
JANUARY ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT I'M GOING
COMMITMENTS OF GENERAL FUND
RESOURCES WAS TO BE AS COMPACT
PROPOSALS 45% BASED FUNDING
INCREASES FOR UC AND CSU. AND AS
YOU'VE HEARD OF COURSE AND THAT
RELEASED THE MAY REVISION. THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THE ADDITIONAL
INVEST CENSUS DATA A NEIGHBOR
VISION ARE ONE TO MAKE. REALLY
IN RIGHT OF THE NEED FOR FISCAL.
LARGELY CITING IN MANY OF THE
THINGS THE L. A. MENTIONED AND
THERE PRESENTE OF. ECONOMIC
INDICATORS THAT SUGGEST SOME
VOLATILITY. AND POTENTIAL RISK
OF FISCAL DECLINES IN THE FUTURE
. MAKE OUR OUR ONE COMMENT AND
THEN ASK A FOLLOW UP QUESTION-
I'LL JUST REPEAT A COMMENT I
MADE IN THE PREVIOUS HEARING
WHICH IS THAT. ARE NORMALLY- THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL OF THE 5%
AND OVER FIVE YEARS AS WAS MADE
IN. JANUARY IN ANY NORMAL YEAR-
WE WOULD BE CELEBRATING THAT AND
JUST TRYING TO PROTECT IT ALL
THE WAY THROUGH THE PROCESS AND
CALL IT A DAY. IN THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE WE HAVE THE HIGHEST
INFLATION WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
DECADES. AND WE HAVE SOME
RESIDUAL COSTS OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC. AND 5% DOES NOT KEEP
PACE A SO FALLING BACK ON THE-
ON THE GENEROSITY OF
PREDICTABILITY OF THE 5% IS GOOD
AND I RECOGNIZE THAT BUT IT DOES
NOT KEEP PACE WITH WAS WHAT THE
EXPENSES ARE. AND PARTICULARLY
IN THE CASE OF CSU WHERETHEY
ARE NEGOTIATING OF US SOME
ADDITIONAL CONTRACTS. THAT WITH
REGARD TO COMPENSATION WILLBE
VERY HARD TO DO WITHIN THE FIVE
PERCENT. IT IS ACTUALLY A
SOMETHING THAT IS THE REASON THE
LEGISLATURE HAS HAS RECOMMENDED
IT BUT THE FOLLOW UP QUESTION- I
WANTED TO MAKE HIS. MMHM IS TO
TEASE OUT A LITTLE MORE THE
ENFORCEABILITY OF THE CONTACTS
BECAUSE YOU MENTIONED. THAT
THERE'S A BUDGET LANGUAGE ON THE
REPORTING. BUT IS THAT THE
EXTENT OF THE ENFORCEABILITY OF
THESE CONTACTS IF LET'S JUST SAY
AND I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT IT IS
THAT FOR WHATEVER REASON ONE OF
THE SEGMENTS DOES NOT FULFILL
SOME OF THE DIRECTIONS THAT ARE
CLEARLY OUTLINED IN THE COMPACT
. HE ISSUE WHAT IS THE
ENFORCEABILITY THEY REPORT THAT
THEY HAVEN'T MET THE THINGS THAT
HAVE SET OUT WHAT ARE THE
OPTIONS TO ENFORCE THAT AND ARE
IN FACT THE FUTURE 5% INCREASES
AT RISK FOR ANYTHING THAT MIGHT
COME OUT OF THEM. BEING UNABLE
TO FULFILL ANY PART OF THE
CONTACT. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- WE WOULD EXPECT WELL I
GUESS I SHOULD SAY FIRSTLY THAT
THE COMPLEX AND THE ROADMAP
ARTICULATE SHARED VISIONS AND
GOALS AMONG ADMINISTRATION AND
LIKE THE SEGMENTS. AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
COMMONALITY IN THE GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE SEGMENTS
ACHIEVED AS WELL. AS FAR AS
ACCOUNTABILITY YOU KNOW ONE
WHERE WHERE VERY HOPEFUL THAT.
THERE WILL BE CONSIDERABLE
PROGRESS TOWARD ALL OF THESE
CALLS INCREMENTS BECAUSE THAT'S
REALLY THE INTENT HERE IS TO SEE
EACH SEGMENT SIXTEEN. AND
BENEFIT STUDENTS AS STRONGLY AS
POSSIBLE- WE DO EXPECT AND
MESSAGE IN JANUARY WITH THE
RELEASE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. THAT THE PLANNED YOUR
EVERY YEAR BASED INCREASES FOR
UC AND CSU WOULD BE PROVIDED
CONTINGENT UPON THE SEGMENT'S
ABILITY TO. KEEP DEMONSTRATE
PROGRESS TOWARD THE GOALS AND
COMMITMENTS IN THE COMPLEX. THAT
SAID WE ARE EXPECTING TO LOOK AT
IT MORE FROM A HOLISTIC GOOD
FAITH EFFORT. TYPE OF APPROACH
THIRTY REPORTING THAT'S
ARTICULATED AND THE SPECIFIC
METRICS THAT ARE OUTLINED IN THE. THE DETAIL COMPACT DOCUMENTS.
WHY NOT NECESSARILY EXPECT ANY
YEAR THAT THEY'RE EXACTLY A 100%
ON. THE TRACK FOR MEETING YOU
KNOW EVERY SPECIFIC METRIC FOR
THAT PARTICULAR YEAR WE ARE
LOOKING EXPECTING GOOD FAITH
PROGRESS GOOD FAITH EFFORT.
DEMONSTRATING THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO FORWARD ON THSE
GOALS THAT THERE IS. A TRUE
EFFORT BEING MADE TO IMPROVE%
UPON THOSE CALLS AND HIT THOSE
TARGETS. WERE RECOGNIZING THAT
IN SOME YEARS YOU KNOW THERE MAY
BE CERTAIN AREAS THAT FALL A
LITTLE BIT SHORT AND THERE MAY
BE OTHER AREAS IN WHICH THEY'VE
GONE. BEYOND EXPECTATIONS FOR
THAT POINT IN TIME WE WOULD BE
CONSIDERING ALL OF THOSE THINGS
MORE HOLISTICALLY WHEN IT COMES
TO ADMINISTRATION'S BUDGET
PROPOSALS FOR THE SEGMENT- MAYBE
A THE APPRECIATE THAT BUT LET ME
TRY THE QUESTION A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT WAY LET'S SAY THAT
WHEN THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S BREASTS ARE REAL
CONCERNS OVER INFLATION OVER
NUMBER OF YEARS AND WANTING TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IT. IF
THE INFLATION MEANT THAT THEY
WEREN'T MOVING AHEAD DIDN'T REAL
DOLLARS- YOU WITH A 5% INCREASE
AND THEN THEY COULDN'T ACHIEVE
PART OF THE COMPACTS IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT HERE BECAUSE YOU
SAID IT SHARED A SHARED
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT YOU WOULD SORT OF ACCEPT AS
A REASON WHY THEY WEREN'T
MEETING PIECES OF THE COMPACT.
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT WE
WOULD HAVE TO DISCUSS FURTHER
AND SEE WHERE THEY HAD BEEN ABLE
TO MAKE PROGRESS I THINK A
NUMBER OF THE GOALS AND
COMMITMENTS. YEAH DO REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT OF
RESOURCES BUT A NUMBER CAN ALSO
BE ACHIEVED. JUST STRATEGICALLY
WITH WITHIN A LOT OF THE THINGS
THAT THE SEGMENTS ARE YOU DOING
IN WITHIN THEIR BASE AVAILABLE
RESOURCES THAT THEY HAVE TO SO.
I EACH CONTACT AND THE ROAD MAP
DOCUMENT BUILD UPON THE
INDIVIDUAL SEGMENTS GOALS THAT
THEY ALREADY HAD AND THAT THEY
WERE ALREADY MAKING SOME
PROGRESS ON. THE FOR YOU SEE THE
UC TWENTY THIRTY PLAN THE CSU
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. AND FOR THE CCC IS
THE VISION FOR SUCCESS FOR EACH
SEGMENT WAS WORKING AND HAD
EFFORTS UNDER WAY AND GOALS
ARTICULATED FOR IMPROVING A
NUMBER OF THESE AREAS. THE
CONTACTS IN THE ROAD MAP FOR THE
BUILD UPON THOSE PLANS. BUT WE
DO EXPECT THAT THE SEGMENTS
WOULD BE ABLE TO MAKE PROGRESS
WITHIN EXISTING RESOURCES AND
MANY OF THESE AREAS THAT THEY'REALREADY TAKING STEPS TO TRY TO
DO SO. AND THAT THE PLAN
INVESTMENTS WOULD FACILITATE
THEIR ABILITY TO DO THAT AS WELL
AS- I DO SOME THINGS THAT OF
COURSE YOU REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
ONGOING RESOURCE THAT SEXUAL
SEVERAL MACROS AT UC AND CSU.
ENVISIONED IN THE OUT YEARS.
THANK YOU FOR THE ANSWER I WOULD
JUST TO BE. THAT IT STILL SEEMS
VERY HAZY- LET ME. ASK IT JUST
FOREVER EVERYBODY HERE AND
LISTENING AT HOME. THIS IS OUR
OVERVIEW OF THE ENTIRE HIGHER
READ AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO BE
GOING THROUGH THE INDIVIDUAL
SEGMENTS AND- AND THERE'S BEEN
SOME OVERLAP AND MAYBE THAT'LL
SHORTEN THE- THE- THE NEXT
DISCUSSIONS A LITTLE BIT AS- AS
WE MOVE THROUGH. LET ME ASK MY
COLLEAGUES IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS ON THE OVERVIEW
SENATOR MEN. I THINK SENATOR
LAYERED- CAROLERS FASTENAL'S MY
QUESTIONS I JUST WANTED TO SEE
MY COMMENTS WITH HIS AND- ON THE
INFLATION POINT I MEAN. YOU KNOW%
GOING BACK TO ECONOMICS ONE A
ONE THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
REAL VALUE NOMINAL VALUE MORE
TALKING ABOUT. YOU KNOW
SOMETHING LIKE 8% INFLATION OR
OR SIX AND A HALF PERCENT OR
WHATEVER IT'S GOING TO END UP
BEING AT THE END OF THIS YEAR- I
DO KNOW FIVE PERCENT. BASE
INCREASE SOUNDS GREAT IT IS
HISTORICALLY HIGH IN RECENT
YEARS- BUT WE'VE ALSO BEEN
DEALING WITH THE CENTURY A ZERO
INFLATION ENVIRONMENT FOR THE
LAST COUPLE DECADES- SO IN THE
CONTEXT OF. WHAT THIS IS AS FAR
AS A REAL VALUE- A 5% INCREASE
LOOKS LIKE A NEGATIVE. I'M IT IS
A DECREASE NOT INCREASE. I WANT
TO TALK ABOUT OUR BASE FOR-
FUNDING HERE. I AND SO. I GUESS
I AS FAR AS QUESTIONS THAT YOU
KNOW I THINK I WANTED TO FOLLOW
UP ON SOMETHING. SOONER LATER
TODAY ASKED AND I THINK THIS IS
FOR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I HOW
MUCH WIGGLE ROOM DO WE HAVE IN
THESE CONTACTS IN IN YOUR IN
ADMINISTRATIONS YOU. TO REVISIT
THESE SHOULD INFLATION CONTINUE
TO BE AT THIS PACE- SO WHAT'S
YOUR VISION AS FAR AS REVISITING
THE GOALS ARE REDUCING THE
FUNDING. AND THAT WOULD BE FOR
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THANK YOU I
GUESS THE QUESTION IS A COMPACT
SET OR IS THIS SOMETHING
UNIVISION IS KIND OF A ROLLING
DOCUMENT THIS CAN BE SUBJECT TO
REVISION AS AS CIRCUMSTANCES
WARRANT. AT THIS POINT IN TIME
WE'RE ENVISIONING THE CONTACTS
ON THE ROADMAP BEING FIVE YEAR
TERM DOCUMENTS. THAT ARE
PUBLISHED ON OUR WEBSITE
HOWEVER. YOU KNOW OF COURSE AS
CIRCUMSTANCES EVOLVE OVER THE
TERMS K. AGREEMENTS WE WOULD BE
CONSIDERING THAT- JUST IN TERMS
OF MONITORING EACH SEGMENT'S
PROGRESS TOWARD MEETING THOSE
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES. AND IF WE
ARE SEEING LARGER FACTORS ARE AT
PLAY THAT ME BE. OPPOSING
CHALLENGES FOR YOU KNOW IN THE
WAY THAT YOU'VE JUST CRIED
PERHAPS ACROSS THE BOARD AND IN
SOME OF THOSE WAYS. THAT WOULD
BE A CONVERSATION WE WOULD
CERTAINLY CONTINUE HAVING WITH
THE SEGMENTS- AND WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AS WE CONSIDER. AS
WE CONSIDER MOVING FORWARD. HOW
HOW DOES PROGRESS OVER TIME AS
IT RELATES TO THE INFLATIONARY
ENVIRONMENT AND THE PROPOSAL'S.
OVERALL THAT WE FOR IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND MAY
REVISION. YEAH I WOULD JUST
EMPHASIZE YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
WERE IN RECOGNITION OF THE FACT
THAT THERE IS- INFLATION
CURRENTLY THAT THERE ARE SOME
VOLATILITY. HOWEVER WE DO HAVE A
LOT OF CONSTRAINTS WHEN IT COMES
TO ADDITIONAL ONGOING SPENDING.
AND MANY OF THOSE VALLEY- SPEAK
SPOKE TO AT THE BEGINNING OF
THIS HEARING AS WELL. AND JUST
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE OVERALL
NEED FOR FISCAL PRUDENCE WHEN IT
COMES TO. ADDITIONAL ONGOING
SPENDING BECAUSE OF COURSE KIND
OF THE WORST CASE SCENARIO IS.
COMMITMENTS OF ONGOING SPENDING
THAT CAN BE FOLLOWED THROUGH
UPON IN FUTURE HERE IF WE FIND
OURSELVES IN THE EVENT OF A
RECESSION- IT'S A MUCH MORE
BETTER- IT'S A MUCH BETTER
SITUATION. WHEN EVENTUAL
EVENTUAL RECESSION HITS THAT WE
JUST AREN'T ABLE TO IT IT
ADDRESS OR INVEST ADDITIONAL ONE
TIMERESOURCES AT THAT POINT IN
TIME. AS OPPOSED TO HAVING TO
MAKE CUTS WHICH IS. AT THE
SITUATION WE FIND OURSELVES AND
IF PREVIOUS COMMITMENTS OF I'M
GOING SPENDING ARE. ARE HIGHER
THAN WHAT WE CAN ACCOMMODATE
THAT DOWN HERE. I GUESS MAYBE
POSSIBLY I CAN APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS ABOUT RECESSION. RISK-
AND DO YOU THINK THE- YOU
PERCENT IS A SUFFICIENT GIVEN
THAT WE DO EXPERIENCE EIGHT AND
A HALF PERCENT. I IN THE YEAR
ENDING MARCH TWENTY EIGHT POINT
TWO- IN DEBT I THINK THAT THE
PARTNER LABOR'S PREDICTING SIX
AND A HALF PERCENT INFLATION BY.
YOU FOR YEAR YEAR AND TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. IS 5% SUFFICIENT. WE
JUST EMPHASIZE THAT THAT THE 5%
YEAR OVER YEAR BASIS INCREASES
ARE. AMONG THE STRONGEST OF THE
SEGMENTS HAVE SEEN PARTICULARLY
IN RECENT YEARS- AND THEN AGAIN
AS MENTIONED AND WE'D BE LOOKING
AT MORE THAN A BILLION DOLLARS
IN NEW ONGOING FUNDING AT THE
END OF THE FIVE YEAR TERM. IN
THE AGGREGATE FOR BOTH UC AND
CSU THEY ARE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN THERE AMONG. THE
TOP THREE OR FOUR PROBABLY
INVESTMENTS OF ONGOING NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND THAT ARE PLANNED IN THE
FACT THAT OVERALL IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL. AND
AGAIN I WOULD RE ARTICULATE THAT
THAT IS NOMINAL INCREASE BUT NOT
REAL INCREASE AND SO I'M BILLION
SOUNDS GREAT BUT IF THE COSTS-
THAT UC'S INCURRING GO UP TO
BILLION OR THREE BILLION. I WILL
NOT KEEPING PACE WITH INFLATION
THEN IT CAN IT'S A NET DECREASE
AND SO I WOULD JUST REITERATE
THAT. MY SECOND QUESTION GOES
TO. SET A COMMONS GOES TO THE
POINT THAT CENTER LATER RAISED
ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY- WELL IT
YOU KNOW WHEN I HEAR THAT YOU'RE
HOPEFUL AND THE MINISTRATIONS
HOPEFUL. AND WE'RE GONNA BE
GAUGING THINGS ON A HOLISTIC
GOOD FAITH EFFORT- THAT THAT
KIND OF SMACKS TO ME OF I CAN'T
A VERY HANDS OFF APPROACH AND I
GUESS THE QUESTION IS ARE YOU
ANTICIPATING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL BE PRIMARILY
RESPONSIBLE FOR- PROVIDING
COUNSELING OVERSIGHT HERE OR IS
THIS THE ADMINISTRATION. EIGHT
IN AND JUST TO DOUBLE DOWN ON
WHAT CENTER WHERE TO ASK WHAT
HAPPENS IF. YOU SEE. SEE ISSUES
AND OR THE CCC'S. OUR YOU NOTE.
SHORTER THERE. GOALS HERE NINETY
MUSIC FACET. WHAT IS WHAT ARE
YOU GUYS GOING TO DO IT OR YOU
JUST LEAVING THAT TO US OVERSEE
. YEAH CERTAINLY EXPECT THAT
THE- GIVEN THAT THE CONTACTS ON
THE ROADMAP RECOMMENDS BETWEEN
GET MINISTRATION EACH RESPECTIVE
SEGMENT. WE WOULD BE DEFINITELY
VERY ENGAGED IN CONTINUING
PARTNERSHIP WITH EACH SEGMENT AS
THEY WORK TOWARD THOSE GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES. LOOKING AT THE
ANNUAL REPORTS QUITE CLOSELY THE
COMPACT AND ROADMAP DOCUMENTS
THEMSELVES ARE ARE FAIRLY
LENGTHY AND GETTING INTO A
NUMBER OF SPECIFIC METRICS. A
BASS LINES AS WELL AS AN
INTERMEDIATE TARGET SINGLES
LEADING UP TO THE LARGER FIVE
YEAR TERM GOALS. AND BEYOND IN
SOME CASES SO- WE WOULD
CERTAINLY BE EXPECTING TO
CONTINUE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE SEGMENTS- ENSURING THAT
THAT INFORMATION IS SHARED AND
RELATED TO THE LEGISLATURE AS
WELL- OF COURSE INFORMED. US OF
THE SEGMENTS PROGRESS- AND- I
WOULD ALSO JUST NOTE THAT THE
APPROACH HERE IS NOT USUALLY
DISSIMILAR FROM COMPACTS THAT
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATIONS HAVE
ENTERED INTO WITH YOU SEE NCS
HERE. IN TERMS OF HAVING A
CONTRACT AGREEMENT THAT'S
BETWEEN THE ADMINISTRATION. AND
THE INDIVIDUAL UNIVERSITY
SEGMENTS- AND THEN MONITORING
PROGRESS AND HAVING THAT
INFLUENCE DISTRACTIONS BUDGET
PROPOSALS FOR THE SEGMENT. AND
MAYBE YOU'LL JUST MAKE IT MORE
SIMPLE WHAT DO YOU SEE AS THE
LEGISLATURE'S ROLE IN THIS
PROCESS WHETHER IT'S
APPROPRIATING FUNDS- PROVIDING
OVERSIGHT WHAT DO YOU SEE IS US
DOING A WE JUST. KIND OF READING. THE REPORTS ARE SENDING US-
WHAT'S OUR ROLE. THERE'S
CERTAINLY ABILITY. WOULD HAVE
ROLE IN ANY OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS FOR THE
UNIVERSITIES AND FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHEN IT COMES
TO THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING PROPOSALS. SO ANYTHING
THAT WE'VE PUT FORWARD. AS A
PROPOSAL IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET OR ANY REVISION BOTH THIS
YEAR AND IN THE FOR. COMING
YEARS FOR THE TERMS OF THESE
AGREEMENTS WOULD BE PROPOSALS
FOR THE LEGISLATURE'S
CONSIDERATION OF APPROPRIATION
OF FUNDING. WE DO HAVE IS I
THINK THE CSU REPRESENTATIVE
MENTIONED IN HIS OPENING REMARKS
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF MENTIONS
IN THE UC NCS YOUR CONTACTS.
ABOUT TO THE EXTENT THAT
ADDITIONAL STATE REVENUE IS
AVAILABLE IN ANY OF THOSE YEARS.
ADMINISTRATION WOULD CONSIDER
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME INVESTMENTS
PARTICULARLY IN HIGH NEED KIND
OF CAPITAL OUTLAY DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE SEISMIC RENOVATION
AREAS AND WE'VE ALSO MADE
MENTION SPECIFIC. CONTACTS TO
EXTEND TAT THERE'S ADDITIONAL
STATE REVENUE AVAILABLE WE WOULD
ALSO CONSIDER YOU KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE WERE INTERESTED AND
ADDITIONAL ONGOING FUNDING
PARTICULARLY FOR GOALS SUCH AS
ADDITIONAL ENROLLMENT GROWTH
BEYOND WHAT WE ENVISIONED AND
ARTICULATED IN THE COMPACTS.
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT WE
WOULD CONSIDER THROUGHOUT THE
BUDGET DEVELOPMENT PROCESS AS
WELL- I'LL JUST CLOSE BY SAYING
I- I. WILL MY VIEW THAT I SEE.
THE MINISTRATIONS YOU THE
LEGISLATURE ROLES IS FLAWED
HERE- YOU KNOW WE IF WE DON'T
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE- THE FACT THAT
TO A ONE OF THE- THREE BRANCHES
OF EDUCATION HIGHER EDUCATION
TALK ABOUT DOESN'T MEAN IT'S
GOALS- IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IS THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL WILL. BE
HOPEFUL AND TAKE A HANDS OFF
APPROACH IF WE DON'T LIKE THAT I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS. WE
CAN JUST KIND OF ACCEPT THAT AND
I THINK THAT. GIVEN OUR ROLE I
WOULD I WAS ELECTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT I REPRESENT MY
CONSTITUENTS. I AND I DON'T
THINK I'D BE DOING MY JOB IF I
DID NOT ALSO TRY TO EXERCISE
OVERSIGHT HERE- SO- YOU KNOW I
SEE. YOUR VIEW OF OUR ROLEHERE
IS AS PROBLEMATIC AND I HOPE
THAT WE ARE ABLE THAT. PARTNER
GOING FORWARD ON ENFORCEMENT AND
OVERSIGHT OF THIS CONTACT I AM
THE CONTACT PLUS GOALS THAT THE
SENATE IS ARTICULATED. I HAVE
HANDS FROM BOTH WELL MY HEAD WAS
REMOVED FOR FINANCE OF A HAND
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND I'M TRYING TO WRAP
THIS UP BECAUSE WE HAVE EIGHT
MORE. ISSUES TO DO IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF HOURS SO ABOUT ALL
RECOGNIZE YOU THE L. A. L. JUST
GIVEN YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT THE
COLETTE I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE YOU ALL KNOW THAT. YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT 5% INCREASES ON
THE GENERAL FUND PORTION OF THE
SEGMENTS BUDGET IS JUST ONE PART
OF THE CORE OPERATING BUDGET
THAT THE HOUSE WITH TUITION
FUNDS MAKING UP A PRETTY LARGE
SHARON THOUGHT SO IT'S MORE LIKE
FOR EXAMPLE 3% OF A CORE
OPERATING BUDGET INCREASED.
FIRST YES YOU SINCE THEY'RE NOT
EXPECTING TUITION INCREASE AS
JUST ANOTHER THING TO KEEP IN
MIND AS YOU MOVE FORWARD AND
TRYING TO THINK ABOUT THE BASS
AND CHRIS SAYS OBVIOUSLY BUDGET
ANNUALLY BECAUSE YOU'VE WANTED
FLEXIBILITY TO RECOGNIZE ALL OF
THE CHANGING ECONOMIC CONDITIONS
BEFORE YOU. YOU WILL HAVE A
DIFFERENT INFLATION PRESSURE
NEXT YEAR YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO
BUILD YOUR BUDGET ACCORDINGLY
AND JUST THE ARTICLE SOME OF THE
POINTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
DEMONSTRATION IS ASKING YOU TO
APPROPRIATE THE MONEY AND THEIR
PLANS AND OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE
EXPRESSING INTEREST WANT TO BE
INVOLVED IN SEVEN EXPECTATIONS
AS WELL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I
THINK THIS IS BEEN A VERY GOOD
HEALTHY DISCUSSION. I JUST
APPRECIATE ALL THE POINTS THAT
WERE MADE I THINK IN MANY WAYS.
IT MAKES THE CASE FOR THE SENATE
BUDGET PROPOSALS PARTICULARLY.
THE BACK AND FORTH REGULARLY ON
THE FACT. THAT THE 5% IS
DEFENDED ON THE FACT THAT IT'S
THE MOST ROBUST INCREASE THAT'S
BEEN SUGGESTED IN YEARS AND YET
IT DOESN'T KEEP UP WITH
INFLATION. BY THE BY ITSELF
COMPLETELY SEPARATE FROM OTHER
THINGS SO I THINK THIS REALLY
LAYS THE GROUNDWORK FOR GOOD
DISCUSSION OVER THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS AS WE- OF LAND THE BUDGET
SO I THANK EVERYBODY FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN THIS. AND NOW.
IF WE TOOK AS LONG FOR ALL THE
REMAINING ISSUES AS WE DID ON
THIS ONE WILL BE HERE AT EIGHT
O'CLOCK TONIGHT. SO I THINK NOW
WE START TO MARCH THROUGH IN A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF A- EFFICIENT
WAY AND WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE INDIVIDUAL SEGMENTS
INCIDENT ISSUE TOO. IS THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND WHAT
HAVE. I HAVE LISTED TWO PEOPLE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
LET THEM DECIDE IF THEY WANT
THEM BOTH TO SPEAK. DANTAN OUR
JENNIFER KACU. POSTING HOUSING
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE ANALYSTS AT NAVARETTE.
NAVARETTE FROM THE A CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE. WILL BEGIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
MORNING SURE MEMBERS STAND OR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
ALL GIVE OUR COMMENTS TODAY.
BURKE COMMUNITY COLLEGE LOCAL
ASSISTANCE THE ADMINISTRATION
RECOGNIZES THE LARGE NUMBER OF
NEW INVESTMENTS INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT. IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. AS SUCH THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE MAY
REVISION FOCUSES ON PROVIDING
SIGNIFICANT SUPPORT. THE STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA OR SCF
OF. INFLEXIBLE BLOCK GRANT
FUNDING TO SUPPORT DISTRICTS
WOULD BE EXPECTED TRANSITION
BACK TO IN PERSON EDUCATION AND
TO ACHIEVE THE GOALS OUTLINED IN
THE ONCE YOU'RE ABOUT. TO THAT
END THE MAYOR VISION INCLUDES AN
OVERALL BASING CREASE OF THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION. FOR THE SCF
SPECIFICALLY TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION TO INCREASE THE
FUNDING RATES INTO DSF AFT. AND
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
MILLION TO AUGMENT THE BASS
DELEGATION. IN RECOGNITION OF
INCREASING OPERATING COSTS
INCLUDING THE SIGNIFICANT
DIGITAL FOTPRINTS THAT
DISTRICTS HAVE DEVELOPED TO
ACCOMMODATE LONG TERM SHIFTS. IN
STUDENT LEARNING MODALITY DEMAND
. THESE CHANGES ALONG WITH
VARIOUS TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS
PRODUCE AN ESTIMATED DECREASE.
OF ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN POINT
ONE MILLION TO THE HOLD HARMLESS
RELATIVE TO WHAT WAS PROJECTED
TO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THE MAYOR
VISION INCLUDES EIGHTY THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION TO REFLECT
THE BASE OR THE INCREASE. IN THE
STATUTORY COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT FROM FIVE POINT 33%
OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. IS SIX
POINT FIVE SIX PERCENT. RIGHT
NOW IT MAYOR VISION AND ONE
POINT THREE MILLION TO MAINTAIN
FUNDING FOR POINT 5% AND
LAWMAKERS. THE ADMINISTRATION
DOES NOT PROPOSE STATUTORY
CHANGES TO THE SCO OR THE
STUDENT CENTER FUNDING FORMULA
AT THE MAY REVISION. THAT ARE
SEPARATE FROM PROPOSED. IS
CHANGING- PROPOSED AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL MONITOR HOW
DISTRICT ENROLLMENT FOR FORM AND
EXPECTS THE STABILITY PROVISION
OF THE SCF FIVE. AND SIGNIFICANT
NEW INVESTMENTS TO SUPPORT
DISTRICTS FUNDING FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE FISCAL
YEAR. THE MARRIAGE AND ALSO
UTILIZES SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME
FUNDING UNDER THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE. TO
PROVIDE A SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR BLOCK
GRANT. AN INCREASE OF ONE POINT
ONE BILLION FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. WHICH TOTALS. ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION INCLUDING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL. BOB
GRAHAM FUNDS WOULD BE AVAILABLE
TO ADDRESS ISSUES RELATED TO THE
PANDEMIC. AND TO REDUCE LONG
TERM OBLIGATIONS. OTHER
ADJUSTMENTS INCLUDED THE MAYOR
VISION ARE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
ON GOING FOR ROUGHLY 5% INCREASE
HIS STUDENT EQUITY ACHIEVEMENT
PROGRAM. FORTY FIVE MILLION ONE
TIME FOR THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY
SCHOOL MEALS PROGRAM. A DECREASE
OF FIFTY MILLION FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ESTIMATE FOR
THE STUDENT SUCCESS COMPLETION
GRANT PROVIDE UPDATED CAL GRANT
ESTIMATES. SIXTEEN POINT NINE
MILLION ONGOING PROBLEM NINETY
GENERAL FUND TO ALIGN THE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM ARE AS
IRATE WITH THE SCF CREDIT RATING
AS OPPOSED TO THE NON CREDIT
RATING. TEN MILLION ONGOING
ABOVE WHAT WAS PROVIDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO AUGMENT THE
NEXT STEP PROGRAM- WITH THIS
INVESTMENT DEMONSTRATIONS ALSO
PROPOSING TO REVISE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO REMOVE THE STATUTORY
CAP ON DISTRICTS. AND ALLOW
ALLOCATION PROVIDED SPECIFICALLY
TO COLLEGES- WHICH IS INTENDED
TO PROVIDE MORE FLEXIBILITY IN
HOW THE FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED. WE
ALSO PROVIDE TEN MILLION TO
ESTABLISH THE CONCEPT EMPLOYEE
SOME ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FUNDS
FAMILIES. AND FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ONGOING TOBACCO
DECREASE IN FEDERAL MATCH
FUNDING FOR FOSTER AND KINSHIP
CARE PROGRAMS. TURNING THE STATE
OPERATIONS THE MAYOR VISION
PROPOSES AN INCREASE OF TWO
POINT SIX MILLION. NON
PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
BUT THE CHANCES OFFICE TRIPLEX
SEVEN NEW POSITIONS TO SUPPORT
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CRADLE
TO GRAVE DATA SYSTEM. SUPPORT
DISTRICTS TOWARD MEETING THE
GOALS OUTLINED IN THE MULTI ROAD
MAP. THIS IS COLLEGES WITHOUT
FOR OFFERING AFFORDABLE STUDENT
HOUSING. AND BUILD CAPACITY TO
ACCOMMODATE AND THE INCREASING
CONTRACT REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
RATHER THAN THEIR VISION SHIFTS
TEMPLE POSITIONS POSTED THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO BE FUNDED.
STARTING IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR TO FUNDED STARTING
AT TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
BRINGING THE TOTAL BETWEEN THIS
AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND
THEIR VISION. I'VE ALSO TO THREE
POINT NINE MILLION FOR TWENTY
SIX POSITIONS IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE WITHOUT HAVING TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
WILL MOVE TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
POLICY HOUSING WITH LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. YOU SHOULD
HAVE A HANDOUT TITLED. HIGHER
EDUCATION MAY REVISION PROPOSALS
IN FRONT OF YOU. PAGE ONECOMPARES PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT SPENDING PROPOSALS OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BETWEEN THE
JANUARY BUDGET AND MAY REVISIONS
SO IT COVERS A LOT OF WHAT WE
JUST HEARD FROM MR HANNIBAL. ALL
OF MY COMMENTS TO A FEW MAJOR
MAY REVISION PROPOSALS BUT I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE. FIRST WE FIND
MERIT WITH FOCUSING NEW I'M
GOING FUNDS ON APPORTIONMENT
INCREASES BOTH THE- ACOSTA
LIVING ADJUSTMENTS THE COLORS.
IN A REVISION AND THE BASIC
REASONS BEYOND THE CALL. SO CALL
HAS A BENEFIT OF HELPING
DISTRICTS EMPLOYEES ADDRESS OF
RISING COST PRESSURES AND THEN
ADDING FURTHER FACING CREASES TO
THE APPORTIONMENT WHICH IS KNOWN
AS THE STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA THE COLLEGES. WOULD HELP
COLLEGES WITH THOSE HIGHER COSTS
BUT ALSO WOULD HAVE THE EFFECT
OF FUNDING MORE DISTRICTS BASED
ON THE FORMULA RATHER THAN
FUNDED ACCORDING TO THE HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISIONS SO YOU TINK
IT WOULD CREATE BETTER
INCENTIVES FOR COLLEGES. SIR
STUDENTS BETTER IF THEY'RE ON
THE FORMULA NO WE THINK
PROVIDING A BASIC CREASES
REASONABLE THE LEGISLATURE
COURSE COULD CHOOSE A DIFFERENT
AUGMENTATION AMOUNT FORCES
SENATE DEMOCRATS. PLAN DOES JUST
THAT THAT PROVIDE SOMEONE HIGHER
AMOUNTS FOR THE US STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA THAT
AND WHAT'S EVEN IN THE MAY
REVISION. NOW OUT OF THE MAYOR
VISION FOCUSES ONE TIME FUNDS ON
TWO MAJOR PURPOSES DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND A DISCRETIONARY
BLOCK GRANT THAT WILL ALLOW
COLLEGES. TO USE THE MONEY TO
ADDRESS LOCAL NEEDS. ALTHOUGH WE
FIND BOTH PROPOSALS HAVE MERITS-
AS YOU BUILD THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT PACKAGING THE
OVERALL STATE BUDGET PACKAGE ARE
YOU MIGHT WANT TO CHANGE THE
ALLOCATION AMOUNT DEPENDING ON
OVERALL LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES.
AND OF COURSE OUR OFFICE IS
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU IN THE
COMING WEEKS I TO WORK WITH YOU
AND STAFF AS YOU MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SHOULD NOW MOVE ON TO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. IN GERMAN
LANGUAGE WAS THAT EVER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE SHE ANSWERS
OFFICE. ANY INTEREST THIS TIME
OF ONE OF THE LOCUSTS MY
COMMENTS AND SOME OF THE TOPICS
THAT HAVEN'T BEEN COVERED- HE
MET WITH THE- GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND THAT. ALLEY OWES
OBSERVATION THAT INVESTMENT IN
BASED RESOURCES. AND STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA RATE
INCREASES IS A LAUDABLE APPROACH
IT ALLOWS DISTRICTS TO CONTINUE
THEIR FOCUS ON ACCESS ACTUALLY
INTO. I TURNED MY MIKE. WELL YOU
DON'T SEE IT. GROWING OUT OF OUR
BALL A- THOSE SIDE BAR SHOULD
NOT TUMBLE OUT OF MY MOUTH. WE
THINK IT'S A PRUDENT APPROACH TO
INVEST IN BASE RESOURCES AND-
PER STUDENT FUNDING ADDED
INSURANCE THAT DISTRICTS CAN
CONTINUE FOCUSING ON ACCESS
EQUITY AND SUCCESS. AND NEEDING
SOME OF THESE GOALS AND THE ROAD
MAP AND THAT WAS THAT ABOUT
EXISTED SINCE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
IN THE VISION FOR SUCCESS AND
ULTIMATELY THE RECENTLY ALL WORK
IN HIGHER EDUCATION TO HELP
STUDENTS MEET THEIR END GOAL. IN
ONE TIME INVESTMENTS- WE'RE GLAD
TO SEE THAT THERE'S A COMMITMENT
TO PAY DOWN- THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG WITH ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION OUR CURRENT
BACKLOG. IS ABOUT ONE POINT NINE
NINE BARRING NO MAJOR COST
ESCALATION ISSUES I'M SO
INVESTING NOW- IN THAT AREA
REALLY MAKES A LOT OF SENSE. I
AND WE'RE ALSO GLAD TO SEE THAT
THERE ARE STILL A COMMITMENT FOR
TECHNOLOGY MODERNIZATION AND
SECURITY AS IT IS A MAJOR RISK
THAT'S ON DISTRICTS STILL HAVE
TO FACE- AS THEY ARE NOW HOLDING
A LOT MORE STUDENT DATA THE
FACULTY INFORMATION AND REALLY
RELY ON TECHNOLOGY FOR BOTH. A
STUDENT SERVICES AND ACADEMIC
ENGAGEMENT. LASTLY WANT TO CALL
ATTENTION TO SOME OF THE
INVESTMENTS IN ACADEMIC PATHWAYS
AND STREAMLINING OF THESE
INVESTMENTS REALLY ADD TO
COMMITMENTS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
MADE THROUGH LEGISLATION OR IN
PRIOR BUDGETS AND THEY JUST HOPE
DISTRICTS ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO ACTUALLY MEET
THE DELIVERABLES. COMMITTED TO I
WANT TO END BY AGAIN THANKING
YOU AND THE SENATE FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO AFFORDABLE STUDENT
HOUSING AND CAL GRANT CAN'T
REITERATE ENOUGH HOW POWERFUL
THOSE INVESTMENTS WOULD BE ON
DECK RIGHT NOW IN ADDRESSING
AFFORDABILITY ISSUES THANK YOU
HAPPY ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY. MUCH APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS OF ALL THREE THE AND
LET ME. BEGIN BY ASKING OF. OUR
QUEST OF THE DAY OF FINANCE IN
AND ONE IS. ARM WE SHOW THAT
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS WERE MORE
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC. ARE
RELATIVELY AND HOW WOULD THEY
BENEFIT FROM THE EXTRADOLLARS
THAT ARE PROPOSED HERE FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN THIS
BUDGET. I'M STANDARD ACCORDING
TO FINANCE SO I WOULD NOTE THAT
YES A LOT OF THE DOLLARS IN THIS
BUDGET ARE PROPOSED TO BE
FLEXIBLE- WHICH ALLOW COLLEGES
TO BEST MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
LOCAL POPULATION SO- MEDICAID
OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THE THAT
THIS THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION INCREASE TO THE BASE. AS
WELL AS THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR BLOCK GRANT WOULD
PROVIDE DISTRICTS WITH THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO BEST FOR
THEIR STUDENT POPULATIONS-
ESPECIALLY THE UNDERSERVED. OR-
UNDIRECTED. BY THE- THEY WOULD
ALSO NOT THE TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION THAT WERE PLAYING
SPECIFICALLY TOWARDS INCREASING
THE RATES THE STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA. IS BEING
ANOTHER INVESTMENT THAT'S GEARED
TOWARDS ENSURING THAT DISTRICTS
ARE. PROVIDED A STRONG INCENTIVE
TOWARDS AND- INCREASING. BOTH
THE AMOUNT OF ACCESS AND THE-
CERTIFICATE AND DEGREE
COMPLETION- OF ALL THEIR
STUDENTS PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT
ARE DIFFERENT I THINK IT'S STILL
AN OPEN QUESTION AND I THINK
IT'S SOMETHING WE WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THIS WEEK. A NEGOTIATE THE
BUDGET AND MOVE FORWARD I ALSO
JUST AS A COMMENT WOULD SAY- I
JUST STILL THINK WRONG GRATEFUL
FOR SORT OF THE TWO YEARS ON THE
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA. THE WHOLE- FACTOR OF
OUR COST OF LIVING- ISN'T NEVER
GOT ADDRESSED AND ISN'T FACTORED
INTO THIS AND I THINK THERE ARE
SOME THINGS AROUND A STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA WE'RE
STILL GOING TO WANT TO TALK
ABOUT. AND THEN TWO QUESTIONS
BOTH THE FINANCE. ARM IT WAS
CALLED OUT THAT THE NEXT STEP
PROGRAM FOR FOSTER KIDS- THE
MINISTRATION AS HAS RECOMMENDED
DOUBLING THE AMOUNT TO TWENTY
MILLION AND US SENATE'S PROPOSAL
WOULD DOUBLE THAT. AGAIN BUT
THEIR EXISTENCE CAP TO LIMITED
TO TEN CAMPUSES AND SO. IF THE
MONEY IS BEING INCREASED I
WONDERED IF THE ADMINISTRATION
AND ITS PROPOSAL IS. ALSO
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF THE CAP
. THANK YOU. AGAIN DAN ORDER
FROM THE FINANCE YES TO THE CAP
IS REMOVED AS PART OF THIS- AND
AS WELL ALLOWS FOR BROWN
OCCASION SPECIFICALLY TWO
CAMPUSES BUT HE GETS TO USE THE
DISTRICTS OFFER FUNDING BUT THEN
ALLOWS- ALLOCATIONS TO BE BASED
OFF ON THE CONSTABLE. I THINK
THAT WAS SOMETHING TO BE HEARD
FROM THE FIELD AS AS WELL AS-
FROM FROM SENATE HEARINGS AND
GOOD HOWEVER I WAS HOPING WE
WERE DEFINED AS THE FIELD AND
THAT OUR KIDS I KNEW YOU'D HEARD
IT FROM US SO THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT ANSWER. AND THEN
MY LAST QUESTION. IS ARM DID
MINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED TWO
HUNDRED. MILLION DOLLARS FOR
PART TIME FACULTY OF HEALTH
BENEFITS AND I DIDN'T SEE ANY
DETAIL FOR HOW THAT'S GOING IS
THERE DETAIL FOR WHAT'S ATTACHED
TO THAT AMOUNT IN THE MAY REVISE
. A SURGEON THAT THAT FUNDING IS
GONNA BE IS PROPOSED TO BE USED
THE CURRENT- PART TIME FACULTY
HEALTH INSURANCE PROGRAM
METHODOLOGY THAT THAT EXISTS- I
THINK ONE OF THE CONCERNS THAT
WE RAN INTO AS WE ARE DEVELOPING
A MARRIAGE WHERE WE'RE THINKING
THROUGH THIS PROPOSAL. IS A LACK
OF ACCESS TO DATA A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE PART
TIME FACULTY HEALTH INSURANCE
LANDSCAPE IS- ACROSS THE
DISTRICT AND ACROSS THE STATE.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WAS
INCLUDED AS PART OF THEIR VISION
THIS IS ATTACHED TO THIS-
DISCRETIONARY BLOCK GRANT
FUNDING- IS REPORTING LANGUAGE
SO WE WOULD BE COLLECTING
INFORMATION FROM DISTRICTS FROM
THE PROVISION OF HEALTH
INSURANCE THE PART TIME FACULTY.
AND SOME OTHER INFORMATION
RELATED TO THAT SO WE CAN HAVE A
BETTER SENSE OF WHAT IT IS THAT
FOR LOOKING OUT WE- THINK
THROUGH WHETHER THERE NEEDS TO
BE MODIFICATIONS TO EXISTING
PART TIME FACULTY HEALTH
INSURANCE PROGRAM- METHODOLOGY I
WOULD JUST OBSERVE THAT THAT
SORT OF CHICKEN AND THE EGG
BECAUSE OF IT TURNS OUT IT'S NOT
WORKING WE HAVE TO GO THROUGH A
YEAR. AND HAVE THEM REPORT THAT
IT'S NOT WORKING AND WE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT
BEFORE WE- APPROPRIATE THE MONEY
AND THERE WERE SOME ISSUES THAT
WE RAISED. OUR ABOUT SPECIFICITY
WHEN THIS WENT BIAS IN FEBRUARY
AND A COUPLE OF THE MORE- FOR.
EXAMPLE THERE'S A MATCH THAT
EXISTS. FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND YET THE R. GATHERED THAT
DOES THE AMOUNT IT'S PROPOSED
HERE. WE WOULD COVER THE
BENEFITS AND WOULD REQUIRE THE
MANSION AND YOU HAVE SOME BAD
JOKES THAT. ARE WORK AT TWO OR
THREE DIFFERENT CAMPUSES AND YET
ARE ONLY COUNTED FOR WHATEVER
THEY DO ONE CAMPUS AND ONCE
AGAIN OUR SORT OF SCREENED OUT
FROM THE ABILITY TO DO THIS. AND
I THINK THAT THE AND THEN THE
OTHER QUESTION WAS THAT I DON'T
THINK IT'S BEEN ADDRESSED IS
MORE INTERESTED IN WHAT THE OUT
YOUR COSTS ARE AND WERE
INTERESTED ON WHETHER OR NOT
THIS AMOUNT ACTUALLY ADDRESSES
THE ISSUE AND SO I JUST HOPE.
SINCE WE HAVE FOUR WEEKS TO LAND
THE PLANE ON THE BUDGET THATWE
CAN GET INTO SOME OF THOSE
DETAILS AND DRILL DOWN ON THEM
AND REFINE THEM AND GET SOME
MEASURE OF SPECIFICITY AND
BEFORE I GET. TEN THOUSAND PHONE
CALLS UP I SUPPORT THIS I REALLY
WANT THIS TO WORK BUT I STILL
THINK WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
DETAILS TO KNOW EXACTLY HOW IT
WOULD WORK WHO WOULD COVER
WHETHER THE OUT YEARS COVERED
WHETHER WE PROP THIS MONEY AND
IT TURNS OUT IT'S MUCH MORE THAN
WE NEED OR MUCH LESS THAN WE
NEED. AND I JUST THINK THOSE ARE
STILL QUESTIONS THAT ARE
UNANSWERED AND I HOPE WE CAN GET
TO THEM LET ME ASK MY COLLEAGUES
IF THERE'S QUESTIONS IN AND
DECIDE ON. WHAT I'M SORRY WHAT
WE HAVE A HAND FROM FINANCE WHO
MIGHT WANT TO. THAN ANY ON. SO
IT DID YOU ON HAND BECAUSE YOU
WANT ME TO RECOGNIZE YOU AND
THEN. THEN HEY YEAH I WAS JUST
GOING TO QUICKLY SAY THAT AGAIN
THIS THAT THE JUSTICE BUT
VIOLENCE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
WHEN I FEATURED IN A TIME
PROGRAM THIS WOULD JUST BE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION TO AUGMENT THE
CURRENT AMOUNT OF FUNDING SO.
UNDERSTANDINGS OF THAT THIS TWO
HUNDRED MILLION WOULD GO TOWARDS
PROVIDING A STRONG INCENTIVE
BUT- WE WOULD NEED TO REVISIT
THE QUESTION OF FUTURAMA. AND I
THINK THAT DESERVES A MEASURE
THAT'S DISAPPOINTING AND ONE WAY
BECAUSE I THINK IN FEBRUARY WE
SAID WE DIDN'T REALLY LIKE THE
WAY THE CURRENT PROGRAM WAS
STRUCTURED SO NOW THE DETAIL
COMES IN FOUR MONTHS LATER. AND
IT BASICALLY PROPS UP THE
PROGRAM THAT THAT MIGHT NOT WORK
VERY WELL SO BOB. I JUST
APPRECIATE THIS EXCHANGE- BUT I
JUST HOPE WE CAN GET AT THIS IN
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS TO MY
COLLEAGUES SEVENTY QUESTIONS.
THIS THEY'RE BOTH. SO- THANK.
ARE ALL. ARE FOR THIS. AND WE'LL
MOVE ON TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WE HAVE JACK'S
WALLED FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. ADJACENT CONSTANT
TORAHS FROM OUR LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST AND WILL WELCOME BACK
SADIO. FOR TEN AND FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WILL GO
IN THAT ORDER WILL BEGIN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD
MORNING MR MEMBERS- GENTLEMAN
FINANCE I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY- ABOUT THE REVISION THAT
SETS OUT FOR GUARDS THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. OF THE
MARRIAGE AND MAINTAINS THE 5%
BASE INCREASE OF TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION GENERAL
FUND. AND THE OTHER INVESTMENTS
INTRODUCED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
IN JANUARY AS PART OF OUR MULTI
YEAR CONTRACT WITH THE STATE.
THE REVISION ALSO PROPOSES A
NUMBER OF NEW AND- IN THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. I'LL
BEGIN BY DISCUSSING THE CONCEPTS
DEMONSTRATIONS BROUGHT FORWARD.
THEY ARE AT THREE HUNDRED
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR NEW INSTITUTE FOR IMMUNOLOGY
AND IMMUNOTHERAPY AT UCLA. THE
ADMINISTRATION ALSO PLANS TO
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL TWO
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR THIS PURPOSE IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
FISCAL YEAR. THIRTEEN MILLION
ONGOING- GENERAL FUND FOR YOU
SEE LABOR CENTERS CIVICALLY THIS
WAS INTENDED. TO PROVIDE THREE
MILLION. EACH TWO OUT OF THREE
LABOR CENTERS IN THE SYSTEM-
THREE MILLION- FOR ACTIVITIES AT
CAMPUSES ABOUT LABOR CENTERS. I
AM FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
EACH FOR- BOTH OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH PROGRAMS
LOCATED AT TO THE CAMPUS. FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
AFTER THE CENTER FOR RESPONSIBLE
TO CENTRALIZED INTELLIGENCE
VCFIRST- THE FUND RESURGENT
PROGRAMMING AROUND THE
BLOCKCHAIN BUT THREE
TECHNOLOGIES. FIVE MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND SPOKE ROUGH
JEFF I'M CENTER FOR AFRICAN
STUDIES YOU STILL LIKE- TWO
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR YOU SEE FIREFIGHTERS AND THE
CONSTRUCTION ALSO PLANS ON.
BUYING ADDITIONAL TWO MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THIS
PURPOSE IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR FISCAL YEAR.
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION ONE
HUNDRED OR FIVE THAT- SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND WHICH IS
ONGOING I DIDN'T REMEMBER IN
INSTITUTIONS OF THE ASSOCIATION
OF INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
ARGENTEUS JUST WHAT FORM IS JUST
PLATFORM- PROVIDE STUDENTS
SEEKING A TRANSFER WITH CRITICAL
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW THEIR
PERSISTENT AND- WILL TRANSFER
WILL NOT TRANSFER TO A POTENTIAL
INSTITUTION. I HAD AN INCREASE
OF TWO POINT ONE MILLION GENERAL
FUND AT THE BACK OF THE PLANE
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX TOBACCO
TAX REVENUES I DON'T SUPPORT OF
EXPLANATION OF FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR. MEDICAL EDUCATION
YOU SEE- THIS AGREES WELL
MAINTAINED A LEVEL OF RESOURCES
AVAILABLE FOR GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION AT FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS- THE MAIN REVISION ALSO
INCLUDES A FEW CHANGES TO OUR
EXISTING PROGRAMS AND PROPOSALS
OPERATE- THE MOST NOTABLE-
CHANGES INCLUDING. ADDING
LANGUAGE TO BE USED- DIRECTING
EASY TO COORDINATE WITH. STATE
AGENCIES IN APARTMENTS THE GUY
THE ONE MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND PROVIDED FOR FORMER
RESEARCHER GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO
BETTER ALIGN THE STATE'S NEEDS-
SOME OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE. HAS
OUT RACES- INITIALLY PASTS. THAT
WE WILL TO THEM AND TOOK SOME
ACTION. I THERE IS ALSO LANGUAGE
. TO THE A ONE TIME HIGHER
PACKAGE TO PROVIDE LEGAL OF THE
BONDS THAT RELATE TO USE KNOCKED
THAT- WE ALSO HAVE- THAT WOULD
EXPAND THE USE BAY NEEDS FUNNY
PROVIDES BUDGET. I TO INCLUDE
HIGH HI PRODUCTS AND USE- THERE
ARE OTHER CHANGES A DRY LETTER
ABOUT ALL FROM SICK TIME NOT GET
ABOUT ONE HALF HOUR QUESTIONS
ABOUT THEM AS YOU MOVE THROUGH
THIS- HEARING SO I THINK YOU
HAVE JUNE BEGAN. I WILL TAKE
QUESTIONS PERFECT TIME THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL MOVE ON. TO THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. I GET MORE DECENT.
SLEDGES ANALYST OFFICE. IF YOU
FOLLOW ALONG THE ALLEY- HANDOUT
ARE. TO SHOWS THESE. YOU SEE A
GENERAL FUND PROPOSE UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET NAY REVISION.
FOR THE SECOND TIME I'M GOING TO
FOCUS ON WHAT IS BY FAR THE
LARGEST PROPOSAL IN THE REVISION
WHICH IS THE U. C. L. A.
INSTITUTE FOR IMMUNOLOGY ENEMY
IMMUNO THERAPY. I'M GENERALLY WE
THINK IT'S REASONABLE THAT THE
STATE- SPEND ONE TIME FUNDING
ON. CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS THAT
HELP ADDRESS MANY OF THE
PRESSING ISSUES THAT. THIS
COMMITTEE HAS DISCUSSED IN. THE
PREVIOUS- MONTHS. THIS PROPOSAL
IS A BIT OF A MISSED OPPORTUNITY
. IN THAT IT DOESN'T ADDRESS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE OR SEISMIC
SAFETY WHICH ARE KEY ISSUES THIS
COMMITTEE HAS TALKED ABOUT. IT
DOESN'T EXPAND FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING WHICH
IS ANOTHER ISSUE THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS DISCUSSED IT ALSO
DOES NOT APPEAR TO- X. EXPANDED
NORMAN CAPACITY- YOU SEE AND
THEREFORE DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE
FOCUSED ON EXPANDING ACCESS FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. ALSO BASED
ON OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
FACILITY IT APPEARS TO COVER
SIMILAR SCOPE OF ACTIVITIES THAT
EXISTING THAT STATE FUNDED
INSTITUTES ARE YOU SEE ALREADY
UNDERTAKE. AND JULIAN
MINISTRATION HAS NOT SHARED MANY
KEY DETAILS AROUND THE PROPOSAL.
FOR THIS REASON WE RECOMMEND YOU
REJECT THIS PROPOSAL AND
REDIRECT THE FUNDS TOWARDS OTHER
HIGH CAPITAL OUTLAY PRIORITIES.
I CAN THINK OF TIME WILL KEEP MY
COMMENTS THERE BUT HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ABOUT
ANY OF THE PROPOSALS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- ARM. WILL NOW MOVES
TO THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
. THEY ARE RETURNING FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. BUT WE
THINK THE GOVERNOR FOR
CONSIDERING YOU SEE FOR
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS AND FOR
THE SAKE OF TIME I'M AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS OR TO ADDRESS ANY
OF THE SPECIFIC PROPOSALS THAT
YOU WOULD LIKE TO HEAR MORE
ABOUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MMHM. LET ME JUST
S. TWO QUESTIONS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
FIRST ONE IS THAT. ARE IT WAS
RECOMMENDED- TO DO THIRTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE UC LABOR
CENTERS. AND THE SENATE PROPOSED
THE SAME AMOUNT BUT IT WAS
UNCLEAR. OF WHETHER THE DETAIL
MATCHES. BASED ON WHAT WE WERE
ASKING AND YOU'RE ASKING ARE WE
ASKING FOR THE SAME THING. SO
CENTER YES. OKAY UNDER ON BLESS
YOU FOR YEARS TO SYNCHRONOUS.
IT'S APPRECIATED AND THEN THE
OTHER QUESTION I HAD FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES THERE'S A
RATHER LARGE PROPOSAL. ALSO THAT
WAS IN THE UNIVERSITY REQUEST
FOR THE ELECTRIFICATION OF THE
UC BERKELEY CAMPUS IS THAT
SOMETHING YOU CONSIDERED. IS ANY
PIECE OF THAT IN HERE AND
ANYWAY. I DON'T BELIEVE IT IS
CENTER HAVING EVER FOR THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT PROPOSAL
UC BERKELEY. OKAY THAT'S GREAT.
THAT HE DOESN'T BELIEVE IT'S IN
THE PROPOSAL AND HE WOULD BE
HAPPY TO HAVE A CONVERSATION. I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT WAS PROPOSES
FROM THE MEMBERSHIP NOW YES I'M
SORRY I HAD ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
. NOT UNDERSTAND YOUR ANSWER AND
I WAS EXPLAINING TO HIM ON THE
MARK SO. OKAY OF A I THINK WE
HAD MAJOR DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE
OVERALL YOU SEE BUDGET EARLIER
BUT LET ME ASK MY COLLEAGUES IF
THEY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY
BELIEVE IT OR NOT WE'RE GOOD SO
I THANK YOU AND I KNOW THAT WE
LAID OUT WHERE THERE WILL BE.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FURTHER
DISCUSSION. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS TO
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM. WE HAVE JENNIFER LOUIS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WHICH THE KING FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AND I LIST TO RAIMES DORMAN BY
SAN JUAN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM BUT
WE'LL HEAR FROM WHOMEVER THEY
THINK IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO
HEAR FROM. EITHER ONE OR BOTH
AND WILL BEGIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CARE GOOD
MORNING- JENNIFER LOU WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE MAY
REVISION PROVIDES A 5% BE. PART
IN THE MAKE MAYOR VERSION
MAINTAINS THE 5% BASE INCREASE
OF TWO HUNDRED ELEVEN POINT ONE
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND OTHER
BUT AS MISMAS INTRODUCED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION IN JANUARY AS
PART OF A MULTI YEAR CONTRACT
WITH CSU. THE MAY REVISION
PROVIDES A TOTAL OF A HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR MILLION ONE TIME
JOURNAL PLAN TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM. THESE INVESTMENTS CAN
FOLLOWING EIGHTY MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND TO EXPAND THE
SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY
BRAWLEY CENTER. SIXTY SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TOWARD CONSTRUCTION
OF THIS USED TO FOURTEEN
ENGINEERING AND COMPUTER SCIENCE
INNOVATION HUB. AN ADDITIONAL
TWENTY FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
EQUIPMENT AND FACILITIES FOR CSU
UNIVERSITY FARMS FOR COMBINED
INVESTMENT OF SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR THE PURPOSE. FOR
THIS PURPOSE WITH THE
AUGMENTATION A FIFTY MILLION
FROM GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. FOLLOWED
BY ONE POINT FIVE MILLION ONE
TIME TRYING TO FIND THE SUPPORT
A FIRST STAR FOSTER YOUTH COHORT
AT POST ISSUE NORTHRIDGE AND CSU
EAST BAY. LASTLY THE MAY
REVISION ALSO PROVIDES FUNDS.
FOR BESIDES UNIVERSITY FARMS
FULLER TEN AND SAN DIEGO STATE
THE GOVERNORS AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET OF EIGHTY THREE MILLION
ONE TIME FROM A FINE. FOR THE
CSU BAKERSFIELD INNOVATION
CENTER WE INCLUDED LANGUAGE TO
EXEMPT THESE ITEMS FROM
EDUCATION CODE EIGHTY NINE SEVEN
SEVENTY THREE AS TO NOT SEE THE
ON THE PERCENT OF CSU STERN
OFFENSE THE CREATION OF
CORPORATION. THEY CAN BE
EXPANDED FOR PAY YOU GO CAP
OUTLAY PER. WITH THE ACTUAL
CONCLUDE MY- TO HAPPEN ANSWER
ANY. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WILL MOVE ON TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
GOOD MORNING CHIANG MEMBERS
SPEAKING WITH L. A. M. H. THREE
N. B. L. A. R. HAND OUT YOUR
FEARS I STEPHANIE REVISION
PROPOSALS FOR CSU. AT THAT
APARTMENT FINANCE INDICATED THAT
LARGEST BOZELL'S ARE ONE
TECHNICALS. FOR SPECIFIC CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS. WE SPENDING
COUPLE CAN BENEFITS RIGHT NOW
BOTH IN ADDRESSING THE ISSUES
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. AND IN
ADDRESSING THE STATE'S BUDGETARY
REQUIREMENTS. WE NEVER MUST HAVE
A FEW CONSENT ABOUT THE SPECIFIC
PROJECTS THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED FOR CSU. FIRST AS
REFERENCED IN THE UC ITEM THE
LEGISLATURE HAS IDENTIFIED
VARIOUS CAPITAL OUTLAY
PRIORITIES FOR UNIVERSITIES
RANGING FROM ADDRESSING DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOGS EXPANDING
AND GROWING CAPACITY TO FIND
MORE AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING
. THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS FOR
SEE IF YOU HAVE A LOT BAY DON'T
TELL CASES LINE WITH THESE
PRIORITIES. MOREOVER WE DON'T
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION CITED A
STRONG RATIONALE FOR
PRIORITIZING THESE PARTICULAR
PROJECTS OF OTHER PROJECTS THAT
YOU AYE BECAUSE PRIORITIES. THE
SOME OF THE PROPOSED PROJECTS
NÚMERO VISION ARE NOT IN CSU'S
MULTIYEAR CAPITAL OUTLAY PLAN.
IT'S JUST US THAT IF YOU HAVE
NOT PREVIOUSLY IDENTIFIED THESE
AMONG THE SYSTEM'S HIGHEST
CAPITAL OUTLAY PRIORITIES.
MOREOVER IT MAY SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE MONKEY PLANNING THAT
IS GOING INTO THESE PROJECTS
TODAY. THE FINAL QUESTION US IS
MOST CONCERNING AS IT RELATES TO
THE SAN DIEGO STATE PROBABLY
CENTER. AS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
OBJECTIVES. ANY OF THE
GOVERNOR'S CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROPOSALS FOR CSU WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
REDIRECTING THESE FUNDS TO OTHER
CAPITAL PURPOSES EIGHTEEN HIGHER
PRIORITY. FOR EXAMPLE THAT COULD
INCLUDE DEBT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE VAST IN FACT SENATE.
DEMOCRATS PLAN- HAS PROVIDED
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING FOR. THANK
YOU HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW MOVE ON
TO THE CSU SYSTEM. SENATOR
LAYERED- THIS IS RYAN STORM I'LL
MAKE IT BRIEF COMMENT ABOUT THE
OPERATIONAL SIDE THE PROPOSAL
THERE ABOUT THE FOSTER YOUTH AND
THEN I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SEE IF YOU BY SAN
JUAN TO COMMENT ABOUT THE
CAPITAL PROJECTS. SO VERY
BRIEFLY- ON- THE- THE FOSTER
YOUTH YOU KNOW WE SHARE THE
CONCERN RAISED BY THE L. A. L.
ON THE ONE TIME BONUS YOU ALSO
FOR THE EAST BAY AND NORTHRIDGE
CAMPUSES. IN PARTICULAR OF THE
ONE TIME NATURE THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD CREATE ONGOING COST
PRESSURES TO SUSTAIN THOSE
PROGRAMS AFTER THE FUNDS EXPIRE
IN ALSO THE PROGRAM IS NOT A
PRIORITY OF EITHER CAMPUS TODAY.
SO IT. DOWNTURN OVER TO BUY FOR
COLLINS. THANK YOU RYAN GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS BY SEN ONE
THE SYSTEM VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
CAPITAL PLANNING DESIGN
CONSTRUCTION THE CSU. CSU
APPRECIATES IT THE
ADMINISTRATION SUPPORT FOR THE
ONE TIME CAPITAL FUNDS FOR
PROJECTS THAT SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY'S PROBABLY CAMPUS
NECESSITY FULLERTON FOR TO
PROMOTE RESEARCH. INNOVATION
WORKING WITH INDUSTRY AN
EXPANDED STUDENT ACCESS TO
ENSURING DISCIPLINES. IN
ADDITION THE MAY REVISE FOR
INITIAL TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR
AGRICULTURE. FACILITIES WILL
IMPROVE FARM FACILITIES SUPPORT
CLIMATE CHANGE APPLIED RESEARCH
AND WAYS TO MAKE CALIFORNIA'S
FOOD SUPPLY MORE RESILIENT. THE
CSU RECCA AND APPRECIATES THE
SENATE SWELLED TO WORK PLAN TO
INCREASE THE ISSUES DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE SPENDING BY NINE
HUNDRED MILLION. IN ANY EVENT
THE SENATE CHOOSES NOT TO FOR
THE MAY REVISED PROJECTS THE SIX
THE L. A. AS RECOMMENDATION TO
REDIRECT THESE FUNDS. TO THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG
WITH THE OPTION PREFERRED BY THE
CSE AND GIVEN THE SIZE OF THE
BACKLOG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO QUESTIONS AND LET ME-
ASK A COUPLE FIRST OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HOW DID-
HOW DO YOU ENVISION A CSU
ADDRESSING THE CARD COMPENSATION
AND BARGAINING ISSUES WITHOUT A
- I'M A REVISION PROPOSAL TO
AUGMENT THE BASE INCREASE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION MISTER
KERR- D. AS MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
MENTIONED EARLIER REGARDING THE
CONTACTS IS SUBSTANTIAL YEAR
OVER YEAR INCREASES PROPOSED
THROUGH THE MULTI YEAR CONTACT
SUPPORT CSU OPERATIONS PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY AND PREDICTABILITY
FOR CSU TO FIND ONGOING NEEDS
ACCORDING TO EXPERTISE AND
REPRESENTS SOME THE LARGEST ALL
JUST AND I'LL JUST. I'LL JUST
STIPULATE THAT YOU ALL MADE THAT
SAME STATEMENT FOR EVERYTHING
WHAT WHAT WHAT WE'LL JUST DO
THAT AND ALL JUST TO BE LIKE
THAT WE SAID INFLATION IS. AT 8%
IN YOUR PROPOSALS AT FIVE AND-
EVERYBODY ELSE HAS TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DEAL WITH IT. OF THE
OTHER QUESTION I WAS GOING TO
ASK FOR FINANCE IS. ARM IT WAS
MENTIONED OF FOSTER YOUTH
AUGMENTATION FOR CSU EAST BAY
AND NORTHRIDGE AND I WAS CURIOUS
WHY THOSE TWO CAMPUSES WERE
SINGLED OUT AND WHETHER THERE
WERE NEEDS AT OTHER CAMPUSES OR
WHETHER WAS A COMPETITIVE
PROCESS- WHAT WAS THE PROCESS
LEADING UP TO A RECOMMENDATION
FOR JUST THOSE TWO CAMPUSES. ON
THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION MR CARE. THE FIRST ARE
COUNTING HE'S CURRENTLY SIR
FOURTEEN CAMPUSES. NATIONWIDE
AND FOR CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY
THE CABINETS ARE CURRENTLY
ESTABLISH AT UCLA CSU SAMBAR
DINO AND AS SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY WITH THE LADDER- FROM
FOR SACRAMENTO STATE BEING
FUNDED IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT. ON A ONE TIME BASIS
THE MEMBER VISION PROPOSES
PROPOSES ONE TERM RESOURCES TO
ESTABLISH THE FIRST STARK HORROR
AT EASTBAY AND NORTHRIDGE TO
EXPAND THE PROGRAMS REACH AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
PROVIDE NEW COHORTS TO POPULOUS
AREAS IN BOTH NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. OKAY MORE
WHAT WILL CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT
THAT A LITTLE BIT THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THE RESPONSE ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. THERE'S NO QUESTIONS
FROM CENTER ROAD CHAU BOGAN
WAITING TO SEE IF SENATOR MAN
HAS ANY QUESTIONS YEAH I GUESS
I GUESS I JUST WANNA GO OUT AND
FOLLOW UP ON ON SENATORS WITH
LETTERS QUESTION AND THIS
APPLIES FOR BOTH THE UC'S NCS
USING THIS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE BUT- GIVEN THAT WE HAVE
A IN RECENT MONTHS SINCE THE
ORIGINAL JANUARY BUDGET SEEN
BOTH- SIGNS OF LINGERING HIGH
INFLATION. I AS WELL AS
INCREASES IN THE SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES IN THE SURPLUS AMOUNT-
WHAT WAS THAT. ADMINISTRATION'S
RATIONALE IN NOT INCREASING
EITHER THAT THE BASE INCREASE OR
WHAT I SEE IS A RELATIVELY
PALTRY INVESTMENT IN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AS COMPARED TO THE
SENATE'S PROPOSAL. AND WHO DOES
YOUR PARTNER RECREATIONS
DEPARTMENT AND OTHERS WHAT WHY
WHY DIDN'T YOU GUYS INCREASE WHY
ARE. WHY IS THE STATE SENATE'S
PROPOSAL SO MUCH HIGHER THAN
YOURS GIVEN THAT WE'VE SEEN A
REALLY MASSIVE INCREASE IN THE
SURPLUS- AND WE'VE ALSO SEEN.
FAIRLY HIGH INFLATION AND SIGNS
THAT THAT'S GOING TO BE AROUND
FOR SOME TIME- WHY DID WHY DID
ADMINISTRATION CHOOSE NOT TO
INCREASE THE BASE INCREASE- AND
AGAIN MAKE A- RELATIVELY MODEST
INVESTMENT FOR MAINTENANCE WHEN
WE KNOW THAT THIS YEAR'S USING
UC'S HAVE HAD VERY SIGNIFICANT.
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE NEEDS.
JENNIFER THE WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I CAN'T SPEAK TO THE
COMPACT AGREEMENT REGARDING WITH
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA BUT
I WILL. SPEAK TO. THE
MINISTRATIONS AGREEMENT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY- THE
MINISTRATION OF REAFFIRMS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL OF
THE SUBSTANTIAL 5% YEAR OVER
YEAR INCREASE AS MY COLLEAGUE
REBECCA KIRK IN. FINANCE HAD
MENTIONED EARLIER AND WHILE THEM
THE MINISTRATION DOES HAVE AN
AGREEMENT IT IS THE STARTING
POINT. FOR SUBSEQUENT BUDGETS
AND THEN- FOR THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS DURING THE TERMS OF THAT
COMPACT- WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT
LEGISLATORS ROLE OF AS PART OF
THE TRADITIONAL BUDGET PROCESS
DISCUSSION. I THINK WE'RE JUST
HAVING THE SAME DISCUSSION AGAIN
SO I APPRECIATE THAT ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS ON THE- OF THE CSU
SYSTEM. SEEING NONE LET ME THANK
OUR WITNESSES WE APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE THE NEW AND JUSTICE
PEOPLE IT JUST JOINED RECENTLY
WE HAD A RATHER ROBUST
DISCUSSION ON ALL THREE LEVELS
OF HIGHER READ AND TE SITUATION
AT THE BEGINNING BEFORE WE WENT
TO THE INDIVIDUALS ARE SEGMENTS
OF DON'T THINK WE'RE BRUSHING BY
THIS QUICKLY. ARE WILL GO TO
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE- WHICH IS
VARIOUS PROPOSALS IN THE MAY
REVISE- AND IT IT'S RELATED TO
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION WILL
HEAR FROM GABRIELA CHAVEZ OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LISA CAME
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE SUBJECT BREMNER FROM THE-
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION AND WILL BEGIN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE.
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'D
NEVER LET CHÁVEZ WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ALL BEGIN
MY PRESENTATION TODAY BY GOING
OVER SOME CHANGES IN THE
CONFERENCE IN A COMMISSION'S
BUDGET. AND SOME TRANSCEND THE
COCHRAN PROGRAM. IN THE
REVISIONS FOR THE CURRENT
PROGRAM. THANKS AN ESTIMATED
DECREASE OF TWO HUNDRED. EIGHT
POINT NINE MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. IN A DECREASE OF
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
POINT NINE MILLION ONGOING
GENERAL FUND EIGHTEEN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. AND
THIS IS BASED ON REVISED
ESTIMATES OF NEW RENEWAL COCHRAN
WHAT HE'S- THIS INCREMENTAL CASE
THAT ADJUSTMENTS REFLECT MODEST
OVER YEARS OF GROWTH IN THIS
COMMITTEE CONTEXT MANAGERS
COMPARED TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROJECTIONS. SIMILARLY AS
WE OBSERVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THE LAST THREE YEARS CHAU
IN MORE MODEST YEAR OVER YEAR
GROWTH THIS GATE WAS THE CLIENT
CAN BE ATTRIBUTED TO LOWER RATE
LASTLY AT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THE COMPANY
STATE UNIVERSITY. THAT JUST
MEANT IS ALSO A REFLECTION OFFER
CONTINUED EFFORTS- TO GET A
BETTER INFORMATION FOR ME. HIS
I'M A REVISION IT WOULD RECEIVE
BETTER ESTIMATES FOR- AARON YOU
STUDENTS AND AS WE HAVE MORE
EXPERIENCE WITH THAT COMPANY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE EXPANSION
PROGRAM WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE
BETTER ESTIMATES. ONE NINETEEN
ANY CONTINUES TO HAVE A NEGATIVE
IMPACT IN A MOMENT. THE FINANCE
BELIEVES THAT THESE THE CLIENTS
HAD TEMPORARILY WE WILL SEE THE
TRANSVERSE AND IN YOUR FRIDGE.
ADDITIONALLY THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES FOUR HUNDRED AND TEN
THOUSAND ONGOING GENERAL FUND.
AND THREE POSITIONS TO SUPPORT
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW
FINANCIALLY PROGRAMS AND THOSE
AMENDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET. NUMBER RIGHT BUT AT SOME
OF THE TRILOGY THAT WERE
PROPOSED IN FOR ME REVISION. LET
ME PROVISIONAL TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT IS PALATABLE MORE
DYNAMIC SYSTEM TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR
TRANSFER COMMITMENTS. MADE BY
MEMBERS OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES. IT
ALSO CLARIFIES THE CRITERIA BY
WHICH THIS INSTITUTIONS CAN
MAINTAIN THE CURRENT NO WORK AND
NINE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY. IN THE ABSENCE OF TIME I
WOULD LIKE TO BRIEFLY IN BECAUSE
OF THE RIVER BEHIND CLOSED
SEVERAL TECHNICAL TRAILER BILL.
TO AMEND THE GOLDEN STATE
TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM SHE SAID
THE GRANT PROGRAM AND THE
STUDENT LOAN PAYMENT BEFORE THE
FOUR RATE ENCOURAGE. I'M HAPPY
TO DISCUSS THOSE FIGHTERS AB HOW
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF MOVE ON TO THE-
ANALYST'S OFFICE. THANK YOU. IF
YOU'RE FOLLOWING ALONG THE L. A-
HANDOUT IN YOUR VISION PROPOSALS
FOR DESTINY CHRISTIAN APPEAR ON
PAGE FOUR. I FOR THE PERMANENT
FINANCE NOTED THAT LARGEST
ADJUSTMENT IS ADD DOWNWARD
ADJUSTMENT TO THE COST ESTIMATE
FOR THE HEALTHCARE GRANT. WE
THINK THAT THE REVISED COST
ESTIMATES ARE REASONABLE BASED
ON THE MOST RECENT PROGRAM DATA
AVAILABLE. WE ALSO RECOMMEND
APPROVING THE THREE NEARLY
BECAUSE CONDITIONS INCLUDING
MAYOR VISIONS. THE COMMISSION
HAS THE RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT
THE FINANCIALLY EXTENSIONS
ENACTED LAST. REGARDING THE MANY
TRAILER BILL PROPOSALS FOR THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION IN JUST A
TIME I WILL WALK THROUGH ALL OF
THE ONE THAT WE HAVE THE MOST
NOTABLE CONCERNS WHICH RELATES
TO THE GOLDEN STATE TEACHER
GRANT PROGRAM. WHICH I BELIEVE
WILL BE HEARD LATER THIS MORNING
AS PART OF THE COUPON SECTION.
AND HAVING SAID WE HAVE TO TAKE
QUESTIONS ABOUT ANY OF THESE
PROPOSALS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL MOVE ON TO THE-
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. GOOD MORNING SURE
LAYERED AND SENATORS JAKE
BRUNNER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION A GOOD TO BE WITH
YOU- THIS MORNING I SHOULD NOTE
AS A DISCLAIMER OF RECEIVED AND-
CONNECTION UNSTABLE WARNING FROM
ZOOM SO HOPEFULLY YOU CAN HEAR
ME ALL RIGHT. BUT WE CAN HEAR
YOU JUST FINE AN AFTER MY- MY
FAUX PAS WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S PERSON I
WILL NOT BE COMMENTING ON YOUR
UNSTABLE CONNECTION. GREAT WELL
I'M MEETING LOT OF CLEAR FOR
NOW- ALTERNATIVE FOR YOU I'M
ACTUALLY YOUR OPENING COMMENTS
CHAIR LAYERED- IN WHICH HE NOTED
SEVERAL ELEMENTS AND THE PROPS
ARE MISSING FROM THE MAY
REVISION THAT WOULD HELP US
BETTER SERVE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
I SUGGEST ANOTHER KEY COMPONENT
THAT WE WOULD AT THE COMMISSION
HOPE TO SEE REFLECTED IN THE
FINAL ADOPTED BUDGET FOR THE
UPCOMING YEAR WOULD BE REFORM OF
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS. WHAT
WILL NOT ONLY HELP US FURTHER
OUR WORK TOWARDS CREATING DEBT
FREE PATHWAYS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION FOR STUDENTS BUT WILL
ALSO HELP FURTHER THE GOALS THAT
ARTICULATED IN A COMPACT AND THE
COMPACT PLUS- WE KNOW THAT HAS
SPARKED COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PARTNERS ALLUDED TO THAT-
STUDENTS ARE CHOOSING NOT TO
ENROLL IN LARGE PART DUE TO
AFFORDABILITY AND SURVEY DATA
THAT'S BEEN COLLECTED THAT CITED
AS THE TOP- CONCERN THAT
PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS HAVE WE
ALSO KNOW FROM RESEARCH THAT.
RECEIPT OF A CAL GRANT DOES NOT
EMPOWER OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS TO COMPLETE MORE UNITS
IN A YEAR AND A PERSISTENT
HIGHER RATES AND OF COURSE-
THERE'S ADDITIONAL SURVEY DATA
THAT DEMONSTRATE THAT THE
STUDENTS THAT I HAVE MOST
EXPERIENCED COST INCREASES OVER
THE COURSE OF THE COMING
NINETEEN PANDEMIC OUR OUR LOWEST
INCOME STUDENTS- SO WE HOPE TO
WORK WITH THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE TO ENACT HEALTH
REFORM AND THIS YEAR'S. BUDGET
ALTER MY COMMENTS NOW TO THE OF
RESOURCES THAT HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR IN THE
MAY REVISION- TOWARDS- THIS
UNIQUE COMMISSIONS
ADMINISTRATION ON OUR PROGRAMS
WE'RE CERTAINLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
RECOGNITION OF A GREATER
CAPACITY NEEDS OUT THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION AND FOR THIS
TOTAL OF EIGHT NEW POSITIONS
HOWEVER WE DO NOT FEEL THAT THIS
ADEQUATELY ADDRESSES OUR
RESOURCES NEEDED TO MAINTAIN
HIGH QUALITY EXPERIENCES FOR
STUDENTS CAMPUS PARTNERS AND
STAFF IN OUR INITIAL REQUEST
STUDENT MISSION I THOUGHT TWENTY
SEVEN POSITIONS AS WELL AS ONE
TIME FUNDING. FOR IT CONSULTING
SERVICES COMPARED TO THE
COMMISSION'S BUDGET PRIOR TO
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THERE'S. AN
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS AND FINE IS THAT
WE ARE MANAGE. WHEN CONSIDERING
BOTH THE- MAY REVIEW FUND LEVEL
AS WELL AS ONCE FUNDS. WERE
APPROPRIATED LAST YEAR AND WE
ARE STILL ADMINISTERING AND IN
THE CASE OF THE TWO OF THOSE ONE
TIME PROGRAMS ACTUALLY HAVE
LIFESPANS. FOR NINE YEARS. THIS
REPRESENTS THE 69% INCREASE IN
THE FUNDS THAT THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION IS MANAGING RELATIVE
TO PRIOR TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
OVER THAT SAME TIME PERIOD THE
COMMISSIONS RECEIVED ONLY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS MORE IN IT-
ANNUAL OPERATIONS FUNDING.
REPRESENTING WHAT'S A 14%
INCREASE OVER THAT FUNDING LEVEL
PRIOR TO TWENTY ONE. AND OVER
THAT TIME PERIOD THERE IS A 0%
INCREASE IN OUR STAFF AT FORTY
AND IN THE NEW POSITION- FOR THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION.
WORKFORCE THRILLED TO SEE THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE FOCUS
ON COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY- BUT OF
COURSE WOULD NOTE THAT THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION MUST BE
ADEQUATELY RESOURCE TO
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTTHESE
PROGRAMS. AND MEET THE NEEDS. OF
OUR STUDENTS AND INSTITUTIONAL
PARTNERS. THE COMMISSION'S ALSO.
OTHER IN WORK STRING BY STE.
CHANGES I FELT THE STATE AND
FEDERAL LEVEL. I WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE NEW UNIVERSAL
APPROACH TO HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS
APPLYING FOR FINANCIAL AID. THAT
WILL TAKE EFFECT THIS FALL AND
WE ANTICIPATE SIGNIFICANT GROWTH
AND REQUESTS. FROM STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES AS WELL AS HIGH SCHOOLS
THAT WILL BE HELPING STUDENTS
APPLY FOR AID STARTING THIS
FALL. THIS CREATES DEMAND
SPURRED THE STUDENT COMMISSIONS
SUPPORT STAFF TRAINING EFFORTS
DATA SHARING WITH K. TWELVE.
OUTREACH MATERIALS AND RESOURCES
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS ALSO
MOVING FORWARD WITH STREAMLINING
THE FREE APPLICATION FOR FEDERAL
STUDENT AID THAT BACKS UP. TO
MAKE THAT A SHORTER. PROCESS FOR
STUDENTS WHICH IS A GREAT THING.
HOWEVER THESE CHANGES REQUIRE
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION TO
UPDATE OUR GRANT PROCESSING
SYSTEMS AS WELL AS THE MAKE A
LANDING CHANGES TO THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT
APPLICATION. THAT WE ADMINISTER
FOR IMMIGRANT AND UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS. GIVEN THESE TO MAKE UP
PROJECTS AS WELL AS THE
CONTINUED WORK ACROSS OUR OTHER
EFFORTS- PARTICULARLY FOR I. T.
DIVISION I HAVE TO POINT OUT
THAT THE STUDENT COMMISSION
REQUEST FOR SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND. ONE TIME. FOR IT
CONSULTING SERVICES WAS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE MAY REVISION AND
WE LOOK AT THAT AS A REALLY
CRITICAL INVESTMENT- TOWARDS
ENSURING THAT WE CAN. MOVE
FORWARD WITH THOSE PROJECTS-
WITHOUT CREATING RISKS FROM
DIVERTING IT STAFF FROM OTHER
EFFORTS. IN CLOSING ALL NOTE
THAT THESE NEED TO REFLECT THE
CURRENT WORKLOAD AT THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION AND DO NOT
CONSIDER OTHER POTENTIAL BUDGET
FOR LEGISLATIVE ACTION. AND WE-
ASK THE LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR
TO CAN. CAN YOU TO CONSIDER
INVESTMENTS OF ORDER PROGRAMS
WITH THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
CAPACITY IN MIND. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I THINK
FOR MYSELF. IN LIEU OF ASKING
QUESTIONS I WOULD SAY THAT IN
THIS TESTIMONY MAY REVISE JUST
CRIED AIRED. AND WE REALLY AIRED
THE SENATE PROPOSAL. AND WHEN WE
HAD THE HEARING THAT WAS EARLIER
IN THE YEAR WE REALLY STEP
THROUGH. BOB WANTING TO KNOW
ABOUT THE EQUITY FRAMEWORK IF
THERE WERE CONVERSATIONS AFTER
LAST YEAR'S- OF VETO OF THAT
PARTICULAR ASSEMBLY BILL ARE
ALSO ABOUT JUST THE DESIRE OF
THE SENATE TO HAVE A BROADER
COVERAGE AND FINANCIAL SUPPORT
FOR STUDENT AID AND I THINK SAID
THAT WHAT THE COMMENTS- JUST
OUTLINED- IS IT THIS IS A
DISCUSSION THAT WILL GO ON
INTERNET IN A MAJOR WAY OVER THE
NEXT FOUR WEEKS SO I WOULD JUST
CALL OUT THOSE. THAT HISTORY AND
TWO OR THE TESTIMONY WE JUST HAD
AND- WATSON IN THE SENATE BUDGET
PROPOSAL SO LET ME ASK MY
COLLEAGUES IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS HERE. I DO
NOT HAVE FOR OUR QUESTIONS- OR
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES ARE
WHEN WE THANK EVERYONE WHO IS
HERE FOR ISSUE FIVE WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO ISSUE SIX WITH THE
WHICH IS THE HASTINGS COLLEGE OF
THE LAW. WE HAVE PROJECTS WILD
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SITUATION CONSTANT TOURISTS FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
DAVID SEWARD CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER AT. OF THE COLLEGE OF
THE LAW AND WILL GO IN THAT
ORDER AND BEGIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WELCOME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. BACK THIS
SHARE OF GOOD MORNING AGAIN
JACK'S WALL. ARE IN FINANCE THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSES TO
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS I EASY
SINCE COLLEGE OF THE LAW. THE
FIRST IS NINETY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE ONE HUNDRED MCALLISTER
STREET PROJECT- ONE HUNDRED.
STREET IS A MULTI USE BUILDING
THAT'S WHAT STUDENT HOUSING AT
AT AT AND ACADEMIC SPACE OF THE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTED IN NINETEEN
TWENTY NINE- IS IN NEED OF
CRITICAL FRUIT MINCE.
PARTICULARLY RELATING TO SEISMIC
BREASTS- THESE RESOURCES WILL
MAKE THE PROJECT FINANCIALLY
VIABLE ALONG WITH OTHER
FINANCING ORGANIZED BY
HOUSTON'S- THE SECOND INVESTMENT
IS EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND ONE TIME GENERAL FUND.
JUST FOR COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
CHANGING THE NAME OF THE
INSTITUTION- ARE LETTER ALSO
INCLUDES PROVISIONAL BUDGET
LANGAT BILL BILL LANGUAGE THAT.
RESTRICTS THE RELEASE OF THESE
BONDS UNTIL THE PROCESS OF ANY
CHANGES READ IT. THANK YOU AND I
AM READY TO ANY AT THE PAN-
PERCENT. THANK YOU MUCH WILL
MOVE TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. USING
CONCENTRATORS DELEO- IF YOU'RE
FOLLOWING ALONG ON THE L. A. YOU
HAND OUT STILL WORD NOW ON PAGE
FIVE IN THAT SHOWS THE- GENERAL
FUND PROPOSALS FOR HASTINGS
UNDER GOVERNOR'S BUDGET NAY
REVISION FOR THE SECOND TIME I'M
GOING TO FOCUS ON- WHAT IS THE
LARGEST OF THE TO ME RVISION
PROPOSALS WHICH IS THE
MACALESTER TOWER RENOVATION
PROJECT. THE PROJECT IS A
CRITICAL SEISMIC RENOVATION
PROJECT AND HAS MUCH BETTER BACK
UP AND MANY OTHER MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS. THAT'S I WANTED TO
RAISE THREE ISSUES FOR THE
COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION. THE
FIRST ON THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING TO FUND THIS PROJECT
OUTSIDE OF. THE AFFORDABLE
STUDENT HOUSING GRANTS- PROGRAM
. NOW IF YOU RECALL HE SINGS DID
SUBMIT THIS PROJECT. AS AN
APPLICATION FOR THAT GRANT
PROGRAM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- IN MARCH DETERMINE THAT
THAT- PROJECT WAS INELIGIBLE FOR
GRANT FUNDING. ANALYST BECAUSE
OF THE LEGISLATURE IS NOT
FINALIZED ON HOW IT WOULD LIKE
TO ALLOCATE AS FOR THE STUDENT
HOUSING GRANTS IT'S DIFFICULT TO
ASSESS HOW THIS PRODUCT PROJECT-
COMPARES IN TERMS OF PRIORITY
TO- TO THOSE OTHER APPLICATIONS
. SECONDS BECAUSE THE PROPOSED
LEVEL FUNDING IS ACCORDING TO
THE- HASTINGS THE THREE MINIMUM
LEVEL TO KEEP THE- OBJECT
FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE THE
ANTICIPATED RENTS FOR THE
BUILDING ARE HIGHER THAN THE
AFFORDABILITY GOAL THAT SENT
STATUTES SO COURTING TO HASTINGS
ARE RENTS FOR THE NEW BUILDING
WOULD BE. A REVERENCE FOR THE
EXISTING BUILDING WOULD BE 30%
OF 80% OF. AREA MEDIAN INCOME
AND THE STATUTORY GOAL CURRENTLY
IS 3% 250% OF THE AREA MEDIAN
INCOME. AND THEN FINALLY WE JUST
WANT EMPHASIZE THAT THIS IS A
PRIMARILY A RESIDENTIAL FACILITY
OF HISTORICALLY THE STATE HAS
FOCUSED ON. ACADEMIC FACILITIES
ACADEMIC FACILITIES ARE NOT SELF
SUPPORTED FROM THE REVENUE AND
TYPICALLY OF THE RENOVATION
PROJECTS FOR A REQUIRE STATE
FUNDING TO BECOME FEASIBLE. OF
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA ALONE
HAS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
SEISMIC ISSUES RELATED TO ITS
ACADEMIC FACILITIES SO THIS IS
STILL OUT. OF SERVICE ONGOING
ISSUE FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THEN WE'LL MOVE ON
TO. HASTINGS I THANK YOU CENTER
LAYERED THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE MAY REVISE IS-
A- MAJOR EXPRESSION OF SUPPORT
FOR THE COLLEGES STILL PLANS TO
CREATE A MULTI INSTITUTIONAL
ACADEMIC VILLAGE. AND WE
SUPPORT- OF THE PROPOSALS THAT
BEEN TENDERED E ARE VERY
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT PROCEEDING
WITH THE SEISMIC STRENGTHENING
OF THE ONE HUNDRED MCALLISTER
BUILDING. AND THE OTHER STATES
SUPPORT WILL MAKE THAT HAPPEN SO
AGAIN OUR APPRECIATION ALL
AROUND- FURTHER ON THE AGENDA IS
A FUNDING FOR A REMAINING COST A
WE ARE WORKING VERY CLOSELY.
WITH SOME WOMEN RAMOS WITH AB
NINETEEN THIRTY SIX AND A
CENTER- BURKE SB TWELVE EIGHTY
EIGHT WHO- GOOD FOR THE
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD. CREATE
THAT NAME CHANGE- THE SUPPORT
PROVIDED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE THOUSAND WILL HELP US-PEOPLE'S BECAUSE WE WILL NOT
COVER THE ENTIRE COST AND WE
WILL WORK WITH THE- THE
LEGISLATIVE SPONSORS OF THE
BILLS TWO HUNDRED GERMAN WHETHER
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT CAN BE
PROVIDED. THE SECOND PUT YOUR
COMMENTS. YES IT DOES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THEN THEN MOVING TO
QUESTIONS LET ME JUST ASK ONE
QUESTION A MAYBE A COMMENT
FOLLOW UP. WITH MR STEWART. I
HAVE THIS JUST VAGUE
RECOLLECTION THAT YOU HAD TO
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS THAT
NEEDED TO BE DONE- BY DOING THIS
ONE WHERE DOES THAT LEAVE YOU IN
TERMS OF NEEDS FOR CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS. WELL THE PROJECT
YOU'RE REFERENCING IS CURRENTLY
UNDER WAY IT'S A IT'S A STUDENT
HOUSING PROJECT- THAT WILL BE
OCCUPIED BY YOU SEE A SOUTH OF
HASTINGS STUDENTS. AS WELL AS
STUDENTS FROM UC DAVIS AND
POTENTIALLY UC BERKELEY SO THAT
PROJECT IS UNDERWAY IT. IS
FUNDED BY A COLLEGE ISSUE TAX
EXEMPT AT- IT IS CUMPLIR. TO THE
WATER MCALLISTER PROJECT AGAIN
PROVIDING- YOUR HOUSING FOR.
STUDENTS FROM THE INDIAN PUBLIC
SECTOR ENTIRE BAY AREA SOLD WITH
THE ONE HUNDRED MCALLISTER-
ALLOCATION WE ARE SQUARED AWAY
WITH ALL OF OUR CAPITAL NEEDS
FOR THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE. WE
HAVE AN ADDITIONAL. COULD BE
DEVELOPED FOR ADDITIONAL
ECONOMIC VISIBILITY
FUNCTIONALITY BUT WE WOULD NOT
EXPECT A STEADY CALIFORNIA TO BE
A FINANCIAL SUPPORTER LAST LET
PROJECT GREAT WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE THAT AND
I KNOW THAT. THERE HAD BEEN AN
ISSUE WHERE. I DON'T KNOW THE
POLITE WAY TO SAY IT OB YOU IN
SOME QUARTERS OF UC ARE
CONSIDERED A STEP CHILD AND OR
WHAT HAVE HAD TROUBLE COMPETING
FOR THE HOUSING MONEY THAT WAS
UNDER THE UC SEGMENT OF HIGHER
EDUCATION SO I'M VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THIS RECOMMENDATION BECAUSE
I THINK IT RESOLVES THAT ISSUE
AND ALLOWS TO THE UC MONEY TO
TRULY GO TO OTHER PARTS OF THE
UC. ARM THAT COMPLETES MY
QUESTIONS ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES ON
THIS SIDE. THEY'RE NOT AND SO I
THANK YOU ALL FOR. YOUR PATIENCE
IN WAITING FOR WHAT TURNED OUT
TO BE SUCH A BRIEF. A MOMENT SO
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO THE-
CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY WE A-
HAVE JENNIFER LOUIS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUST IN
CONSTANT TOURISTS FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AND REBEKAH WENT THE DEPUTY
STATE LIBRARIAN WILL GO IN THAT
ORDER WILL BEGIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WELCOME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. HELLO
MISTER CARE MEMBERS GENERALLY
AGAIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE MAY REVISION
PROVIDES TWO POINT FOUR MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FUND FOR A TOTAL
OF THREE POINT EIGHT MILLION TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY.
AMONG THESE INVESTMENTS INCLUDE
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY THREE
THOUSAND ONGOING JOURNAL FINE
FOR THREE AND A HALF POSITIONS
TO SUPPORT INCREASED
ADMINISTRATIVE AND PERSONAL
WORKLOAD. THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND ONGOING GENERAL
FUND FOR COMMUNICATIONS AND
OUTREACH TO LOCAL LIBRARIES FOR.
THREE POSITIONS TO EXPAND PUBLIC
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION TO
CALIFORNIA LOCAL LIBRARIES AND
PATRONS AND UNDERSERVED AND
MULTI LINGUAL COMMUNITIES. FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND ONGOING
TURNER FIND TO MODERNIZE STATE
LIBRARY SERVICES WITH AN
AUTOMATED LOAN SYSTEM AND
PROVIDE SUBSCRIPTIONS IN E.
BOOKS AND ONLINE DATABASES FOR
RESEARCH BY STATE AGENCIES AND
POLICYMAKERS. AS WELL AS ONE
MILLION NINETY ONE THOUSAND
ONGOING TRYING TO FIND FOR
TECHNICAL SHIFT IN OPERATIONS
FOR A POSITIONS FROM FOR TO FIND
TO JENNIFER AND TO SUPPORT. A
COMPLETE GREATER COMPLIANCE WITH
THE FEDERAL LIBRARY SERVICES AND
TECHNOLOGY ACT GUIDELINES AND
RESULT IN THESE ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDS TO BE REDIRECTED
TO SUPPORT LOCAL LIBRARIES. AND
LAST WEEK OR PROVIDING A ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION A ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT TWO
ADDITIONAL YEARS OF ONLINE JOB
TRAINING AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FOR VETERANS IN
OLDER ADULTS. CURRENTLY
SUPPORTED BY ONE TIME FUNDS
THROUGH CALIFORNIA LOCAL
LIBRARIES BUILDING A BLIND AND
COMPLIMENTARY COMPLIMENTARY TO
GOVERNOR'S BY THE AUGMENTATION
OF EIGHT POINT EIGHT MILLION ONE
TIME IN GENERAL FUND. LASTLY THE
MAY REVISION ALL OF- INCLUDES AN
ASSORTMENT OF TECHNICAL A
LANGUAGE- TO CLARIFY GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AUGMENTATION REGARDING
GOVERNOR COMPREHENSIVE
DIGITALISATION STRATEGY BY
EXTENDING AND CONVERTS PERIOD AS
WELL AS INCLUDING REPORTING
DEADLINES WITH ACTUAL CONCLUDE
MY PRESENTATION AND BE HAPPY TO.
RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. JUST BEFORE WE GO TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST LET ME NOTE
THAT MY PHONE HAS EXPLODED
OVERMARS. REFERENCE TO HASTINGS
AS A COUSIN AND EVERYBODY'S
WEIGHING IN WITH THEIR DIFFERENT
STUFF FAMILIAL RELATIONSHIPS F
HASTINGS TO YOU SEE SO I WILL.
JUST NOTED FOR THE RECORD AND
THANK THEM OFF FOR FEEDBACK-
WILL MOVE ON TO THE LEGISLATIVE.
OFFICE I JUST DOUBLE CHECKING
THAT I AND YOU TO PROPERLY AND
YOU CAN HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU
JUST FINE AND- HOPEFULLY YOUR
CONNECTION IS NOT UNSTABLE. AT
THE MOMENT IT DOES NOT APPEAR
SO- SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE SIX
OF THE ONLY A HAND OUT YOU'LL
SEE THE- ASSOCIATED TABLE FOR
THE STATE LIBRARY. JUST KEEP IN
MIND THIS TABLE IS THE ONLY
TABLE MY HAND OUT AND THOUSANDS
NOT MILLIONS SO THERE'S- TOLD-
THE REVISION PROPOSALS ARE THREE
POINT EIGHT MILLION. THE LARGEST
PROPOSAL HERE- AS THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NOTED WOULD EXPAND
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
AROUND LIBRARY BASED- OUR
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS. WE RAISED A
SEVERAL CONCERNS OF THAT
PROPOSAL DURING GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AROUND THE LIMITED
INFORMATION ON THE NUMBER OF
PARTICIPANTS ON THEIR OUTCOMES.
IT DOES NOT ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS AND WE CONTINUE TO
RECOMMEND THAT YOU REJECT THIS
PROPOSAL. WE ALSO SUBMITTED-
SOME COMMENTS TO STAFF AROUND
MANY OF THE ON GOING PROPOSALS
AND RAISE CONCERNS GENERALLY
AROUND THE A LACK OF INFORMATION
ON THE PROPOSALS. I WOULD LIKE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT I'M SINCE WE
RELEASED THAT ALLOWS THOSE
COMMENTS THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
STARTED TO PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH STAFF AS MORE
INFORMATION BECOMES AVAILABLE ON
THESE PROPOSALS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE DEPUTY STATE
LIBRARY. IN MY NAME MISTER TERRY
MEMBERS. HAPPY TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING TO TALK ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE AND WORK WITH THE
STATE LIBRARY DOES AND WE ARE
GRATEFUL TO REPORT TO ALLOW THE
STATE LIBRARY YOU CONTINUE TO
ACTIVELY CARRY OUT ITS MISSION
PROPOSALS HERE- IN THE MAYOR
REVISION CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
LOCAL LIBRARIES WITH. ASSISTING
AMERICAL COMMUNITIES MAN CREATES
SUCH AREAS AND EQUITY IN ACCESS
TO WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
RESOURCES THAT WOULD BE
EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE IF THEY WERE
TO TRY TO PAINS AND THAT'S ON
THEIR OWN AND WOULD NOT BE
AVAILABLE. ON INDIVIDUAL BASIS.
IN OTHER WORDS THE THINKING.
ADAM HELLO LABOR WELL FIFTY YEP
PLEDGED THE PROGRAMS THAT
ALREADY ON FOR LIKE FOR HIS THAT
THE CAN. LET THEIR COMMUNITIES
THAT THE- PROGRAMS THAT CRUCIAL
TO THEIR- ARE BALL JANET HAPPY
TO ANSWER I. IT THERE ARE ANY.
THANK YOU MUCH I'M JUST TO ASK
WHY QUESTION OF THE- DEPARTMENT
OF. IN THAT IS LAST- THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR. IN
THIS BUDGET ESTABLISHED GRANTS
TO LOCAL LIBRARIES FOR CERTAIN
PURPOSES AND IT WAS.
OVERWHELMINGLY SUCCESSFUL AND IN
FACT OVERSUBSCRIBED AND IT IS
WHAT IT IS A ONE TIME FUNDING
THING THE REASON WHY. IT WAS NOT
PUT BACK IN THIS BUDGET FOR ONE
TIME FUNDING TO MEET THAT NEED
THAT WAS DEMONSTRATED LAST YEAR
. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION
MISTER KERR- THE TWENTY TWENTY
MY BUDGET A COMPUTATION WAS ONE
TIME AND- THE CURRENTLY REVISION
DOES PROVIDE- AN AUGMENTATION
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
RECREATION- SIMILAR TO HOW THE
ITEM WAS AUGMENTED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT. AND I
WILL BE HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH
YOUR STAFF IF THEY HAVE FURTHER
ENQUIRIES- AND I CAN PASS ALONG
TO MY COLLEAGUES OF THE
DEPARTMENT- WHO OVERSEE THE DIP
BUDGET OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
WREXHAM. AT STATE PARKS AND
RECREATION. WHAT THEN LET ME ASK
A FOLLOW UP QUESTION BECAUSE THE
SENATE BUDGET PROPOSAL PUTS
GRANTS IN. AND YOU'RE REFERRING
TO ONE AND PARKS AND REC WHAT'S
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT IS
IN FOR PARKS AND REC AND WHAT
THE SENATE IS PROPOSED TO JUST
CONTINUE THE GRANTS PROGRAM
THROUGH THE- LIBRARY. I AM NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THE SPECIFICS OF
THE SENATE PROGRAM FOR SPECIFIC
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF ROCK PARKS
AND RECREATION. SO I'LL HAVE TO
PASS ALONG YOUR INQUIRY. AS OF A
MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL- FOR DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS AND REC THROUGH THE MEET
ME REVISION FOR THE- BY THE
ADMINISTRATION- THE-
AUGMENTATION SHOULD FUNCTION
SIMILARLY TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT. IN TERMS OF
FUNCTION OF MECHANICS WEBER HAND
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST I
HAVE A SNEAKING SUSPICION. HE
WANTS TO OFFER SOME CLARITY HERE
. SURE ON THE SHOW THEIR
MINISTRATIONS REFERRING TO A
SEPARATE INITIATIVE THAT WAS
FUNDED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
BUT THE DEPARTMENTS TOOK PART IN
A PARKS AND RECREATION THAT
FOCUSED ON. EXPANDING OUR PATRON
ACCESS TO STATE PARKS AND
OFFERING- FREE UP PARK PASSES AT
LOCAL LIBRARIES AND- MARKETING
THOSE MARKING THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PATRONS- I
THINK WHAT WHICH IS WHAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO SENATORS THE- MUCH
LARGER AUGMENTATION PROVIDED
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET AROUND A
LIBRARY INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH
REALLY HAD A VERY DIFFERENT
FOCUS IT WAS FOCUSED ON- YOU
KNOW- A LIBRARY FACILITY NEEDS
AND EQUIPMENT PURCHASES AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE AND THEN
THERE'S- AN ADDITIONAL ITEM IN
THE SENATE DEMOCRAT BUDGET. AND
THAT THOSE ARE THOSE ARE THOSE
ARE DISTINCT- ISSUES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF. PARKS AND
RECREATION. I APPRECIATE THAT
CLARITY THANK YOU INTO IT
BECAUSE I UNDERSTOOD WHAT THE
SENATE'S PROPOSAL WAS I'D NEVER
HEARD OF THE- HOUSE RELATED TO A
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION PROPOSAL SO. I THINK
IT JUST THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS JUST AN OBSERVATION- I
HAVE A VERY RETAIL DISTRICT WERE
I JUST DO TONS AND TONS OF. OF
EVENTS AND MEETINGS THROUGHOUT
FOUR COUNTIES AND THIS IS ONE
THAT PEOPLE WALKED UP OUT OF
CROWDS IT JUST THANKED ME FOR.
OF BUNCHES OF TIME SO I THINK.
THE ASSISTANCE TO LIBRARIES IN
THE IN THE BLOCK GRANTS WAS
REALLY WELL RECEIVED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND THAT IS WHY
GIVEN THE FACT IT WAS
OVERSUBSCRIBED IT'S IN THE
SENATE PROPOSAL AND SO. ARM I
APPRECIATE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCING THEY WOULD PASS ALONG
OUR COMMENTS BUT I THINK IN
NEGOTIATIONS WE WILL REALLY
PRESS FOR THAT BECAUSE IT IS A
ONE TIME. ITEM AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT. THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S HIGHLIGHTED AS A
PREFERENCE. OF HIS FOR FUNDING
EVEN THOUGH. WE HAVE LOTS OF I
THANK ON THE TAPE FOR A LOT OF
THINGS. ANY ELSE ALL OF ON THE
LINE. THEN NINE LET ME THANK
EVERYBODY FOR BEING HERE. AND
THAT COMPLETES THE FIRST PART OF
OUR AGENDA AND WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO THE SECOND PART. OF WHICH IS
K. THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION.
AND- AND WE HAVE A SIX ISSUES
THAT GO THROUGH PROP NINETY
EIGHT AND THE K. TO TWELVE
BUDGET. ARE AND THE FIRST ONE-
AND I SEE HE HAS JOINED US SO OF
THE FIRST ONE IS A ONE PERSON
PANEL OF- THE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND
WHO'S GOING TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE
ON THE STATE OF K. THROUGH
TWELVE EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S INFORMATIONAL. JUST AS I
MADE A STATEMENT INTRODUCING OF
THE FIRST HALF I'M GOING TO MAKE
A STATEMENT IN REDUCING THE
OTHER ISSUES WHEN THE
SUPERINTENDENT IS DONE SO- WE
APPRECIATE YOU MAKING THE TIME
TO BE WITH US- WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE MR STUPOR TENANT
FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M GRATEFUL TO BE
WITH YOU KNOW AND TO SHARE JUST
A FEW HIGHLIGHTS- ABOUT THE K.
FOURTEEN HIGH SCHOOLS BUDGET. AS
I'M SURE YOU'VE NOTED- THAT
THERE'S BUDGET DIRECTS A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY EIGHT POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS- PERHAPS THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF FUNDING FOR A
K. FOURTEEN SCHOOLS EVER- YEAH
YEAH I KNOW YOU ALL KNOW. THAT
WE ARE- CONFRONTING MANY
CHALLENGES THAT HAVE COME FROM
THE PANDEMIC- IN IN ADDRESSING-
ISSUES OF EQUITY THAT EXISTED
BEFORE AND WERE EXACERBATED
DURING THE PANDEMIC WE THINK
THAT THIS BUDGET IS THOUGHTFUL.
ABOUT ITS APPROACH TO ADDRESSING
MANY OF THOSE ISSUES ONE OF THEM
BEING MENTAL HEALTH OF COURSE-
AND WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT THIS
BUDGET PROPOSES. TO EXPAND-
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS FOR BOTH
TEACHERS AND COUNSELORS. AND
MAKES MONEY AVAILABLE FOR THOSE
WHO WOULD BECOME A COUNSELOR- TO
THE GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAM WE ARE OBVIOUS YOU'RE
TRACKING THIS CLOSELY. AS IT
RELATES TO A BILL THAT WE ARE
SPONSORING WITH SENATOR MCGUIRE
THAT WOULD HELP US TO RECRUIT
TEN THOUSAND. NEW MENTAL HEALTH
CLINICIANS BY PROVIDING THEM
SCHOLARSHIP SIMILAR TO WHAT IS
IN THE GOLDEN STATE TEACHER
GRANT PROGRAM- WE ALSO ARE VERY
PLEASED TO SEE THE CONTINUED
FOCUS ON LITERACY- THE AS YOU
KNOW E'VE NAMED A TASK FORCE ON
SUPPORTING OUR SCHOOLS. ON
ACHIEVING THE BENCHMARK OF
READING BY THIRD GRADE FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND THIS
BUDGET- BUILDS ON MANY OF THE
PROPOSALS THAT HAVE COME OUT OF
THAT TASK FORCE AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL. TO THE GOVERNOR'S
LEADERSHIP IN PROMOTING IN
PARTICULAR THE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WILL
SUPPORT THINGS LIKE LITERACY
COACHES AND SPECIALISTS WE KNOW
THAT- READING IS A GATEWAY
SKILL. AND THE ABILITY TO READ
MEANS MANY THINGS IT MEANS THAT
YOU- YOU WHEN YOU LEARN TO READ
YOU CAN READ TO LEARN ANYTHING
AND. THAT WE KNOW THAT OUR
COACHES AND SPECIAL STARBUCKS- A
FULL OUR SCHOOLS SO HELP OUR
STUDENTS TO. THEIR LITERACY. WE
ARE TO THE FOCUS ON THIS-
LITERACY EFFORTS ON SUPPORTING
MULTI LINGUAL LEARNERS IN
LIBRARIES ARE SIMILAR TO WHAT
YOU SCHOOL LIBRARY SIMILAR. TO
THE LAST DISCUSSION ABOUT
SUPPORTING LIBRARIES- BECAUSE WE
MUST SUPPORT A BY LITERACY FOR
STUDENTS- AS WELL. THIS BUDGET
ON CONTINUES TO BUILD ON
INVESTMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE AN
EXPANDED LEARNING PROGRAMS. AND
A PROPOSES AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
HUNDRED THREE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR EXPANDED. LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM WHICH
MEANS THAT ESSENTIALLY OF THIS
PROGRAM COULD BE FUNDED FULLY-
FOUR YEARS AHEAD OF SCHEDULE-
THIS IS THE BUDGET ALSO
ENVISIONS EXPANDING. THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS PROGRAM-
LITERALLY TODAY THE STATE BOARD
HAS TAKEN UP THE ISSUE OF
APPROVAL OF THE VERY SCHOOLS
THAT WILL RECEIVE GRANTS FROM.
YES ALLOCATION OF THREE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR COMMUNITY SCHOOLS UP
FOR PLANNING GRANTS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS AND FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE- THOSE-
GRANT SEPARATE IT OUT INTO THE
PAY BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THOSE
RESOURCES. THERE'S SUCH A HIGH
DEMAND. AND NEED FOR COMMUNITY
SCHOOL SO WE APPRECIATE THE
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION INVESTMENT PROPOSED FOR
A COMMUNITY SCHOOLS SPENDING
CONTINUES TO BUILD ON THE
COMMITMENTS UNIVERSAL MEALS FOR
ALL STUDENTS- CONSTRUCTION
MODERNIZATION OF SCHOOL
FACILITIES AND EARLY LEARNING.
OPPORTUNITIES THE TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN AND SIXTH GRADE
SCHOOL I WOULD JUST MENTION A
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION FOR
CONSTRUCTION A SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION ANOTHER ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION- FOR- SCHOOL-
MAINTENANCE AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE AND I KNOW OUR
SCHOOLS DO THAT THERE'S A BUDGET
PRIORITIZES. HELPING SCHOOL
STABILIZER BUDGETS IN THE FACE
OF THE CLONING ENROLLMENT-
PROVIDING FLEXIBILITY FOR
CALCULATING AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE- YOU KNOW A PROPOSAL
FOR SOME THREE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS THAT WOULD. HELP
SCHOOLS TO MAINTAIN STABILITY IN
ADDITION TO THAT A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN THE BASE OF PERHAPS
THE HIGHEST INCREASE THAT WE'VE
SEEN SINCE THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
LCF AT ANY EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR
DISCRETIONARY BLOCK GRANT I
WOULD ALLOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
ADDRESS ISSUES OF STAFFING-
STUDENT LEARNING CHALLENGES
PENSIONS AND OTHER ISSUES. THAT
THEY MAY FACE THESE ARE ALL
CRITICAL- AS WE POINTED OUT IN
HEIGHT AND HIGHLIGHTS. I
CERTAINLY COULD SPEAK TO OTHERS-
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO DO SO THANK
YOU SENATOR PER HAVE BEEN GIVING
US TIME BEFORE- WE MIGHT TALK
ABOUT PROGRAMS LIKE THE FREEDOM
SCHOOL ADDITION TO THAT THAT
SEEKS THREE. MILLION DOLLARS IN
THIS BUDGET TO EXPAND AND
AFROCENTRIC EVIDENCE BASED
LITERACY INTERVENTION FOR
STUDENTS OF ALL AGES I WOULD
DEEPLY FOCUS ON HOW TO SUPPORT
ON THE CHEAP IN A BLACK STUDENTS
AND TO SUPPORT STUDENTS- WHO HAD
BARRIERS- IN THE AWAY- AND TO
HELP THEM- NOT LEAST OF WHICH-
WOULD BE. LIKE A TO SEE SEVEN
COULD CHANGE THE CHARACTER.
RESULT OF LCS AFTER PROVIDED
DESIGNATION STUDENTS WHO HAVE
BEEN DETERMINED TO BE THE LOWEST
PERFORMING STUDENTS AND OUR
STATE AND SB NINE FIVE TWO WHICH
WAS SPONSORING TO EXPAND DUAL
LANGUAGE IMMERSION PROGRAMS-
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE FAMILY
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS IN A B.
TWO. FOUR SIX FIVE WHICH WE ARE
ALSO SPONSORING TO SUPPORT
LITERACY- I WOULD JUST POINT OUT
THAT- THERE'S ONE ISSUE THAT I
WOULD HOPE THAT. I CONTINUES TO
GET DISCUSSED BEFORE THIS BUDGET
IS FINALIZED AND THAT IS HOW TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM- BY SOME ACCOUNTS I
CRIED ABSENTEEISM FOR
KINDERGARTNERS IS UP BY ABOUT
THIRTY SEVEN PERCENT. I'M DURING
THE POST PANDEMIC AND NOW WE
KNOW THAT MANY FAMILIES STRUGGLE
TO BE CONNECTED WE KNOW THIS
BECAUSE OUR SCHOOLS PROVIDED
NINE HUNDRED MILLION MEALS TO
FAMILIES AND SO WE KNOW THAT THE
NEED WAS GREAT WE KNOW THAT
THERE WAS DISRUPTION. WE JOIN
MANY OF OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
LITERALLY CALLING FAMILIES WHO
NEVER CHECKED IN END UP FOR OUR
SCHOOLS AS THEY TRY TO GRAPPLE
WITH ISSUES. OF DECLINING
ENROLLMENT THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO ADDRESS ISSUES OF CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM THAT MEANS OUTREACH
WORKERS WHO CAN KNOCK ON DOORS
AND CAN HELP IT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY WE SPONSORED S. B.
EIGHT THIRTY A BILL THAT
PROVIDES THOSE KINDS OF
RESOURCES. WE KNOW THAT IT'S A
HEFTY PRICE TAG WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S AN EVEN GREATER PRICE
TAG WHEN STUDENTS ARE NOT IN
SCHOOL LEARNING AND THEN OF
COURSE THE FINANCIAL COSTS THAT
OUR SCHOOLS EXPERIENCE WHEN
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM. IS LEFT
UNCHECKED SO. WE'RE GRATEFUL TO
AYE ANSWERING QUESTIONS I'M
JOINED BY NUMBER OF OUR STAFF AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IN
OUR GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS TEAMS-
BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THAT YOU MAY HAVE ON
THE ON THE LINES OF- K. FOURTEEN
EDUCATION AS. IT RELATES TO THE-
PROPOSED BY. FIRST OF ALL LET
ME. YOU FOR YOUR OF READERS AND
YOUR- TODAY IT IS REALLY HELPFUL
US. AND I KNOW. THAT WE HAVE
YOUR STAFF- STANDING BY. AND
BEING AVAILABLE AS WE GO THROUGH
THE INDIVIDUAL ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA AND- AS WE- DROVE DOWN ON
EACH ONE INDIVIDUALLY THAT MIGHT
PIZZA. THE MORE APPROPRIATE
PLACE FOR MOST OF THE QUESTIONS
LET ME ASK OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS ON THE
SUPERINTENDENT IS HERE. I SEE
NONE SO LET ME JUST THANK YOU
AGAIN WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION IN YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON THESE ISSUES
AS WE MOVE THROUGH THEM AND- AND
ARE. AND THANKS FOR YOUR
PATIENCE BECAUSE YOU ARE THE
FIRST PART OF THE SECOND- A PART
OF THE AGENDA AND WE NEVER KNOW
WHEN WE'RE GOING TO GET TO IT
AND AS SOMEBODY WHO HAS A
COMPLICATED SCHEDULE I'M SURE
THAT DISRUPTED YOUR SO JUST
THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH US
AND BEING HERE. TODAY ALL YOU
NEEDED- WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
ONGOING CONVERSATION THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN. AND THANK YOU
OF MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
CORRECT THANKS AGAIN. BEFORE WE
MOVE TO ISSUE TOO I WAS GONNA
MAKE SOME OPENING COMMENTS ON
THE K. THROUGH TWELVE BUDGET
JUST THE WAY I DID TO BE. BEFORE
THE HIGHER READ BUDGET AND- LAST
WEEK WE HEARD THE SENATE PLAN.
ON PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT TEN
K. THROUGH TWELVE AND- TODAY
WE'RE HEARINGS- THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISE PROPOSAL THAT IT
GIVES US A CHANCE TO PUT THEM.
OUR IN RELIEF BECAUSE ON THE K.
TO TWELVE SIDE THE SENATE BUDGET
PLAN WAS DEVELOPED IN RESPONSE
TO FEEDBACK. FROM SCHOOL LEADERS
AND STAFF WITH AN EYE TO THE
DECLINING ENROLLMENT THAT WAS
JUST MENTIONED. OF OUR STUDENT
POPULATION. AND WE APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR'S THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH TO K. TO TWELVE
EDUCATION THIS YEAR. THERE ARE A
COUPLE OF KEY DIFFERENCES. THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT. THE
CASE THROUGH TWELVE SENATE
BUDGET PLAN PUTS AN EMPHASIS ON
MAXIMISING DISCRETIONARY FUNDING
FOR SCHOOLS. A TO THAT END THE
SENATE PROPOSAL WOULD ADD FIVE
BILLION INTO THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA THE L. C. F. F.
IN THE BUDGET YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE. WHICH WOULD
INCREASE TO TEN BILLION BY
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
ON TOP OF A SIX POINT FIVE. 6%
COLA IN OTHER WORDS PROVIDE A
YEAR TO YEAR INCREASE OF ROUGHLY
FOURTEEN PERCENT. OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN MAY
REVISION WOULD INCREASE CELL CFF
FUNDING BY TWO POINT ONE
BILLION. WITH THE CURRENT-
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD ADD AN ON
GOING TO BILLION ON TOP OF A SIX
POINT 56% COLA. THAT COMES OUT
TO ROUGHLY A 10% YEAR TO YEAR
INCREASE. IN PREVIOUS ITEMS- IN
HIGHER EDUCATION IN THIS
HEARING. WE NOTED THE CHALLENGES
FROM THE PANDEMIC AND INFLATION.
AND WHAT REALLY WOULD ALLOW
SCHOOLS TO MOVE AHEAD. R. N. N.
IN NORMAL YEARS HAVING A SIX
PERCENT- R. COLO WOULD BE
CHEERED AND AS I SAID EARLIER
WAS A SIMILAR THING IN HIGHER
EDUCATION. I WILL JUST FIGHT TO
KEEP IT THERE THIS YEAR THERE
ARE JUST SO MANY ADDITIONAL
PRESSURES THAT THAT WE REALLY
HAVE TO DO MORE TO HELP THE
SCHOOLS MOVE AHEAD. THE SENATE
PROPOSES TO DISCRETIONARY BLOCK
GRANTS THE TOTAL FIFTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS WHEREAS THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES ONE
DISCRETIONARY BLOCK GRANT FOUR
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS AND
SEVERAL OTHER GRANT PROGRAMS.
I'D NOTE HERE THAT THE SENATE
BLOCK GRANT ROLES MOST OF THE
GOVERNOR'S GRANT PROGRAMS
FUNDING INTO A CENTRALIZED GRANT
. MY LASTLY. BOTH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS IN THE SENATE PROPOSAL
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS INCLUDING SCHOOL MALES
EXPANDED LEARNING AND FACILITIES
AND DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BUT
NOTABLY THE SENATE'S PROPOSAL
ALSO INVESTED SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION WHICH IS REALLY
HOME TO SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION SO
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION IN A
COLLABORATIVE AND THOUGHTFUL
MANNER AS WE MOVE TOWARD A FINAL
BUDGET AND THEN AT TODAY'S
HEARING A WE WERE GOING TO BE
GOING THROUGH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL BUT I
WAS SORT OF WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THE CONTEXT AS WE HEADED INTO
IT. SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT AND DISCRETIONARY
SCHOOL FUNDING- WILL HAVE A
CONCRETE THING FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- KENNETH
COUPON FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND WITH MANY
ITEMS TODAY WE WILL HAVE
SOMEBODY AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
OF FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION SO WILL BEGIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE. HELLO CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'M ON IN SAINT FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'LL
BE PRESENTING YOU WITH A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT MINIMUM GUARANTEE.
AND LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA OR ELSE YES AFTER THAT
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE MAYOR
VISION. PROF NINETY EIGHT CARE
AND HE IS ESTIMATED TO INCREASE
BY ABOUT NINETEEN POINT SIX
BILLION ACROSS THE BUDGET WINDOW
FROM TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE COMPARED TO
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. AND THIRTY
FIVE POINT SEVEN BILLION
RELATIVE TO THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET ACT. ALL
BUDGET YEAR STAR MAN AND THE
TEST ONE WHICH MEANS THAT PROP
NINETY EIGHT RECEIVED
APPROXIMATELY 38% OF THE REVENUE
CHANGES IN EACH OF THE THREE
BUDGET YEARS. THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT MINIMUM GUARANTEE AS
REVENGE TO REFLECT THE CONTINUED
IMPLEMENTATION OF UNIVERSAL T.
K. FOR A ONE TIME VERSUS ONGOING
PROP NINETY EIGHT POLICY
ADJUSTMENTS AVAILABLE IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. OF THE SIXTEEN
POINT SIX BILLION THERE IS EIGHT
POINT SEVEN BILLION AN ONGOING
AND SEVEN POINT NINE BILLION ONE
TIME EXPENDITURES PROPOSED.
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE OR
EIGHTY EIGHT IS PROJECTED TO
DECLINE BY APPROXIMATELY 5% FROM
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THERE FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. ADX CALCULATIONS
INCLUDE UPDATED DEMOGRAPHIC DATA
AND TAKE INTO ACCOUNT NEARLY AND
ROLLING TEA CASE STUDENTS. AS
WELL AS YOUR STUDENT ABSENCES
RELATED TO COPE AT NINETEEN. IN
REGARD TO THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
RAINY DAY FUND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROJECTED THAT A TOTAL OF
NINE POINT SEVEN BILLION IN
PAYMENTS TO THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM STABILIZATION ACCOUNT-
PISSA. WOULD BE NEEDED BETWEEN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. ADJUSTMENTS IN
CAPITAL GAINS REVENUES UP THE
TWENTY TO TWENTY. VISION HOWEVER
VICE THESE PAYMENTS DOWN FROM
THAT NINE POINT SEVEN BILLION AT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO THE TOTAL A
CURRENT TOTAL OF NINE POINT FIVE
BILLION IN THAT. MISSION ALL NOW
PRESENT A BRIEF SUMMARY OF THE
LCS. RESTFUL DISTRICTS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND THE BUDGET
YEAR AT THE MAYOR VISION OF CFF
DECREASED BY ABOUT ONE POINT
THREE BILLION AS COMPARED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AT WHICH POINT
WE HAD PROJECTED AN INCREASE OF
TWO POINT ONE BILLION. THIS IS
PRIMARILY DUE TO PROJECTED
EIGHTY EIGHT DECLINE ABOUT 5% A
LARGE COLA INCREASE OF SIX POINT
56% WE ALSO PROVIDE A TWO POINT
ONE BILLION DOLLAR DISCRETIONARY
ON GOING INCREASE TO THE BASE
LCS FIVE WHICH COVER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND CHARTER SCHOOLS AS
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO MITIGATE
THE IMPACTS SURPRISING PENSION
OBLIGATION. OBLIGATIONS
INCREASED COSTS FOR GOODS AND
SERVICES AND OTHER ONGOING LOCAL
BUDGET CONCERNS. THIS INCREASE
WILL FLOW THROUGH THE LCS
FORMULA AND WILL INCREASE NOT
ONLY THE BASE GRANT BUT
CORRESPONDING SUPPLEMENTAL AND
CONCENTRATION GRANTS AS WELL.
LANGUAGE FOR THIS ONGOING
INVESTMENT WILL BE INCLUDED IN
THE FORTHCOMING ARE AT. IN
REGARD TO THAT DECLINING
ENROLLMENT PROJECTION FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE THE
CLEANING INVOLVEMENT PROTECTION
IN THE BUDGET YEAR OF
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS. WHICH REFLECTS
THE REVISION OF THE THREE YEAR
DECLINING ENROLLMENT PRODUCTION
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS BY
MODIFYING THE COMPUTATION OF
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT FOR THE PURPOSES OF THE
THREE YEAR AVERAGE. THIS
PROTECTION AS PROVIDED FOR
DISTRICTS AS LONG GOING TO TEST
THAT FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS TO
PROVIDE A ONE TIME DECLINING
ENROLLMENT PROTECTION FOR THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO SCHOOL
YEAR FOR CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS ONLY. AND THE AMOUNT OF
FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. TO PROVIDE RELIEF FOR
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION WE
PROVIDE AN ONGOING FACED
INCREASED TO THEIR LCS UP AS
WELL. THIS WILL BE IN THE AMOUNT
OF ONE HUNDRED ONE MILLION
DOLLARS. AND WITHOUT WILL BE
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS RELATED
TO PROP NINETY EIGHT- LCS US-
PRESENTERS WILL DISCUSS MAJOR
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FUNDING
PROPOSALS AND THE NEXT ISSUE
WHICH IS A SHE THREE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF A MOVE TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU JEREMY CAN COMPOUND
THE ANALYSTS OFFICE WILL GIVE
YOU A FEW HIGHLIGHTS MATURED IN
OUR SYSTEM WE PUBLISHED THIS
MORNING. IBM CHRISTMAS
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE NINETEEN POINT SIX
BILLION OVER THE THREE YEAR
PERIOD. IS A BIG STORY BUT MAYBE
SURPRISINGLY IS NOT A VERY
COMPLICATED ONE. I COMPARED TO
JANUARY GENERAL FUND REVENUE
ESTIMATES ARE UP NEARLY FIFTY
SIX BILLION OVER THE THREE
YEARS. AND UNDER THE FORMULA WE
CALL TEST ONE SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES RECEIVE ABOUT
40% OF THAT ADDITIONAL REVENUE.
WE THINKTHE GENERAL FUND
ESTIMATES DEMONSTRATION PROVIDED
A REASONABLE AND IT LOOKED VERY
CLOSE TO THE ESTIMATES THAT WE
ARE FINALIZING. NOT PORTION OF
THAT INCREASE WAS OFFSET BY. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ESTIMATE OF
LOCAL PROPERTY TAX REVENUE. THEY
HAVE BROUGHT DOWN THEIR
ESTIMATES ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION COMPUTERS JANUARY. AND
WE THINK WE THINK THEY'RE A
LITTLE LOW I WOULD THINK
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE IS LIKELY
TO COME ANY CLOSER TO JANUARY.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT HAPPENS
THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE WOULD INCREASE ON A
DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR BASIS. THAT'S
A TURNING TO THE K. TWELVE
SPENDING PACKAGE OVERALL. A
TOTAL OF SEVENTEEN BILLION IN
NEW K. TWELVE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT AUGMENTATIONS. THAT'S ON
TOP OF NEARLY SIXTEEN BILLION IN
JANUARY PROPOSALS. SO THE WHOLE
PACKAGE BEFORE YOU WITH NEARLY
THIRTY THREE BILLION. GOVERNOR
ALLOCATES ABOUT NINETEEN BILLION
OF THAT THE ONE TIME ACTIVITIES
FOURTEEN MILLION FOR ON GOING.
ANOTHER ISSUE YOU'VE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT LATELY AND IN SOME OTHER
CONTEXT AS THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT. AND THIS
MAY REVISION ONTAINS A TOTAL OF
ABOUT FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION IN
K. TWELVE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT SPENDING ON CAPITAL
OUTLAY. WHICH IS EXEMPT FROM THE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT. AND THAT'S
SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE ONE WAY THE
STATE CAN COMPLY WITH THE LIMIT
JUST USE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING FOR EXAMPLE
PURPOSES. WE SOMETIMES TALK
ABOUT HOW THE STATE AS A
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT BUDGET
FOR SCHOOLS AND A NON
FOR EVERYTHING ELSE. BUT THE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT DOES NOT
HAVE THAT DISTINCTION. IN THE
AMOUNT OF EXCLUDED SPENDING
WITHIN PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
CAN HAVE. SIGNIFICANT EFFECTS ON
THE WAY ALLOCATE FUNDING FOR THE
REST OF THE STATE BUDGET. I
THINK THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
GIVE YOU A GOOD OVERVIEW OF THE
MAJOR MOVING PIECES IN THIS- MAY
REVISION. THE BIGGEST ONE IS
THAT EIGHT BILLION ONE TIME
DISCRETIONARY GRANTS AVAILABLE
FOR ANY LOCAL PURPOSE. HE DID
BASED ON ATTENDANCE. HAS SOME
INTENT LANGUAGE ABOUT HOW
DISTRICTS. ARE THE STATE HOPES
THE DISTRICT IS THE FUNDING-
RANGING FROM A NUMBER OF
PRIORITIES THE GOVERNOR LAYS OUT
EVERY FROM I ENCOURAGING-
PROJECT. MAINTAINING STAFFING
LEVELS TOO COINCIDENTAL HEALTH.
AS FAR AS THE ONGOING INCREASES
MOST OF THE NEW FUNDING IS FOR
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA. THIS IS PROBABLY THE
MOST COMPLICATED ASPECT OF THE
KICKOFF PACKAGE BECAUSE IT HAS
SO MANY MOVING PIECES. BUT I
THINK THE WAY TO STAY ORIENTED
IS THE FOCUS ON THE TOP LINE
NUMBER IS. UNDER THE NAY
REVISION THE TOTAL FUNDING FOR
LCS PATH WOULD INCREASE ABOUT
SEVEN POINT TWO BILLION MARKET
BY DID THIS YEAR TO TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. AND THAT'S A TOTAL
INCREASE ABOUT TWO POINT NINE
BILLION COMPARED WITH THE
JANUARY PROPOSAL. AND THAT'S THE
RESULT OF. A FERMENTED JUST
MEANS THE LOWER BASEMENT
ATTENDANCE AT THE- GOVERNOR'S
NEW ATTENDANCE- HOLD HARMLESS
PROPOSAL. THE INCREASE IN THE
STATUTORY COLA IN THE
DISAMBIGUATE BAYSIDE MEDITATION
ON TOP OF THAT AMOUNT. WHICH WE
ESTIMATE. AT ROUGHLY THREE POINT
2% AND IT'S ALL A SPECIAL NINETY
FOR COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION-
WE ESTIMATE THAT PROPOSAL WOULD
INCREASE. FUNDING WITH A 15% ON
AVERAGE THE EXACT AMOUNT WOULD
VARY A BIT FROM COUNTY TO
COUNTY. SOME COUNTIES WILL
RECEIVE INCREASES EVEN THOUGH
THEIR EXISTING FUNDING ALREADY
EXCEEDS THEIR TARGETS. UNDER THE
FORMULA. THAT'S A TURNING TO OUR
COMMENTS DECIDES ON- AJ IF
YOU'RE LOOKING AT OUR HAND OUT.
THIS IS THE LARGEST VISION
PACKAGE SINCE THE ADOPTION OF
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT. NEARLY
THREE BILLION LARGER THAN THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO MAY
REVISION JUST THE PREVIOUS ALL
TIME HIGH. BUT WE THINK ONE OF
THE POSITIVE FEATURES IS THAT IT
ALSO HAS. AND IF YOU AS AND HELP
TO BUILD BUDGET RESILIENCY AND
WE THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT GIVEN
SOME OF THE ECONOMIC WARNING
SIGNS THAT MY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED. AND HIGHER. BILLION
IN I'M GOING TO K. TWELVE FUNDS
THAT ARE ALLOCATED TO ONE TIME
ACTIVITIES. THERE'S NOTHING.
UNIQUE ABOUT THAT NUMBER. THE
FINAL BUDGET COULD CERTAINLY GO
HIGHER LOOK LITTLE HIGHER LOWER
THAN THAT. BUT IT GIVES YOU A
SIGNIFICANT QUESTION TO DEAL
WITH THE POTENTIAL DOWNTURN.
PROPOSITION NINETY RESERVE ALSO
GROSSED NINE POINT FIVE BILLION.
NEARLY 9% OF THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. NOT HUGE IN THAT CONTEXT
BUT A VERY HELPFUL STARTING
POINT FOR MANAGING VOLATILITY.
ON THE LCF WE THINK MOST OF THE
PROPOSALS ARE REASONABLE.
PROVIDING AN AUGMENTATION BEYOND
THE COLOR COULD ALLOW DISTRICTS
TO SUSTAIN PROGRAMS EXPANSIONS
MISTAKES OF SEVERAL COST
PRESSURES. RANGING FROM HIGHER
INFLATION HIGHER PENSION COSTS.
WE ALSO THANK THE PROPOSED
ATTENDANCE ADJUSTMENTS ARE
REASONABLE BECAUSE THEY WOULD
MITIGATE. THE TEMPORARY DROPS TO
THE PANDEMIC WHILE STILL
MAINTAINING THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN STUDENTS AND FUNDING
OVER A LONGER PERIOD OF TIME. WE
DO HAVE SOME NOTABLE CONCERNS
WITH THE PROPOSAL FOR COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION. THE MAY
REVISION WOULD INCREASE FUNDING
AT A FASTER PACE THAN FOR
DISTRICTS WITHOUT A COMPELLING
RATIONALE AND WE'RE CONCERNED
THAT IT WOULD MAKE THE FISA OF
THE HISTORICAL FUNDING
INEQUITIES THE STATE HAS
ATTEMPTED TO EVEN OUT OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS. WERECOMMEND
YOU REJECT THAT PROPOSAL AND
INSTEAD TAKE A LESS COSTLY
APPROACH THAT'S CLOSER TO WHAT'S
BEING PROPOSED FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. ON THE DISCRETIONARY
GRANT TO THINK THIS IS AN IDEA
SOME MERITS. WOULD HELP SCHOOLS
ADDRESS THEIR HIGHEST ONE TIME
PRIORITIES AND COMPLIMENTS OF
OTHER PROPOSALS IN THE BUDGET.
AND YOUR PRIORITIES YOU CAN
TAILOR THE PROPOSAL IN A COUPLE
WAYS YOU COULD JUST THE INTENT
LANGUAGE. FOR EXAMPLE MAYBE WANT
TO ENCOURAGE DISTRICTS TO FOCUS
MORE ON PANDEMIC RECOVERY OR
DRESSING LOCAL DEBTS AND
LIABILITIES. YOU CAN ADJUST THE
AMOUNT. THERE'S SOMETHING MORE
ALONG THE LINES OF THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS PLAN OR- OTHER THINGS
THAT YOU MIGHT WANT TO FIND IN
THIS- IN THE FINAL BUDGET. YOU
CAN EVEN ADJUST THE PAYMENT
SCHEDULE YOU WANT DISTRICTS TO
USE THOSE FUNDS TO SUPPORT
PROGRAMS OVER A PERIOD OF
SEVERAL YEARS. YOU CAN DISPERSE
FUNDS ACCORDING TO THAT TIME ON.
WE HAVE A CONCERNS WITH A FEW
SPECIFIC PROPOSALS IN THE NAY
REVISION- DOES INVOLVE SOME OF
THE TEACHER TRAINING INITIATIVES
AS WELL AS THE RIGHT TO MUSIC
SET ASIDE WITHIN THE EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAMS.
OKAY MORE ABOUT SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES THE NEXT PANEL. BUT THE
FUNDING FOR SOME OF THOSE
PROPOSAL SEEMS PREMATURE GIVEN
ALL THE FUNDING THAT'S ALREADY
BEEN MADE AVAILABLE. EITHER IN
THE JANUARY BUDGET OR IN
PREVIOUS BUDGETS. AND LASTLY WE
RECOMMEND YOU EXPLORE THE
POSSIBILITY OF PROVIDING MORE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FUNDING
FOR FACILITIES. AND WEIGHING
THAT OPTION WE DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION TO A FEW
CONSIDERATIONS. ONE IS THAT THE
STATE HAS A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF FUNDING AVAILABLE THAT'S-
ONLY AVAILABLE ON A ONE TIME
BASIS. I USING THAT FUNDING FOR
FACILITIES TO PROVIDE BENEFITS
THAT WOULD LAST FOR MANY YEARS.
I WE ALSO THINK THERE ARE SOME
PROMISING OPTIONS RIGHT NOW. ONE
COULD BE HELPING DISTRICTS
OBTAIN THE DISABILITIES THEY
NEED TO EXPANSION JUST NOT
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE KEY. IS
ALREADY THERE KEY CHALLENGE FOR
DISTRICTS AS THEY GEAR UP THE
EXPANSION. ANOTHER OPTION COULD
BE PROVIDING MORE FUNDING FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION IS A GOOD
DOWN PAYMENT BUT WE THINK THE
BACKLOG IS EVEN LARGER. AND I
COULD EVEN ACCELERATE ONE OF THE
KICKOFF PARTY IS LAID OUT. IN
THE SENATE DEMOCRATS PLAN A FEW
WEEKS AGO. OR THE STATE COULD
THINK A ONE TO AND STUFF PAYMENT
TO THE SCHOOL FOR. PROGRAM IN
THAT COULD HELP ADDRESS OF THE
BACK. IN DEMAND FOR. MAJOR
CONSTRUCTION RENOVATION. THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING COULD
QUALIFIES EXCLUDABLE CAPITAL
OUTLAY THE APPROPRIATIONS
LIMITS. AND THAT WOULD EASE SOME
OF THE PRESSURE ON THE OVERALL
STATE BUDGET. AND LASTLY IT
WOULDN'T HAVE TO COMPETE WITH
ANY OF YOUR ONGOING PRIORITY IS
. THAT COULD BE DONE ENTIRELY
WITH RE PURPOSING SOME OF THE
ONE TIME FUNDS. FUNDS THAT ARE
ONLY AVAILABLE FOR ONE TIME
ACTIVITIES. US WITHOUT A
COMPLETE MY COMMENTS AND MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE SUBSEQUENT
PANELSWILL COVER THROUGH THE
OTHER PROPOSALS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS AND THEN I'LL CHECK
WITH MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
OVERVIEW AND ONE OF THEM IS IT
THEY'RE BOTH A FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
FIRST ONE- HI ASK PREVIOUSLY IN
ANOTHER SEGMENT BUT IT'S A
QUESTION ABOUT DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS AND- STUDIES SHOW THEY
WERE MORE IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC SO HOW DO THEY BENEFIT
FROM THE EXTRA DOLLARS THAT ARE
BEING RECOMMENDED HERE. HOW DO
WE KNOW THAT EXTRA DOLLARS GO TO
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS TO
ADDRESS THEIR NEEDS ENORMOUS.
AMBER ALEXANDER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTIONS EARLIER NO
THAT AREAS BECAUSE WE'RE SEEING
YOUR OTHER COLLEAGUES THERE AND
I THOUGHT SHE WASN'T MOVING. WE
SHE WASN'T MOVING HER LIPS SO
HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET THE RIGHT
PERSON UP ON THE SCREEN THANK. I
DON'T THINK THE INTERRUPTION.
MAYBE I NEED TO SPEAK LONGER
WAIT TO GET BACK YEAH CANTOR ON
RESERVE SO I SEE MYSELF I'M
HOPING YOU'RE SEEING ME AS WELL
WE'RE GOING TO IT. THANK YOU FOR
THAT FOR THE QUESTION- YOU'LL
NOTICE AS WE GO THROUGH AND THE
INVESTMENTS IN SUBSEQUENT PANELS
EACH PROGRAM REALLY- PLACES A
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT EMPHASIS ON-
YOU KNOW. PARTICULAR STUDENT
GROUPS I MEAN I'M OBVIOUSLY THAT
BOTH LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA AUGMENTATION AS WELL AS
THAT AND YOU KNOW THE COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA. DOES GO
OUT FOR ALL STUDENTS- HOWEVER WE
WOULD NOTE THAT AS THOSE DOLLARS
ARE BEING SPENT NO THERE ARE
THERE IS OBVIOUSLY THE LOCAL
DECISION MAKING PROCESS AND
VOEPEL CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY
PROCESS THAT DOES. LOOK TO. MAKE
SURE THAT THE STUDENTS THAT ARE
AND THEY END UP LOOKING AT
STUDENT GROUPS THAT ARE
GENERATING SOME OF THE
SUPPLEMENTAL AND CONCENTRATION
BASED GRANT FUNDING DOLLARS. ARE
BEING SERVED ADAM YOU KNOW
PROPORTIONALLY TO THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT THEY'RE GENERATING.
YOU'LL ALSO SEE AND SOME OF OUR
OTHER PROGRAMS AROUND AND
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS AND SOME OF
THE LITERACY COACH AND PROPOSALS
AS WELL IN TRAILER BILL. THAT
THERE ARE PRIORITIES CALLED OUT
IN THE VARIOUS PIECES OF TRAILER
BILL TO BETTER TARGET- BUT
DOLLARS BETTER AT BEING
APPROPRIATED FOR THOSE PROGRAMS
TO THOSE. STUDENT GROUPS THAT
ARE I'M MORE HANEY. MARKET FOR
YOU AND MORE WANT TO CAN. THAT
DOES. IN THE- IN THE BUDGET
DELIVERY. AND OTHER. FOR
FINDING. IS TO. T. OFF OF A
COMMENT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S MADE WHICH IS REALLY.
A WITH THE UNPRECEDENTED GROWTH
IN. PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDS- HOW DID. THE
ADMINISTRATION DETERMINED THAT
TWO POINT ONE BILLION WAS THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL FOR LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
INCREASE WHETHER THAN A LARGER
INVESTMENT WHICH IS REFLECTED IN
THE SENATE BUDGET PLAN BUT OUR-
WHY DID DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SERVER LAND ON TWO POINT ONE
BILLION AND NOT GO HIGHER GIVEN
THE AVAILABLE ON GOING FUNDS. WE
AGREED WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- I WILL SAY THE SPECIFIC
TECHNICAL CALCULATIONS FOR WHEN
OUR COLLEAGUE CHRIS FERGUSON IS
ABLE TO JOIN- ON HOW AND HOW WE
REACH THAT SPECIFIC AMOUNT ARE
YOU REFERRING TO THE TWO POINT
ONE BILLION IN DECLINING
ENROLLMENT HOLD HARMLESS THAT
WE'RE PROVIDING FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. NO I THINK IT IS THIS
IS THE GENERAL AUGMENTATION TO
THE- ODD TO THE- NINETY EIGHT
LCF LEVEL YES IT STILL LIVES ON
THE AVAILABLE RESOURCES THAT WE
HAVE WE ALWAYS HAVE TO
PRIORITIZE- YOU KNOW DIFFERENT
NEEDS AND DIFFERENT AREAS AND AT
AT THE END OF THE DAY- WE KNOW
THIS WAS THE AMOUNT WE KIND OF
SETTLED ON- WE WEIGHED. YOU KNOW
INCREASING THE BASIC THE BASE
GRANT WHICH ALSO INCREASED THE
THAT SUPPLEMENTAL AND
CONCENTRATION GRANTS BECAUSE IT
FLOWS THROUGH THE ENTIRE
FORMULA- WE WAIT INCREASING THAT
BY A HIGHER PERCENT- I THINK
THAT MY COLLEAGUE CAN FROM THE
ALLEY- MENTIONED IT WAS
APPROXIMATELY THREE POINT TWO
THREE POINT 3% INCREASE SO THAT
WAS THAT THE NUMBER WE HAD KIND
OF- REACHED AFTER BALANCING
OTHER PRIORITIES- BUT I CAN GET
YOU MORE DETAILED INFORMATION ON
THAT- I THINK THE MORE DETAILED
INFORMATION COME UP IN THE
NEGOTIATIONS OVER THE BUDGET WE
JUST. FELT FROM THE SENATE LEVEL
THE HIGHER AMOUNT WAS WAS
JUSTIFIED AND I THOUGHT
UNDERSTANDING HOW YOU LANDED A
LOWER AMOUNT GIVEN ALL THE
AVAILABLE FUNDS WAS WAS THE
QUESTION SO WHAT WILL
DISCONTINUE THAT IN THE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE BUDGET
THANK YOU FOR YOUR RESPONSE YES
MY COLLEAGUES IF THEY HAVE. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS HERE ON THE SIDE
. AND I'LL THEY'RE BOTH GOOD
AMAZINGLY SO- FLIGHTS I THANK
EVERYBODY ON THIS ITEM AND WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE
AT ALL JUST ACKNOWLEDGE AT ALL
THESE ARE RELATED AND- ISSUE
THREE IS THE MAJOR PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT SPENDING PROPOSALS
ARE WE HAVE ALEX SHOW FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'VE TWO
PEOPLE LISTED FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
WE'LL LET THEM DECIDE. ONE OR
BOTH MICHAEL FERRIS INSERT. THEN
WE HAVE SOMEBODY AVAILABLE FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AT
CAISTOR QUESTIONS WILL BEGIN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
ALLEN CHAU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- SO I'LL PRESENT AN
OVERVIEW OF THE MAJOR. NINETY
PROPOSALS FROM THE MAY REVISION
AND THEN I HAVE SEVERAL OF MY
COLLEAGUES TO BE ABLE TO HELP
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS- SO
BEGINNING WITH COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
THE MARY VISION INCLUDES ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION ONE TIME PROP
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS FRANCE- TO EVERY
ELIGIBLE. LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCY THAT WISHES TO APPLY-
THIS FUNDING WOULD BE AN
ADDITION TO THE INITIAL THREE
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT. FOR A
TOTAL OF FOUR POINT FIVE BILLION
PROP NINETY GENERAL FUND- FOR
THE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS PROGRAM.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS REVIEWED
APPLICATIONS FOR THEIR FIRST
ROUND OF PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS AND PLANS
TO AWARD PROXIMALLY TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY GRAMS AND SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS- ADDITIONALLY THE
DEPARTMENT EXPECTS INCREASED
INTEREST IN APPLICATIONS FOR THE
SECOND ROUND OF PLANNING GRANTS
AS WELL AS FOR THIS THREE FUTURE
ROUNDS. OF IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS
- MOVING ON FOR THE EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM
AT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE HAVE
PROPOSED AN ADDITIONAL THREE
POINT FOUR BILLION ONGOING- TOP.
OF THE ONE BILLION. DOLLAR
INVESTMENT- INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT.
THAT HD NAY REVISION WE
INCREASED THAT BY AN ADDITIONAL
FOUR HUNDRED THREE MILLION FOR A
NEW ONGOING TOTAL OF FOUR POINT
EIGHT BILLION. WE ALSO MODIFIED
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
REFLECT ONCE LAST YEAR FUNDING
FOR- OF- TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT FOR ALL ELEAZAR.
REGARDLESS OF THEIR LOCATED.
PEOPLE PERCENTAGE. AB MOVIE ON
TO NUTRITION THE MAYBE FOR BOOT
- PROPOSES ADDING SIX HUNDRED
AND ELEVEN POINT EIGHT MILLION.
ONGOING PROP NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TO PROVIDE AND
ENHANCE- MEAL REIMBURSEMENT
RATES UNDER THE STATE MEAL
PROGRAM. AT THIS FUNDING WILL
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL SIXTY
THREE CENTS REIMBURSEMENT PER
MEAL AND WOULD ENSURE THAT
SCHOOL FOOD AUTHORITIES CONTINUE
TO RECEIVE CURRENT LEVELS OF
REIMBURSEMENT. WHEN FEDERAL
WAIVERS EXPIRE AT THE END OF THE
CURRENT YEAR- STATE SO THE
SIGNAL PROGRAM WOULD REIMBURSE
REMAIN COST BETWEEN THE COMBINED
FEDERAL AND STATE RATE NOT TO
EXCEED ABOUT FOUR DOLLARS AND
SIXTY TWO CENTS- AND ESSENTIAL
SCHOOL REIMBURSEMENT RATES ARE
INCREASED ANY EXCESS FUNDS WILL
BE ALLOCATED- REALLOCATED TO THE
KITCHEN INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
TRAINING GRANT PROGRAM SO WITH-
UPDATED COLA. AND ROADS
ESTIMATES- THIS PROVIDE A TOTAL
OF TWO HUNDRED AND NINE MILLION
FOR THE BASED PROGRAM- AND THEN
THE MAYBE VISION ALSO MAINTAINS.
THE FIVE HUNDRED NINETY SIX
MILLION FROM GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
FOR UNIVERSAL MEALS THESE
TOGETHER WITH THE MAY REVISED
PROPOSAL. WOULD RESULT IN A
TOTAL INVESTMENT OF ABOUT ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION. ONGOING FOR
SCHOOL NUTRITION- AND THEN SIGN
FOR THE COMMUNITY. INITIATIVE
THE MAYOR REVISION INCLUDE AN
INCREASE OF ONE. MILLION ONE
TIME. NINETY EIGHT. EXPANSION OF
THE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE FOR CDI- AS YOU MAY
RECALL THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET ACT PROVIDED THIRTEEN
POINT THREE MILLION PROP NINETY
EIGHT FOR THE CBI- THE CI WHICH
IS ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR ITS
- BILL TO BUILD CAPACITY IN
COMMUNITIES AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. TO HAVE AUTHENTIC
CONVERSATIONS WITH EACH OTHER
AND BUILD TRUST WITH THE FOCUS
ON IMPROVING OUTCOMES FOR
STUDENTS THROUGH THE CONVENIENCE
OF PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
NETWORKS FOCUS ON COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT- RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS WORK
ESPECIALLY IN AND LATER THE
PANDEMIC THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING THE EXPANSION- THAT
WOULD EXPAND THE REACH OF THE
PROGRAM TO HUNDREDS OF
ADDITIONAL AT LEAST THROUGH THE
CREATION OF PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING RESOURCES- THAT WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO ELEAZAR FREE OF
CHARGE- IN THIS NEW VESSEL WOULD
ALSO SUPPORT THE CREATION. OF A
COMMON DEFINITION AND METRICS
FOR EFFECTIVE AND EQUITABLE
COMMUNITY INSURANCE AS WELL AS
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR MANY MORE AT
LEAST YOU PARTICIPATE IN
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING NETWORKS.
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS
AND- WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
MOVE. TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. GOOD MORNING
MISTER TURNER MEMBERS MICHAEL
PHELPS WITH ILLEGAL. I'LL BE
COVERING OUR OFFICES COMMENTS ON
THREE OUT OF THE FOR PROPOSALS
IN THIS ISSUE I DON'T. THAN I'LL
TURN THINGS OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES ARE CORTES WILL COVER
CHANDA TRISTIAN. REGRETTING THE
PROPOSED AUGMENTATION FOR THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS GRANT PROGRAM.
WE RECOMMEND ADOPTING THE
FUNDING INCREASE AS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING WOULD COVER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ESTIMATES OF
THE PLAN FOR THE PROGRAM. ALL
THE LEGISLATURE COULD REDUCE THE
FUNDING AMOUNT BASED ON ITS
PRIORITIES TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IN FUTURE YEARS.
REGARDING THE EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM. WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE ADOPT
THE UNIFORMS WHEN THE RATE OF
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED. ENGLISH
ARAMBULA COME STUDENT IN GRADES
K. THROUGH SIX. BUT REJECT THE
TWO TIER PROGRAMMATIC
REQUIREMENTS INWHICH SOME
SCHOOLS WILL BE REQUIRED TO
OFFER THE PROGRAM TO ALL OF
THEIR STUDENTS. AND OTHER
STUDENTS WILL ONLY BE REQUIRED
TO OFFER THEIR- TO OFFER THE
PROGRAM TEAM MISTER AND LOW
INCOME STUDENTS. WE RECOMMEND
INSTEAD OF SETTING A UNIFORM
EXPECTATION THAT SCHOOLS MOST OF
ALL INTERESTED. ENGLISH LEARNER
AND LOW INCOME STUDENTS IN
GRADES K. THROUGH SIX. THIS
WOULD CREATE A UNIFORM FUNDING
AND PROGRAMMATIC EXPECTATIONS
FOR ALL SCHOOLS. WE ALSO
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE REJECT
THE ONE BILLION IN ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR ALL SET ASIDE FOR
ARTS MUSIC. DISTRICTS ARE LIKELY
TO HAVE SUBSTANTIAL OF. THE
PROGRAM. THE TENSION UNSPENT
FROM THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE YEARS
THAT COULD BE USED FOR ONE TIME
EXPENSES. IF THE LEGISLATURE
WERE TO ADOPT THE ONE TIME
FUNDING SET ASIDE FOR THE
EXPANDED LEARNING PROGRAM. WE
RECOMMEND REMOVING THE
RESTRICTION OF 75% OF THE FUNDS
TO SPECIFICALLY WAS FOR ARTS
PROGRAMS. REGARDING THE FUNDING
FOR THE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVES WE THINK THAT
PROVIDING FUNDING FOR THAT. FOR
THIS PURPOSE IS REASONABLE. BUT
WOULD NOTE THAT THIS PROPOSAL BE
SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION OF THE
INITIATIVE OF THE LEGISLATURE
COULD REDUCE FUNDING AMOUNT
BASED ON HIS PRIORITIES. PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN FUTURE
YEARS. WE RECOMMEND BOTH. THIS
SOME PROGRAM HAS A REPORTING
REQUIREMENT THAT WOULD BE DUE IN
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN WE
RECOMMEND THAT ON THIS RECORDING
FARMING MOVED UP TO OCTOBER
TWENTY TWENTY SIX FLIP THE
LEGISLATURE HAS TIME TO REVIEW
THE FINDINGS PRIOR TO THE
EXPIRATION OF THE- FUNDING FOR
THE PROGRAM- THAT CONCLUDES MY
COMMENTS NOW WILL TURN THINGS
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES ARTWORK
SAYS WE CAN'T OPEN FIRE COMPANY.
OF SCHOOL NUTRITION THANK YOU.
GOOD FAIR CORTEZ WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE SO
WE HAVE A COMMON WITH REGARD TO
THE NUTRITION PROPOSAL TO
INCREASE THE RATE- FOR SCHOOL
MEALS AND WE WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT INCREASES IN REIMBURSEMENT
RATES- ARE REASONABLE GIVEN COST
PRESSURES NUTRITION PROGRAMS
BASED. ON HOWEVER THE
LEGISLATURE COULD PROVIDE A
LOWER AUGMENTATION DEPENDING ON
ITS PRIORITIES AND THEN WE DO
RECOMMEND REJECTING ON THE
REALLOCATION OF ONIONS FUNDS OF
FUNDING FOR THE KITCHEN
INFRASTRUCTURE IT'S DECISIONS
ABOUT. UNSPENT FUNDS CAN BE MADE
IN THE NEXT BUDGET CYCLE AND
THAT CONCLUDES MY WORK THAT
CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS BUT I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- HELLO YES MY
COLLEAGUES FIRST ARE THEY HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. NO FROM SENATOR
MAN CENTER OF TROUBLE. I THINK
JUST FURTHER CLARIFICATION FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS TO
THE- WHAT IS THE OVER A PROPOSED
RATE FOR REIMBURSEMENT FOR
SCHOOL MEALS THE STATE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE AND THE
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT RATE. AT
THANK YOU EL SHOW DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- SO THE OVERALL STATE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE WOULD COME
OUT TO ABOUT EIGHTY NINE CENTS-
AS SORT OF LIKE THE STANDARD
REIMBURSEMENT UNDER THE STATE
MEAL PROGRAM- THE FEDERAL. THAT
REIMBURSEMENT RATES I MEAN THAT
DEPENDS ON THE PROGRAM- I DON'T
HAVE THE SPECIFIC NUMBERS IN
FRONT RIGHT NOW I BELIEVE YOU
KNOW FOR NATIONAL SCHOOL LUNCH
PROGRAM THE CURRENT YEAR IT'S
ABOUT THREE. I'M SEVENTY THREE-
FOR A FREE LUNCH- SO UNIVERSAL
MEALS WOOD- YOU KNOW FIND AT THE
COMBINE THOSE TWO COMBINED.
REYES TOGETHER. SECONDLY TO
QUESTION. THEN OUR WEBMASTER ONE
QUESTION OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HERE- B. N. AND THAT HAS
TO DO WITH- RECOMMENDATION FOR-
FOR COMMUNITY SCHOOLS GRANTS
BECAUSE THE- LEGISLATURE
APPROVED LAST YEAR THREE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR THIS PROGRAM THEN
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION DID
SEVEN HUNDRED. MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE FIRST ROUND OF PLANNING
ADMINISTRATION GRANTS JUST TWO
WEEKS AGO HOW DID MINISTRATIONS
AND DETERMINED ANOTHER ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION WHICH NEED. THE
MORNING CALL FINISHER TANGO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION NUMBER IS
BASED OFF OF THE NUMBER OF
APPLICATIONS FROM THE FIRST
ROUND OF PLANNING IMPLEMENTATION
GRANTS. AND ADDS HE EXPECTS OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
EXPECT THERE TO BE AN INCREASED
INTEREST APPLICATIONS FOR THE
FUTURE ROUNDS OF PLANNING
IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS AND
ESSENTIALLY WE USE THAT NUMBER-
AN END USER EXPECTATIONS THAT
THEY'LL BE ADDITIONAL TO
ADDITIONAL RATHER PARAGRAPHS OF
THE RISE OF PUBLICATION GRANTS.
THE NEW AND USING THOSE
ASSUMPTIONS TO GET TO THE ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION WE ALSO
WANTED TO PROVIDE THIS
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO THE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
GRANTS EVERY ELIGIBLE THAT
WISHES TO APPLY. BUT DOES THAT
MEAN THAT THUS FAR THERE HAVE
NOT BEEN THREE MILLION DOLLARS A
THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN GRANTS
THE EXPECTATION IS THEY'LL BE
GRANTED TO FULFILL WHAT'S
ALREADY BEEN APPROPRIATED AND
THREE BILLION AND THAT THERE'S A
NEED OF ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
TO IT HASN'T BEEN REALIZED YET.
IS THAT THE GIST OF IT. YES
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY HOW DO NOTE
THAT FOR BUT DISCUSS ALTHOUGH.
HE ALSO NOTED EARLIER IN THE
HEARING. THE HIGHER EDUCATION
HOUSING IS OVER SUBSCRIBED BUT
THERE WAS NO RECOMMENDATION MADE
AND THE LIBRARY GRANTS WERE
OVERSUBSCRIBED AND THERE WAS NO
RECOMMENDATION MADE SO. BUT HERE
IT'S NOT QUITE OVERSUBSCRIBED
THERE'S A RECOMMENDATION FOR
MORE SO I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
COMPARISON FOR OUR DISCUSSIONS
AS WE MOVE AHEAD. ANYTHING ELSE
ON ISSUE THREE OF FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. THEN LET'S MOVE TO
ISSUE FOR SCHOOL FACILITIES AND
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE LET ME
THANK EVERYBODY THAT WAS THERE
FOR THE PREVIOUS PANEL ON ISSUE
FOUR. OF WE HAVE JENNIFER KAKU
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND AMY LEE FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WILL BEGIN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE- GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS JENNIFER
CROCKETT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. IN PROPOSES SHIFTING TO
EUROPE APPROPRIATIONS FOR THE
ONE BILLION TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND PREVIEWS PREVIOUSLY
PROPOSED IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND NINE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND PREVIOUSLY PROPOSED
IN 232-422-1224 A TOTAL. OF TWO
BILLION ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
SIGNED IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
TO SUPPORT NEW CONSTRUCTION AND
MODERNIZATION PROJECTS THROUGH
THE SCHOOL FCILITY PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES TO APPROPRIATE ONE
POINT TWO BILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AND SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE TO SUPPORTIT IN SUPPORT OF
NEW CONSTRUCTION MODERNIZATION
PROJECTS. ADDITIONALLY THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES AN
APPROPRIATION OF ONE POINT
SEVEN. ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
ONE TIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO ADDRESS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS.
THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL MOVE TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. GOOD
MORNING SENATORS ANYWAY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I
WILL KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF BUT
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. WE RECOMMEND
TO THE LEGISLATURE ADOPTS THE TO
ME REVISION PROPOSALS ON SCHOOL
FACILITIES AND THEN OFFER SOME
ADDITIONAL CONSIDERATIONS FOR
THE LEGISLATURE FIRST
UNINTENTIONAL FUNDING PROPOSED
FOR THE SCHOOL FACILITIES
PROGRAM IT'S FUNDING WOULD ALLOW
THE STATE TO CONTINUE FUNDING
SCHOOL FACILITIES PROJECTS AFTER
THE STATE LAST SCHOOL BOND
PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE. IT'S
FORTY EXHAUSTED AND BUDGET YEAR
AS MENTIONED EARLIER BY MY
COLLEAGUE AND ISSUE TO THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
FUNDING IN THE SCHOOL FACILITIES
PROGRAM UDER PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT AS THIS MAY BE SOME
PRESSURE ON THE OVERALL STATE
BUDGET AND- EVERAL OTHER BACK
BENEFITS AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
. WE ARE NEXT TO ME. THE
PROPOSED FIND WHAT SCHOOL
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG THAT LIKELY
A KEY. DURING THE LAST RECESSION
WHEN THE STATE PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY OVER THE AMOUNT
SCHOOLS WERE REQUIRED TO SET
ASIDE FOR ROUTINE MAINTENANCE.
HERE THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER PROVIDING MORE FUNDING
AS A MAINTENANCE BACKLOG LIKE
RISA PASSES THE PROPOSED AMOUNT.
THE LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO
CONSIDER ALLOCATING FUNDING
BASED ON TAXABLE PROPERTY VALUE
RATHER THAN THE PROPOSED A
DUPLICATED PEOPLE COUNT. WE CAN
TALK MORE PROPERTY VALUE LIKELY
STRONGLY CORRELATES WITH
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE NEEDS AS
DISTRICTS WITH LOWER TAXABLE
PROPERTY VALUES ARE TYPICALLY
MORE CONSTRAINED IN OUR ABILITY
TO RAISE LOCAL FINE REVENUE. FOR
SCHOOL FACILITY IMPROVEMENTS.
THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS THANK
YOU. OUR THANK YOU IN LET ME UP
WITH A QUOTE OF- WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST AND- FOR
THOSE OF YOU LIKE ME WHO ARE
TRYING TO FOLLOW AT HOME. OF THE
WE HAD- A SCHOOL BOND THAT IN
ESSENCE IS- ESSENTIALLY THE
FUNDING IS RUNNING OUT. AND
THREW APPROPRIATIONS FROM THE
LEGISLATURE WHERE PATCHING
TOGETHER CONTINUING SUPPORT FOR
. OF FACILITIES IN IT IN THE
HOPE OF SOME OF US THAT AT SOME
POINT THERE WOULD BE A BOND FOR-
FOR FACILITIES AND IN MANY WAYS
THESE APPROPRIATIONS ARE PATCH
TO THE FUTURE AND SO. IF WE
APPROVED WHAT THE- THE MAY
REVISION IS HOW FAR AHEAD WOULD
THAT TAKE US IN FACILITIES
FUNDING AGAINST. OF THE NEED
THAT HAS BEEN DEMONSTRATED
THROUGH APPLICATIONS. I KNOW
THAT'S A CONVOLUTED QUESTION BUT
I'M TRYING TO PUT THIS IN
PERSPECTIVE ABOUT A POTENTIAL
BOND AND WHAT MONEY WE HAVE
AVAILABLE AND TELLS SUCH A
POTENTIAL BOND MIGHT BE REAL
HONEST. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION SENATOR CLEARED I THINK
THAT IS I'M A BIT OF A
CHALLENGING QUESTION TO ANSWER
AT THIS TIME I THINK WE CAN SAY
THAT THAT FUNDING THAT WAS
SUPPOSED IN BEGIN YOUR BUDGET
THAT WE'RE NOW. SHIFTS TO AT
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO SPENDING
THAT WILL COVER MOST OF THE
APPLICATIONS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
IN THE QUEUE FOR THE SCHOOL
FACILITIES PROGRAM. WE'RE NOT
ENTIRELY SURE WHAT THE RATE OF A
FUNDING REQUEST WILL BE SORT OF
AFTER THAT POINT BUT MOST LIKELY
THE FUNDING THAT THAT
ADMINISTRATION HAS SATISFIED.
WERE BOTH TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR WELL WELL I GO UP A RATHER
LONG WAY I DON'T KNOW A FINANCE
WANTS TO PROVIDE ANY ADDITIONAL
PROJECTIONS ON AND HOW FOR THE
PROPOSED FUNDING KIND OF. A LET
ME ASK THE FINANCE PERSON WAS
PROBABLY REALLY HAPPY THAT. THAT
SHE WASN'T CALLED ON ORIGINALLY. IF SHE WISHES TO COMMENT ON
THIS- THE YOU CHAIR- YEAH
ACCORDING TO THE- OF PUBLIC
SCHOOL CAN. OUR BEST ESTIMATES
RIGHT NOW ARE THAT THE FUNDING
SHOULD LAST US THROUGH THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. AFTER
THAT THAT OFFERS US SOME
PERSPECTIVE ON THE POTENTIAL
YEARS THAT WE MIGHT. OUR GO TO
THE VOTERS WITH THE BOND BUT
FROM. WHAT WHAT THAT WILL JUST
BE ANOTHER ITEM FOR DISCUSSION
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GROUND
TRUTH THOSE NUMBERS AS WE HEAD
INTO THE FINALIZATION OF THE
BUDGET DELIBERATIONS ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES ON
ISSUE FOR. SENATOR MADE. I JUST
WANTED TO NOTE THAT- THE STATE
SENATE'S VOTE BUDGET PLAN
INCLUDES- ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR
I. T. K. FACILITIES AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE
BECAUSE- I'VE HEARD FROM A
NUMBER OF SCHOOLS IN DELHI AS
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE THE FUNDS
ARE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
FACILITIES IN PLACE AND IT
LACKED THE FUNDING. TO TRY TO
IMPLEMENT THE GOVERNOR'S
AMBITIOUS UNIVERSAL T. K.
PROGRAMS I THINK IF WE WANT OUR
SCHOOLS TO. DO THIS WEEK WE HAVE
TO PROVIDE FUNDING I THINK THIS
IS APPROPRIATE SO I WOULD URGE
THAT THIS- PARTICULAR FUNDING
INVESTMENT- BE KEPT IN. WHAT ARE
THE FINAL OUTCOMES ARE. FROM THE
END LET ME JUST PIGGY BACK ON
BECAUSE ON THE THANK THE SENATOR
FOR HIS COMMENTS TONIGHT REALLY
AGREE. AND IN OUR PREVIOUS
HEARINGS WE TALKED ABOUT. BOTH
FACILITIES AND STAFF ARE BEING
ISSUES FOR. THIRTY K. PRE K. AND
THE SENATE'S PROPOSAL ALSO DOES
SOMETHING THAT I DON'T THINK IS
DONE IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL ON THAT IS THAT. A
BASIC AID SCHOOL DISTRICTS. ARE
NOT GIVEN MONEY FOR THE T. K.
PRE K. AND- ALL THE REST OF THE
SCHOOLS ARE ON THE FUNDING
FORMULA GET THEM. AND THE
SENATE'S PROPOSAL BEFORE THE
GRANTS FOR PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION WOULD APPLY TO
TWO BASIC AID SCHOOLS AS WELL AS
A WAY OF ADDRESSING THAT ISSUE.
AND I THINK THAT'S TRUE WITH THE
BLOCK GRANT FUNDS AT THE SENATE
OF RECOMMENDED IN GENERAL. AND
IT IS JUST I GET LOTS OF
QUESTIONS FROM THAT AND I WOULD
JUST ACKNOWLEDGE. THAT THERE ARE
VARYING DEGREES OF BASIC AID
SCHOOLS. OF SOME ARE VERY SMALL.
JUST OVER THE TRIGGER AB ONE
PARTICULAR LARGE PROPERTY TAX
BEARING PROPERTY IN THEIR
DISTRICT SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
AND THEN OTHERS. ARE INCREDIBLY
WEALTHY AND SUBSTANTIALLY OVER
AND BUT NEITHER ARE GIVEN ANY
MONEY THAT TO DEAL WITH T. CARE
PRE K. IN THE FACILITIES RELATED
TO IT SO. I WOULD JUST PIGGY
BACK THAT THAT COMMON ON A
SENATOR MANUAL CAN I WOULD
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH YOURS
AS WELL I FORGOT TO MAKE THAT.
EXCELLENT POINT ABOUT. THE NEED
FOR BASIC AID DISTRICTS TO ALSO
RECEIVED FUNDING A FOREIGN ASK
THEM TO TAKE ON THIS ADDITIONAL
BURDEN- EVEN BASIC AID SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DO NEED THAT FUNDING
SO I THINK I WOULD AT. SUPPORT
CENTER LATEST PUSH HERE THANK
YOU AND WE'RE TAKING THINGS UP
FOR THE DISCUSSIONS TO COME. ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS ON ISSUE FOR.
THEN SINGING LET ME THANK THE
PANELISTS AND WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ISSUE FIVE COMMISSION
ON. TEACHER CREDENTIALING
EDUCATED WORK FORCE FOR VOTE
PROPOSALS. WE HAVE MEGAN SABAH
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AMY LEE BACK FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
MERRY FIXIE SANDY FROM THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING WILL TAKE COME IN
THAT ORDER AND BEGIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
MORNING CARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MET AT THE BOTTOM PART
OF THE FINANCE- I RECOGNIZE TIME
IS RUNNING SHORT I'LL TRY TO
KEEP MY REMARKS. BRIEF EMAIL
REVISION PROPOSES NEW RESOURCES
FOR THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING INCLUDING FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND ONE
TIME. TO AUGMENT THE TEACHER
RESIDENCY GRANT PROGRAM TO
SUPPORT TEACHER AND SCHOOL
COUNSELOR RESIDENCY PROGRAM. AND
THE FUNDING MAY BE USED TO
ESTABLISH A NEW SCHOOL CUMPLIR
RESIDENCY PROGRAM OR ADVENTURE
EXISTING TEACHER RESIDENCY
PROGRAM. AT NEXT THE MAIN
REVISION PROPOSES TWENTY MILLION
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND ONE TIME FOR THE COMMISSION
TO SELECT THE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCY. THE THIRD AS A STATEWIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTER TO
SUPPORT THOSE RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS. AND THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CENTER WILL
COLLABORATE WITH THE COMMISSION
TO DEVELOP AND DISSEMINATE AND
TECHNICAL. WITH INPUT FROM
INTEREST HOLDER- AND THAT THE
FRAMEWORK AND TECHNICAL BUSINESS
WILL LEVERAGE AND BUILD UPON
EXISTING. OFFERINGS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL- AND BY AS WELL AS MY
NONPROFIT- INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER. EDUCATION OTHER
FOUNDATION- D. FINALLY THAT'LL
COVER AT THE COMMISSION IN THE
MAIN. INTENDED ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION. NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
WANTS. IN TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
TO THE TELL COUNTY OFF OF IT. TO
CONTINUE TO MINISTER. THE
CALIFORNIA CENTER ON TEACHING
CAREER. AND THEN THE REVISION
PUT. INVESTMENT AFTER OF IT. FOR
pIN SCIENCE PROFESSION DEVELOP
INITIATIVE AND THE- THREE
MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME FEW
AUGMENT RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES. FOR
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING THROUGH
THE EDUCATOR EFFECTIVENESS BLOCK
GRANT I'M WITH THE PRIORITY FOR
STEM EDUCATOR SUPPORT. UNTIL THE
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY HERE WILL
REMAIN THE SAME AS IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- EDUCATOR FACT OF THE
BLOCK GRANT INVESTMENT AND WITH
pHERE WILL BE ON PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING IN MATH AND FINANCE.
AND DID- THE MATH AND SCIENCE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
INITIATIVE ALSO INCLUDES EIGHTY
FIVE MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND ONE TIME. HE
THREE. ACRE TWELFTH GRADE.
EDUCATORS REPORT. NATIONAL
LEARNING TO IN- NEXT FIVE THE
CALIFORNIA MARKET FOR A-
CALIFORNIA FIVE STANDARDS AND
THE MATH AND FIND DOMAIN OF THE
HELL CREEK WORRY. OF THAT EIGHTY
MILLION THIRTY FIVE MILLION IS
A- TO THE FRONT COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND TO WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH. THE LIKE
ENTITY TO EXPAND AND AUGMENT ON
THE STATEWIDE EARLY MATH
INITIATIVE AND THEN THE
REMAINING FIFTY MILLION OF THAT
EIGHTY FIVE MILLION. IF TO BE
ALLOCATED TO ACCOUNT. EDUCATION
TO PARTNER WITH FRIENDS NOW-
PREGNANT EARLY MATH INITIATIVE.
I'M NOT ADDITIONAL THE MAIL
REVISION PROPOSED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ONE.
AVAILABLE- THREE. TO CONTINUE
WORK AT THE EDUCATOR WORKFORCE.
GRANT FOR THE WAY FOR COMPUTER
SCIENCE THAT WAS FUNDED ON
THROUGH THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDJAK- AND AS YOU MAY RECALL
THAT WITH A FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT. AND THAT WILL
PROVIDE PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
FOR TEACHERS AND PARA
PROFESSIONAL STATEWIDE. IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE LEARNING AND
EDUCATION AND- SEPARATELY THERE
IS AN ADDITIONAL FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS AND PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FINDS ONE TIME
AVAILABLE OVER THREE YEARS TO
CONTINUE THE WORK OF. ON THE EVE
WEEK PROGRAM TO COORDINATE AND
SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITY FOR EDUCATORS ACROSS
THE STATE AND INTERNATIONAL
EDUCATION IN SUPPORT FOR ENGLISH
LEARNERS- THE NEIGHBORHOOD CAN
ALSO PROPOSES FIFTEEN MILLION
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND ONE KIND TO SUPPORT THE
READING AND LITERACY STUFF WHEN
I THREE AUTHORIZATION. AND TO
GRANT PROGRAM. WHICH WILL
SUPPORT SIX THOUSAND TEACHERS
STERN A SUPPLEMENTARY
AUTHORIZATION READING AND
LITERACY. ON THE LAST INVESTMENT
ALL COVER OUT THE DEPARTMENT IN
EIGHTY MILLION PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND ON
GOING. TO SUPPORT THE CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEE FROM BIRTH AND
PROGRAMS- AND I'LL NOTE HERE
THAT THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL TEN
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT TO
EXPAND THE PROGRAM TO CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES AT UNITY
COLLEGE AS THE. SWELL AND THEN
FINALLY- MAY REVISION PROPOSES.
AND SHE TO THE GOLDEN STATE
GRANT. WHICH IS ADMINISTERED BY
PUBLIC THING EIGHT CONNECT. THE%
TWENTY ONE YOU BUDGET I PROVIDE
FIVE HUNDRED NOW ONE FOR THE
PROGRAM HE SPENT OVER YEARS.
EXISTING LAW ALLOW FOR GRANT UP
TO TWENTY DOLLAR DO YOU THINK
YOU ARE. ENROLLED A TEACHER
PROGRAMS- CLICK ON IN HIGH NEED
. ON AND COMMIT TO TEACHING A
PRIVATE SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA
BEFORE AND IN CALIFORNIA WHO FOR
YEARS WITHIN YEAR AFTER
COMPLETING A PROGRAM. I'M
EVERYTHING AND THEN I CAN ABOUT
THE DATA SAID FOR FUTURE AND ALL
SUBJECTS AREAS NOT JUST HOW YOU
FEEL SO IN THE REVISION X. ON
THE STATE GRANT PARK I WOULD BE
THE NEED FEEL. HI AND INCLUDING
USED TO OUR IN A AND FOR. WORKER
FROM- COUNTLESS. AMERICAN
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE I. SEVERAL
MAY TO FOR. AND BETTER. THE
ADMINISTRATION PROGRAMS I AM
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY THAT THE-
TIME TO COME. ALL ON THE LINE
FOR. RIGHT YOU. AND THEN MORE TO
THE LEGISLATIVE IN OF. THANK YOU
ANYWAY WITH L. A. M. ON THE
TEACHER PROPOSAL REQUIRE
COMMANDER APPROVE REDUCE AMOUNTS
SPECIFIC HOW OF AMOUNT FOR AND
THE TEACHER RESIDENT TECHNIQUE
ASSIST CENTER AND SEPARATELY THE
READER AND LET AUTHORIZATION
FRANCE I'M A TECHNICAL CENTER
REDUCE AMOUNT WILL AND- FOR. I
JUST OVER I WHICH WILL COULD
CONSIDER FUNDING AND FOR THE AND
GRANTS A REDUCED AMOUNT
REFLECTING MORE REASONABLE
GROWTH TARGET WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THE REMAINING
TEACHER PROPOSALS UNDER THIS
ISSUE. STARTING FIRST WITH A
PROPOSED FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR ADDITIONAL TEACHER RESIDENCY
GRANT WE THINK SUCH A
SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME
AUGMENTATION IS PREMATURE GIVEN
THAT AROUND TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETY MILLION OF THE FUNDING
PROVIDED IN THE LAST BUDGET HAS
INCLUDING NEW SCHOOL COUNCIL
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS COULD HAVE
LIMITED BENEFITS AS SCHOOL
COUNSELING IS NOT AN AREA OF
CHRONIC SHORTAGE TYPICALLY FOR
THE STATE AND THE INTEREST AMONG
SCHOOLS TO DEVELOP THESE
RESOURCE INTENSIVE. REMAINS
UNCLEAR LIKEWISE ON THE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
PROPOSALS RELATED TO MATH
SCIENCE AND EDUCATOR WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT GRANTS THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET PROVIDED ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE OVER FIVE YEARS FOR A
WIDE RANGE OF EDUCATOR.
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. CONFRONTING IS
STILL OF A FROM LAST YEAR'S
FINDING AND SCHOOL CAN PROBABLY
USE THESE MUSIC THIS FIND. OR
EXPRESSION BASED ON LOCAL. AND
TAILORED TO LOCAL. AS SUCH WE
THINK STATE OF NEED TO FIND.
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AT THIS
TIME. MOVING ON WE ALSO
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE REJECT
THE PROPOSED EIGHTY MILLION ON
GOING FOR THE CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES SCHOOL SUMMER
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. THE
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES STATEWIDE
HAVE ON EQUAL ACCESS TO THE
PROGRAM AS ONLY THREE HUNDRED
AND ELEVEN OUT OF ABOUT ONE
THOUSAND SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
COUNTY OFFICES. PARTICIPATE IN
SAID WE THINK LOCALLY NEGOTIATED
PAY RAISES FOR CLASSIFIED STAFF
THROUGH THE PROPOSED ALTHEA HAVE
FACED INCREASED. WOULD BE MORE
EQUITABLE AND WIDESPREAD. LASTLY
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSES
MODIFYING GOLDEN STATE TEACHER
GRANTS THE ON THE HIGH NEED
FIELDS. FOR EXAMPLE SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND STEM FIELDS-
INSTEAD INCLUDE ALL TEACHER
CANDIDATES AND PEOPLE ARE
PERSONAL SERVICE CREDENTIALS
INCLUDING SOCIAL WORKERS
COUNSELORS AND PSYCHOLOGISTS. WE
RECOMMEND TO THE LEGISLATURE
REJECTS THESE CHANGES AND NOT
ALL PROFESSIONS OR SUBJECT AREAS
THAT WOULD BE NEWLY ELIGIBLE ARE
IMPACTED BY CHRONIC SHORTAGES.
FURTHER EXPANDING ELIGIBILITY
COULD REDUCE THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THESE GRANTS TO ENCOURAGE
INDIVIDUALS PURSUE YOU THE HIGH
NEED TEACHING FIELDS WHICH
SCHOOL TYPICALLY HAVE MORE
DIFFICULTY STOPPING AND- THAT
INCLUDES MY COMMENTS BUT HAPPY
TO ANSWER. QUESTIONS OF
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY THAT COMPLETE OUR
PAN AND KNOW WE PEOPLE. A ANSWER
. IT WAS JUST MENTIONED THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING IS HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS IF WE NEED THEM AND
WE'RE RUNNING REALLY LOW ON TIME
AND SO. RATHER THAN ASK A
QUESTION- JUST MAKE THE
STATEMENT THAT I NOTED TO THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT INCLUDED.
ARE IN PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
SUBJECTS OTHER SUBJECTS LIKE
SOCIAL SCIENCES IN LANGUAGE ARTS
AND AS WE TALK ABOUT THIS GOING
TO THE- TO THE CLOSE. WILL JUST-
IT- ASK FOR A RESPONSE ON THAT.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
NON FROM CENTER CHAU BOGGED DOWN
FROM SENATOR MAN THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING THERE ON. UP ON THE
SIDE WILL MOVE TOWARD LAST ISSUE
IN- CAPABLE TWELFTH PARK. WHICH
IS EARLY EDUCATION. AND WE HAVE
JODI LIEBERMAN FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND SARAH
CORTEZ FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S. OFFICE WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING CHIU
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JERRY
LIEBER WITH THE OF FINE. ALL
RIGHT OVER OF THE NOTABLE- EARLY
EDUCATION RELATED INVESTMENTS
INCLUDING THE MAY REVISE FOR
BOTH TRANSITIONAL INDERGARTEN
AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM I'LL BE
STARTING WITH TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN. FOR TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN FOR THE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
EXPANSION PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE REDUCE THE
DOLLAR PREPARATION BY
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FIVE
MILLION AT. THIS WOULD FAVORITE
AT NAY REVISION WHICH IS ARE A
REFLECTION OF THE REVISED EIGHTY
EIGHT ESTIMATES IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY THREE
YEAR. AND TRAILER BILL WE ALSO
CLARIFY AUDIT PENALTIES RELATED
TO CLASS SIZE RATIOS AND TEACHER
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS IN TWO K.
CLASSROOMS REQUIRED BY LOCAL
SIGN OPTIONS FOR TKA AND FOR THE
PURPOSES OF FUNDING ADDITIONAL
CERTIFIED OR CLASSIFIED STAFF
PERSON TO EVERY CLASSROOM YOU
SPECIFY- THAT WOULD BE BASED ON
P. TWO EIGHTY EIGHT IN THE
PREVIOUS YEAR. WE WANT TO RESULT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES FAMILY FEE
WAIVERS FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM OF THE TEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND AND
TEN POINT FIVE MILLION GENRAL
FUND TO PROVIDE THESE WAIVERS
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE FISCAL YEAR. IN
ADDITION THE MAYOR REVISION
PROPOSES INVESTING ONE POINT ONE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY
TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR TO
SUPPORT FAMILY FEE WAIVERS FOR
THIS- THIS CURRENT. YEAR ALSO
INCLUDE AS AN EXTRA. OF THE
STATE PRESCHOOL FUN HOLD
WILL PROVIDE IT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM OF
FUNDING BASED OFF OF THE MAXIMUM
REIMBURSABLE AMOUNT. BASED A
PERCENT TO THEIR STATE
CONTRACTS. FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY TWENTY THREE FISCAL
YEAR. WE DO NOT EXPECT THERE TO
BE A COST THE STATE'S IMPLEMENT
THIS RATHER WE EXPECT SUPPORT OF
STAVING. ADDITIONALLY THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES TO INCREASE
THE DOLLAR PREPARATION FOR
INCLUSIVITY RATES THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR STUDENTS WITH
SIGNIFICANT NEEDS AND BILL
LANGUAGE LEARNERS. THE INCREASE
WILL BE FOR THREE POINT NINE
MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND AND THIRTY MILLION
GENERAL FUND. WE WERE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
CALCULATE THE COST PROVIDING NEW
ADJUSTMENT FACTORS BASED OFF
CONTRACT LEVEL DATA. AS OPPOSED
TO SYSTEM WIDE TOTALS AS DONE IN
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. FINALLY THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSES TO ADMIT
JUST FACTOR OF ONE POINT EIGHT
FOR TWO YEAR OLD CHILDREN. WE DO
NOT ANTICIPATE A SIGNIFICANT
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
PROPOSAL AS WE EXPECT THE NUMBER
OF TWO YEAR OLDS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE CIRCULAR. AND THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL MOVE ON TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
MORNING INTERPRETATIVE ELLIE L.
AND WE JUST HAVE A COMMENT WITH
REGARD TO THE MEAN REVISION
PROPOSAL TO CONTINUE REIMBURSING
STATE PRESCHOOL PROVIDERS ARE
FULL CONTRACT AMOUNT REGARDLESS
OF THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN THEY
SERVE WELL THE PROPOSAL PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR BOTH CHILD CARE AND
PRESCHOOL PROVIDERS THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
IMPLEMENTING A MULTI YEAR
CLASSES TRANSITION TO FUNDING
EXCLUSIVELY BASED ON ENROLLMENT
IN THE FUTURE. WITH A MULTI YEAR
PLAN CHILD CARE PROVIDERS WOULD
HAVE CLEAR EXPECTATIONS TO HELP
THEM WORK TOWARDS SERVING THE
NUMBER OF CHILDREN THEY DID
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC. THANK YOU
AND I'M AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU N. I WOULD NOTE AGAIN
OUR PREVIOUS CONVERSATION ABOUT
FACILITIES AND STAFF BUT LET ME
ASK MAYBE THE ADMINISTRATION ONE
QUESTION BECAUSE I KNOW WE'RE
JUST. ALMOST OUT OF TIME AND I
NEED TO HAVE SOME MEASURE OF
PUBLIC COMMENT HERE. ARM IS THE
MOST RECENT ENROLLMENT DATA FOR
THE SCHOOL YEAR SHOWED THAT THE
LARGEST DECLINE IN AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE WAS IN THE
KINDERGARTEN. THROUGH THIRD
GRADE CATEGORY. AND I WONDERED
IF THE ADMINISTRATION
ANTICIPATES WITHIN ITS UPDATED
ESTIMATES FOR TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN- IS THIS EXPANSION
ON THE IT BASED ON THE FACT THAT
THE ENROLLMENT WILL RECOVER SOON
OR WOULD THIS SAME LOS BE
EXPERIENCED FOR THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS HOW DOES THAT DECLINING
ENROLLMENT IN THOSE GRADES-
IMPACT WHAT YOU'RE BRINGING
FORWARD IN THIS PROGRAM.
STODDERT CHAIRMAN I CHRIS
FERGUSON WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- SO CERTAINLY IT REDUCES
THE OVERALL COST TO IMPLEMENT-
YOU KNOW UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN- IT ISN'T A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OVER THE
MULTI YEAR PERIOD- THAT SAID- WE
DO HERE YOUR BROADER QUESTION
AROUND- DECLINING ENROLLMENT
TRENDS WOULD YOU PROPOSE THAT
THREE YEAR ROLLING AVERAGING
USING- YOU KNOW CURRENT YEAR
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE- IN A
MODIFIED VERSION THAT WILL HELP.
FOR THE TRADITIONAL- I
ENROLLMENT DECLINES THAT THAT
YOU WERE NOTING BUT IN TERMS OF
THE OVERALL- PROPOSAL FOR A
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN YOU
KNOW WE SAW THE IMPACT IS
RELATIVELY MINOR WHEN IT WAS
SPECIFIC TO- JUST THE T. K.
PROJECTION. THANK YOU AND SO IN
SHORT. THOSE DECLINING
ENROLLMENT FIGURES ARE BODY DID
WHAT YOU'RE RECOMMENDING HERE.
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT QUESTIONS FROM
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES ON THE SIDE
NO FROM SENATOR MENSEN ROACH
JOB. I DO AND- JUST. UNSURE OF
WHAT OUR FUTURE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS WILL BE- COVERING
RATHER NOT READ HAVING I DO HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS WITH REGARDS TO.
THE AB PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS BOTH
INTO DELIVERY AND THE AB. TYPES
OF PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS THAT WILL
BE ABLE TO FIND SPECIAL WITH THE
REVISED AND SO FORTH JUST TO
GET. SPECIFIC- ISSUES ADDRESSED
ONE- I'M CREATURES I HAVE I
PERSONALLY HAVE A BILL IN- IN
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS I'M I'M
SORRY IN THE ASSEMBLY AND ASKING
THE STALLED THERE BUT IT'S WITH
REGARDS TO PARENT ENGAGEMENT AB
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS AND I'M SORT
OF CURIOUS I I'VE READ- IN SOME
OF OUR THE NAY REVISIONS THAT I
HEAR THAT THERE IS A WELLNESS
MINDFUL PROGRAMS THAT ALLOCATE
EIGHTY FIVE MILLION OVER TWO
YEARS TO SUPPORT GRANTS FOR
WELLNESS MINDFUL. MINDFULNESS
PROGRAMS IN SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES AND EXPANSION OF
PARENT SUPPORT AND TRAINING
PROGRAMS- AND THERE'S ANOTHER
ONE. IN THE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE IN WHICH THE MAY
REVIEW REVISION INCLUDES A ONE
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME PROP
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO
CONTINUE THE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT INITIATIVE WHICH
DISSEMINATES BEST PRACTICES FOR
SCHOOL COMMUNITY INTERACTION-
AND SO FORTH SO IF I WERE TO ASK
AND IF WE HAD INTERESTED- VESTED
STAKEHOLDERS THAT WOULD LIKE TO.
LEARN ABOUT PARENT PARTICIPATION
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS AS AN
ADDITIONAL DELIVERY OR AB- TYPE
OF A PRESCHOOL PROGRAM AVAILABLE
IN OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. I'M WHICH WITH
THERE BE ANYWHERE HERE WHERE
THESE PARTICULAR PROGRAMS COULD
BE- APPROPRIATED OR- IT IT
IMPLEMENTED UNDER WHAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET. I KNOW WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT AND I KNOW
THE SACRAMENTO BEE COUPLE AT
EIGHT REPRESENT A COUPLE OF.
TIMES IN THIS COMMITTEE WITH
REGARDS TO YOU READING AND OUR
SCORES IN THE STATE I KNOW WE'RE
ALLOCATING A LOT OF FUNDING IN
IN TRAINING READING SPECIALISTS
AND SO FORTH BUT ONE OF THE
COMPONENTS SAID THE ARTICLE
DRESS WAS THE IMPORTANCE OF
PARENT ENGAGEMENT AND I TRULY
BELIEVE THAT THE- YOU KNOW THE-
YOUNGER. A STUDENT POPULATION
THAT WE INCLUDE OUR PARENTS AND
REALLY EMPOWERING THEM WITH THE
RESOURCES AND A LARGE BASE OF
TOOLS THE TWO KIDS TO BE ABLE TO
HELP THEM. OUT BE BETTER
PREPARED PARENTS NAVIGATING
THEIR STUDENTS EDUCATIONAL
BEHAVIORAL AND PHYSICAL-
ACADEMIC WELL BEING- THE BETTER
WE WILL BE IN CALIFORNIA SO I'M
KIND OF CURIOUS- ASKED YOU IF
THERE'S ANYTHING WITHIN THIS
THIS MAY REVISED WHERE WE COULD.
INCLUDE BUT OUR SCHOOLS OUR
COMMUNITIES COULD ACTUALLY- HAVE
FUNDING FOR THESE TYPE OF
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS AND WHO IS
YOUR QUESTION DIRECTED I GUESS
IT WOULD BE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE GREAT AND I SEE THREE
DIFFERENT PEOPLE I THINK FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DID.
WHAT I WANTED TO PICK. ONE AND
DECIDE WHO'S GOING TO RESPOND.
INFORMALITY THE DIFFERENT OF
FINANCE I'M HAPPY TO REST ON ON
BEHALF OF OUR T. THERE- I DID
WANT TO TACKLE YOUR- SENATOR.
THE ENGAGEMENT INITIATIVE WELL
THAT INITIATIVE HAS NOT FOCUSED
EXCLUSIVELY ON PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS AND IS FOCUSED. ON MORE
BROADLY PARENT AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AND THAT WOULD
INCLUDE- YOU KNOW PARENTS AS
WELL AS COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT
ARE AND FOCUSED EXCLUSIVELY ON A
PRESCHOOL ISSUES ARE SUPPORTING
PRESCHOOL AGE CHILDREN. SO
THERE'S DEFINITELY AN
OPPORTUNITY- FOR THEIR
ENGAGEMENT THROUGH THROUGH THAT
AVENUE- IT WILL SAY THAT THE
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT THAT'S INCLUDED IN
THE BUDGET IS- IT'S AN
AUGMENTATION TO I AM AN INITIAL
INVESTMENT IN THE PROGRAM IT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
I MEAN HAS BEEN UNDER WAY BUT WE
ARE HOPEFUL THAT THIS AS SECOND
MORE AND MORE ROBUST AROUND THE
WORLD YOU FOR COMPREHENSIVE AND
FOCUSED ON AREAS I'M- INCLUDING
AT A PRESCHOOL STUDENT TO
STUDENT VOICES ANOTHER ONE OR
HELPING WILL BE ELEVATED.
FURTHER IN THE SECOND ROUND OF
FUNDING. I WOULD JUST WANT TO
JUST. ENCOURAGE- ALL OF US TO
TRULY LOOKINTO HAVING MAKE
PERHAPS MORE SPECIFIC LANGUAGE
THAT WE CAN. CLEARLY IDENTIFY AS
A SOURCE FOR FUNDING FOR-
PRESCHOOL PARENT PARTICIPATION
WE HAVE A LOT OF DELIVERIES AND
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING IT MAKES
DELIVERY ON THAT BUT I HAVEN'T
YET SEEN ONE THAT SPECIFICALLY-
DIRECTS OR ALLOWS FOR PARENTS TO
BE IN THE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM AND
WE I KNOW WE'VE HAD. SEVERAL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT HAVE
BEEN INCREDIBLY EFFECTIVE
INCLUDING HERE IN IN SACRAMENTO
AND PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXISTENCE HAVE EXISTED AT THE
SUCCESSFUL BUT YET WE HAVEN'T
HAD IT- DIRECT FUNDING FOR IT
AND WE'VE HAD WE'VE LOST SOME OF
THOSE PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT THE
STATESO I WOULD. HIGHLY
RECOMMEND THAT WE EAT WE EAT.
TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF
RESPONSIBILITY AND- DIRECTORS
FUNDING FOR THESE APPROACH
BECAUSE I THINK THEY'RE
INCREDIBLY POWERFUL- IN THAT.
AND THEN ANOTHER SUGGESTION THAT
I WANT TO TAKE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
JUST KIND OF HIGHLIGHT. I'M
BEING THAT WE DO HAVE OUT I JUST
SPOKE WITH THE GROUP WITH
REGARDS TO PROGRAMS THAT ALLOW.
PARENTS TO. HAVE PROGRAMS
AVAILABLE TO HELP THEIR THEIR
STUDENTS TEACH READING AND SO
FORTH ANOTHER FLEXIBILITY. IN IN
THESE PROGRAMS BUT SOMETHING.
HAPPENED THAT COULD- DIRECT
FUNDING FOR THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS- SOMETHING TO CONSIDER
AND JUST PUNTING THE SEED HERE
IS TO ALLOW LANGUAGE SUCH AS
QUOTEUNQUOTE DISTRICT OR COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION PROVIDED
INSTRUCTIONAL TOOLS AND CAPACITY
BUILDING. FOR PARENT ENGAGEMENT
IN STUDENT LEARNING- WE TALK
ABOUT GIVING A LOT OF LOCAL
FLEXIBILITY AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
BUT I THINK HAVING DIRECT
LANGUAGE SO WE CAN UTILIZE. AND
KIND OF PULL FROM SO WE CAN
HAVE. MORE ACCESS TO PROGRAMS
WORK FOR PARENTING GAUGE MEANT
WOULD BE INCREDIBLY HELPFUL AND
BENEFICIAL FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND OUR EDUCATIONAL
ENDEAVORS BECAUSE- QUITE FRANKLY
WE ALL AGREED THAT. OUR OUR
STUDENTS ARE IN THE CLASSROOM
FOR AN AVERAGE OF SIX TO EIGHT
HOURS BUT THEY STILL HAVE TO GO
HOME AND UNLESS WE REALLY
EMPOWER PARENTS TO HAVE THE
SKILL SETS THE KNOWLEDGE BASE-
THE TOOL KITS THAT THEY NEED IN
ORDER FOR THAT FOR I TO BETTER
SUPPORT THEIR STUDENTS. OR THEIR
CHILDREN- YOU KNOW WE WON'T BE
AS EFFECTIVE AS WE CAN BE SO IF
I COULD JUST PLANT THOSE SEEDS-
TO ALL OF YOU AND- AS WE MOVE
FORWARD I WOULD LOVE TO SEE A
LITTLE BIT MORE SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE THAT WE CAN.
ACCOMMODATE THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR I. YOUR COMMENTS AND I.
AM CONFIDENT EVERYBODY IS NOTING
THEM FOR AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS THAT
COMPLETE ISSUE SIX. IN THE ONE
ITEM WE HAVE LAUGHED IS TAKING
PUBLIC COMMENT. AND WE HAVE RUN
OUT OF TIME SO I'M GONNA TRY TO
DO AS ABBREVIATED. AS POSSIBLE
SO IF YOU ADDRESSED IT AND ALL
START WITH IN THE ROOM. IF YOU
JUST SAY YOUR NAME YOUR GONNA
SESSION AND JUST YOUR POSITION
MORE MONEY LAST MORNING ONE PLAN
ANOTHER PLAN JUST SO THAT WE CAN
GO THROUGH THIS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE- WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. I GUESS GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JONATHAN CLAY ON BEHALF
OF SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE PROPOSAL
FOR FUNDING FOR THE IMPERIAL
VALLEY CAMPUS THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS JEFF BARKER
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
AND THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
SUPERINTENDENT OF RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. EXPRESSING SUPPORT FOR.
THE PROPOSAL ON PAGE THREE TO
ALLOW ELEAZAR TO USE THEIR
PREVIOUS ATTENDANCE YIELDS IN
THE CURRENT YEAR. SUPPORT FOR
THE BLOCK GRANT APPROACH
REFLECTED IN ALL ALL BOTH THE
SENATE PLAN AND THE MAY REVISED.
AND GRATEFUL FOR THE SENATE
SUPPORT FOR FUNDING HOME TO
SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION. AND
LASTLY SUPPORT FOR THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR COUNTY
OFFICES OF VETERANS CALPERS
CHECKED OUT BUT IF EVERYBODY'S
THAT LONG WHAT. WILL BE HERE
FOREVER AND WE CAN'T BE I TRY TO
BE BRIEF CENTER. AND MEMBERS
BRIAN WHITE OF WITH HE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS REPRESENTING ASSOCIATION
OF PERSONALIZED LEARNING TOOLS
AND SERVICES OR A PLUS. A WEEK'S
APPRECIATE THE PROM NINETY EIGHT
INCREASE FUNDING HOWEVER WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT POLICY CONCERNS
ABOUT EXCLUDING NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS FROM. THE
HOLD HARMLESS PROVISIONS. THAT
IS JUST THE FINAL UNFAIR ALSO
SHOULD YOU KNOW NOT GET CAN'T
COMMENT WHETHER IT'S FAIR NOT
JUST TELL ME WHAT THE AFFORD
AGAINST WE ARE AGAINST THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AT ITS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I CLASS AND
THEY START. WE APPRECIATE IT
NINE OF THE FIRST THREE
WITNESSES HAVE BEEN SITTING HERE
PATIENTLY WAITING AS AS THIS
PERSON. WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS- MATT
IDEA- MEMBER OF THE ORGANIZATION
GENERATION UP AND A STUDENT AT
UC BERKELEY- HERE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR EXPANDED FUNDING FOR
THE CAL GRANT EQUITY. FRAMEWORK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTER
TURN. ACTION AND SO WITH COST
STUDENTS. WHERE TRONG SUPPORT OF
THE- CALL. PROPOSAL THAT HUNDRED
EIGHTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS. AND
A RECURRING FUNDING- REQUESTED
FROM THE CSU- THE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS AND FINALLY THE
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS- INVESTED IN A
PROGRAM FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. GOOD AFTERNOON STEPHANIE
GOLDMAN ON BEHALF OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE SUPPORT
PART TIME FACULTY HEALTH CARE WE
SUPPORT CAL GRANT REFORM. AND
CHANCES OFFICE STAFFING AND WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE SENATE'S WELSH
WORK PLAN FOR STUDENT SUPPORT
SERVICES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RACCOON PARTIAL WOULD YOU ASPIRE
WE SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLY VERSION
OF THE INVESTMENTS IN THE
CALDERON REFORM- AS WELL AS- BUT
CALLING FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR STAFFING FIRMS HE SACKED. TO
SUPPORT A GIGGLE FIVE SO
INTIMIDATION- AS WELL AS-
CALLING FOR ADDITIONAL FORTY
FORTY OF THE FPI OF THE
CURRENTLY THERE'S A PROPOSAL FOR
TEN MILLION. WOULD LIKE TO ASK
FOR INITIAL TWENTY MILLION FOR A
TOTAL OF THIRTY ONE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GRASSROOTS AJ LUCAS
WITH UNITED LEYVA TRUSTED
BUSINESS. IN THE EARLY REGION
AND WE SUPPORT COG ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR CALIFORNIA GRANT
EQUITY FRAMEWORK. OUR EMPLOYERS
AND OUR WORK FOR THE MOMENT
AGENCIES TRUST THAT THIS. NEW
MODERNIZATION WILL HELP- WAS
VERY KIND TO ME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AS CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN
LINGER ON THE OFF THE CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION WE
ALSO HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE NON
CLASSROOM BASED EXCLUSION ON THE
HOLD HARMLESS. A LOT OF THOSE
PROGRAMS DO HAVE CLASSROOM BASED
SETTINGS- THEIR HYBRID TYPE
PROGRAMS AND SO EXCLUDING THEM
WE THINK IS- NOT APPROPRIATE
ALSO ON THE LONG TERM EIGHTY A
HOLD HARMLESS A THREE YEAR
ROLLING AVERAGE WE ARE CURRENTLY
NOT INCLUDED AND WOULD LIKE TO
SEE CHARTER SCHOOLS INCLUDED IN
THAT. WERE ALSO NOT INCLUDED IN
THE TRANSPORTATION FUNDING WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK WITH YOUR OFFICE
AND- YOUR STAFF ABOUT- HOW WE
COULD BE I COULD REALLY
EQUITABLY INCLUDED IN THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON- CENTERS MY
NAME IS KIMBERLY WELL I'M A
STUDENT UC BERKELEY AND
REPRESENTATIVE GENERATION UP
WHICH IS STUDENT LED EDUCATION
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION THAT
REPRESENTS. WITHOUT STUDENTS
ACROSS THE STATE. ASSEMBLY ASA
SUPPORT INVESTMENT OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION. AND THE
FINAL STATE BUDGET TO IMPLEMENT
THE CALVET AGREE. ASSOCIATIONS
YOU KNOW USE IT IS- AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THE INCLUSION OF U.
S. P. FOSTER USES IMPACTED AND
SAFE HAPPEN WE'RE ASKING FOR
INVESTING AND CAL GRANT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE DEFICIENCY. HI I'M
MICHELLE ANDREWS I'M ALSO STOOD
AT UC DAVIS HERE WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION- ALSO WANT
TO REITERATE OUR- THAT WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THE SUPPORT FOR C.
PAP U. S. KEYS- AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH. AND THEN WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE AN INVESTMENT THE
CAL GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HI
EVERYONE HI MY NAME IS MARIA
MARTINEZ I'M ALSO A STUDENT AT
UC DAVIS- AND I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF. THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATIONS ASKS FOR FUNDING
FOR THE YOU SEE. THE PEPPER
GRAMS UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT
PROGRAMS AND THE CAL GRANT
EQUITY FRAMEWORK THANK YOU THANK
YOU. GOOD EVENING MY NAME'S
THOUSAND PRASAD VICE PRESIDENT
LEGISLATORS FOR THIS INCIDENT
FOR CALIFORNIA CAN YOU COLLEGES
AND SUPER GRATEFUL FOR THE
FUNDING OF THE NEXT UP PROGRAM.
AND CAL GRANT BUT LOOK TO SEE
MORE INVESTMENT FOR ITS CURRENT
FORM THANK YOU THANK YOU
IT'S NOT EVENING YET WE DON'T
WANT TO. GO THAT FAR. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS
RECOMMEND BECAUSE REPRESENTING
CARBON CYCLE INSTITUTE THE
AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE ACTION
NETWORK. AND THE CERTIFIED
CALIFORNIA CERTIFIED ORGANIC
FARMERS WE'D LIKE TO- SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
INVEST IN THE AGTECH. EDUCATION
SENATE GRAMS WE LIKE SOME OF THE
FOCUSED MORE ON SUSTAINABLE AND-
ORGANIC AGRICULTURE PRACTICES.
WE'D ALSO LIKE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ALLOCATED TO THE CSU
SYSTEM. FOR MORE ON TECHNICAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON KAREN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GENEVIEVE
CUTTING SHOW FOR I AM A STUDENT
AT UC SAN DIEGO AND A MEMBER OF
GENERATION UP AN EDUCATIONAL
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION LED BY
STUDENTS. I'M HERE TO ASK YOU
INCLUDED THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING THE CAL GRANT EQUITY
FRAMEWORK THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THANKS FOR
EVERYBODY FOR THEIR DISCIPLINE
IN THE ROOM. AND WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO THE PHONE LINE AND I WAS
TOLD THERE THIRTY IN Q.
MODERATOR WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO- CRYSTAL HOW MANY
ARE IN QUEUE RIGHT NOW.
MODERATOR. ONE MOMENT HERE. OUR
WE HAVE FIFTY. WE CAN'T DO THAT
. WE WERE SUPPOSED TO BE OUT OF
THIS ROOM FIFTEEN MINUTES AGO
SO- I'M GONNA GO- TELL TWELVE
TWENTY AND TAKE HOWEVER MANY CAN
I SPEAK AND SO JUST OF THOSE OF
YOU ON THE LINE NAME
ORGANIZATION IN YOUR POSITION
AND ALONG YOUR SPEAK TO LET
SOMEBODY ELSE. ARE GETS TO GO SO
MODERATOR LET'S BEGIN. HERE WE
GO FIRST TO LINE TWENTY FIVE.
ONE TWENTY FIVE. A FIVE YEAR
OPEN. THANKS LINE OLD. WE ARE
LARA LEVIN. I DO THINK WE HAVE A
LOT OF CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER AND
BUT ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION OUR GOAL
WOULD BE TO ASK YOUR INSURER-
INCLUSION AND SUCCESS OF THE OF
THE STATE ENGLISH LEARNERS
THANKS THE ADMINISTRATION BRING
CLEAN FUNDING FOR THE EDUCATOR
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT GRANT BUT
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE NEED FOR
MORE FUNDING SPECIFICALLY
WORKING WITH LEARNERS. FOR A
TOTAL OF TWENTY MILLION YES THE
SENATE TO INCLUDE A TEN MILLION
APPROPRIATION TO BRING BACK THE
BILINGUAL TEACHER PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS THANK YOU
VERY. MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALLER
. LIKE TWENTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON IS EXPECTED OUT OF
RIKERS STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF
THE CREATE CALIFORNIA WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE SENATE TO
CONSIDER ONE BILLION INVESTMENT
. OR INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS IN
OUR IMAGINATION AND WORLD
LANGUAGE POLICY FRAMEWORK FOR
THE BUDGET AFTER BREXIT IN AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. I. THIRTY FIVE. HI
THIS IS NELSON THOUGH- WITH PCS
THE LOBBY CORPS AND I'M HERE TO
SAY I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE EXTRA
FUNDING FOR THE UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENT PROGRAM STATE BANK AND
CAL GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK ON
BEHALF OF THE CCP SITUATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALL IT. FORTY
SIX. HI MY NAME IS WHAT AND I
THINK THE OKAY CARE ACT WORKING
ONE DOLLARS I ASK YOU TO PLEASE
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT YES THIS
BUDGET CYCLE BY 45% ONGOING
FUNDS AND TEN MILLION ON FUNDS
FOR OUR CARE PROGRAMS WE ALL
SUPPORT FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR OUR NEXT. YEAH ALSO. FIFTY
NINE ONE TIME FOR PARK WILL AND
TREATMENT FOR APPROACH. THE ONES
TO FIND YOU VERY MODERATOR NAY
CALL. MY FOUR. HELLO THIS IS FOR
DOCTOR ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY FACILITY COALITION WE
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACILITIES WE
SUPPORT THE NEXT ALLOCATION OF
THE PROPERTY ONE BOND FUNDS FOR
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECT
ADDITIONALLY WE REQUEST THE NEW
INFUSION OF FUNDS THAT THE COURT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAPITAL OUTLAY
OF BONTA THIRTY HAVE ENTIRELY
COMMITTED TO YOUR PROJECT ASKING
FOR TWO POINT SIX BILLION FOR
THE PROGRAMS TO BRIDGE UP TO A
NEW STATEWIDE PROGRAM THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
NEXT CALL. NINE FORTY EIGHT. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON CAROL GONZALEZ ON
BEHALF OF LONG BEACH COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT SANTA MONICA
COLLEGE AND ST- COLLEGE ARE WE
SUPPORT THE HOLD HARMLESS FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ADDING OF
COLA TO THE HOLD HARMLESS
BEGINNING TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY TWENTY SIX. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
NEXT CALL. NINE FIFTY TWO. HELLO
MY NAME IS ALEX. SHARES OF.
HOWEVER I DON'T AGREE THROUGH
THE FULL FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDING. PROGRAMS WELL
YOU'RE NOT BILLION DOLLARS ON
GOING. AROUND AS WELL AS FUNDING
FOR THE PROGRAM I COULD BE
FRAMEWORK THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND LET ME REMIND
EVERYBODY TO MEET YOUR DEVICES
WHEN. YOU'RE SPEAKING MODERATOR
NEXT CALL. THANK YOU. JOSH
REAGAN ON BEHALF CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK IT'S PAID A PATH
FOR THAT FREE COLLEGE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS WORK RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING THAT YOU SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS THE
FINAL BUDGET IMPLEMENT THE
CONTRACT BURKE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MY. FIFTY FIVE.
HELLO MY NAME IS ONE OF US HERE
ON THE STATE YOU SIXTY I DON'T
WANT OTHER THAN ASKING FOR
SUPPORT FOR ONGOING FUNDING FOR
STATES THAT ADOPT A SAID
PROGRAMS AND OVERALL SUPPORT FOR
THE FUNDING OF THE TALLGRASS
EQUITY FRAMEWORK IN BEHALF OF
UTSA THANK YOU THANK. YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NINE
SIX. HI MY NAME IS ERIN ROBERTS
I AM A STUDENT AT UCSB I'M
CALLING IN ORDER TO ASK YOU TO
CONTINUE THE FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS TO UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
AND INVEST TWENTY TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN Q. I THINK
THAT PROGRAM AND ALSO TO A
FUNDING ISSUE THE CAL GRANT
EQUITY FRAMEWORK THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. LINE FIFTY NINE. HI
DEBBIE RUSHER WITH JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YEARS ASKING FOR A
THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION FOR THE NEXT THAT
PROGRAM AND TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FOR FOSTER YOUTH
FUNDING FOR SEE IF YOU CAN YOU
SEE THAT MAKES CLEAR THAT ALL
FUNDS MUST BE USED FOR PROGRAMS
SPECIFICALLY TARGETING THIS
POPULATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
LINE. THIRTY EIGHT. EVEN CALLING
ON A FACULTY MEMBER AT CSU
STANISLAUS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION TO REPRESENTING YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IN YOUR LEADERSHIP
IN THE BUDGET PROCESS WERE IN
FIRM SUPPORT OF THE SENATE'S
BUDGET PRIORITIES FOR THIS ISSUE
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. WHY HE. GOOD
MORNING AMERICA TRY TO THE
PHILOSOPHER COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE FOR HOUSING VOUCHERS
QUESTION ABOUT HOW FOR THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL WOULD TAKE UP
WITH THE BACKLOG OF APPLICATIONS
APPROACHING THREE POINT FIVE
BILLION AND HISTORICAL RATE OF
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION PER YEAR
AND AFFECTS THE APPLICATION THE
PROPOSED FOUR BILLION OVER FOUR
YEARS WELCOME TO CONTINUE THE
PRACTICE OF METERING FACILITIES
RESOURCES IN A WAY THAT THE MOST
DETRIMENTAL TO THE ALREADY
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED SO
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL WHOSE STUDENTS
NEED AT LEAST EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS THE DRAFT. THROUGH THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND
THAT INCLUDES DEDICATED FUNDING
TO TAKE THE PHILIPPINES WHICH
WILL NOT OTHERWISE BE MET THANK
YOU THANK. YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. THANK
SEVENTY ONE. FROM THE OUT OF
CHILDREN NOW PART B. ISSUE THREE
SUPPORT COMMUNITY SCHOOLS-
SUPPORT EXPANDED LEARNING BUT
NEEDS SOME CHANGES FOR FUNDING I
REGARDING ISSUE SIX AND
EXPANSION OF T. K. WE NEED TO
PLAY WITH THE FUNDING ON THAT IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
AROUND EXPANDING ENROLLMENT
WHILE. SIMULTANEOUSLY HAVING
DECLINING ENROLLMENT AND FINALLY
WE WOULD LIKE TO OFFER A
PROPOSAL WHICH WILL INCLUDE
INVITING ON HOW TO EXPAND THE
STATE WON'T BE ENTERING
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL WITHIN A
BUDGET NEUTRAL WAY- ALLOWING TO
CERTIFICATES IN HEAD START AND
PRESCHOOL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR WE REACHED. TWELVE
TWENTY THIS WILL BE OUR LAST
CALL. FORTY LINE FOR EIGHT.
GOVERNOR ALLOCATE THAT THE ICC
YOU WE APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT
THE SENATE'S PROPOSED TWENTY
FIVE POINT NINE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN CALTRAIN
IMPROVEMENTS AND ARE HUGE AND WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT TO INTEGRATE
OUR INSTITUTIONS INTO THE ACCESS
PLATFORM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ON. THAT COMPLETES OUR
PUBLIC TESTIMONY AND LET ME
APOLOGIZE TO EVERYONE- THAT WAS
STILL ONLINE AND WISH TO EXPAND
ON THEIR COMMENTS. ARE WE WILL
TAKE YOUR COMMENTS IF YOU MADE
COMMENTS AND THEY WERE BRIEFING
ON EXPAND THEM OR IF YOU'RE
UNABLE TO SPEAK. AND YOU WISH TO
SUBMIT COMMENTS I WILL TAKE THEM
IN WRITING TO THE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE- OR TO
OUR WEBSITE BECAUSE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE STILL DID
HEAR FROM ROUGHLY THIRTY PEOPLE.
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY AND OFFICIAL HEARING
RECORD- SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE AND YOUR UNDERSTANDING
JUST GIVEN HOW LONG THIS HEARING
IS GONE. TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
THAT PATIENCE AND COOPERATION
WITH CONCLUDED THE AGENDA THE
SENATE BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEES. A SUBCOMMITTEE ONE
ON EDUCATION STANDS ADJOURNED.